there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody we got people in the
comments eating lemon pound cake i know
i was like fighting over who was first
it's independent it's another wednesday
night you know
zach says hey all i'm stoned lmao okay
yeah well you know we'll probably be
drunk soon but it'll take a while to get
there i think
went down to sign all the paperwork to
get the house put into escrow
yeah six grand
yeah but you get that that's gonna go
towards closing costs yeah it doesn't
vanish
uh so everything everything's going
through had the [ __ ] septic guys over
yeah
the guys came out and said pumped yeah
inspection i got to show that to va
um
probably next month like i think they
said it was on the 12th we probably have
it closed then
january 12th yeah
okay so we missed that date we missed
missed the window for the [ __ ]
tax-free year gotta pay taxes for whole
year property taxes that sucks 300 bucks
a month
yeah because see he's a veteran so he
doesn't have to like pay but we've not
gonna state yeah but you didn't get like
i didn't get it in time you didn't get
in time well we didn't no i didn't know
that's only for the complete year
well that would jump in in the middle of
the year that makes sense so i couldn't
get it closed in december
so the first year is going to be
more expensive than
normal because we'll still have to pay
the property all right though we're
going to get super chats from people
[Laughter]
so yeah don't count on that
christmas is coming up everybody's broke
including yeah it's broken this is this
is broke month
yeah december's always [ __ ] really
broke month man yeah
really broke yeah you got christmas and
all this [ __ ] happening at once
and it wasn't a big christmas present
day i got everybody i could
yeah
i got you know i got you some stuff and
i got the kitty some stuff i got you
like three things i got you some stuff
and it's not here yet
i got it here's friday i have three
things that i and i got two of them yeah
i got the two main ones it's just kind
of one that's that hasn't come out yeah
and then we set a present we sent a
present so
yeah and um
let's see what else we could do
gives presents to my drug dealers
[Laughter]
my drug dealers
let's see
we'll see what's going on i don't know
depends on how much [ __ ] money yeah
yeah yeah
but no once once once [ __ ] 20 22 is
over we'll be we'll be it'll it'll be
it'll be a lot easier
yeah and the energy costs were not high
in this house they were lower in this
house
yeah we got the first bill and we were
like oh that was
a nice surprise because it was cheaper
it's because it's all cinder block house
yeah like it's more energy efficient and
i think this house is newer than that
yeah it's newer
and it's not [ __ ] glass our last
house was basically made out of glass
and you just look well there was just
like just sucked all the [ __ ] air
conditioning out of it and this one's
got two uh two two central air
conditioning units outside
and it's still and they're big and it
still uses up less energy because they
don't have to run hard i guess
yeah i mean if you have two of them i
mean this house is bigger like a lot
bigger than our old house but it's not
twice the size i think it's 50 percent
bigger and it has two
ac units so like i said it and it
doesn't i i feel like the one at the old
house ran constantly yeah this one yeah
this one just runs and then when it gets
to the temperature it shuts off so it
doesn't even run hardly at night doesn't
seem like it and 72
or 73 feels awful cool in this house
compared to 72 or 73 in the other house
it's still fed hot fell hot at 72-73 i
mean honestly this office maybe because
i have really dark curtains and stuff
but this office is like [ __ ] freezing
all the time well you keep the doors
closed too i keep the doors closed i
keep the windows closed i don't want i
don't like sunlight coming here [ __ ]
that i like it i like it to be like a
cave but that's why i have my little
jacket back here because it's like
[ __ ] people are still piling in so
we're gonna chitchat for a little bit
until everybody shows up they're
starting to show up but
new information on the zodiac killer
yeah this is something like people asked
us about and uh i was like yeah we
should probably do a revisit i know it's
like a little bit late because i think
the new info
such as it is came out in october
um but we're going to like talk about
i'll probably like go i'll probably do
like um
i'm not going to do like in depth i'll
probably do like a summary of the
original crimes just kind of
quickly uh because we did a show about a
couple years back and uh then we'll get
into like the new [ __ ] joe drove by
sam's on the way back and [ __ ] picked
up sam's booze i got that [ __ ] sam's
sam's club
vodka you can get a big ass bottle of it
it tastes just like gray goose and it's
like 11 bucks
and then i got
i got some of that [ __ ] sam's tequila
and silver tequila and that should taste
just like [ __ ]
milagro silver i can't tell them apart
that's a fancy ass spot yeah it's got a
fancy ass bottle and everything that's
only 19 bucks
did i say thank you to mike no we're
mike's no super chat oh do you see us on
a super chat no it's just he just sent
us a super chat so thank you mike in
case i didn't say that right there man
is like
probably the second best
or maybe even the best silver tequila i
found in the united states it tastes
just like milagro silver
yeah i mean it's just like it it's sad
because i mean we don't get to sam's as
often as we used to because it's farther
so we usually just go because there's a
liquor store just like right up the
street next to the public so we usually
go to that one but it really is a lot
more uh cost efficient to get stuff from
sam's it's a lot cheaper yeah grandpa's
hammer says any presents for the day
drinkers at the biker bar
no [ __ ] go give your other girlfriend
like a wedding ring yeah this girlfriend
i kind of lost track of the other
girlfriend what happened to her i don't
know i hadn't been over there recently
it's um it's you know we've been doing
other things here
i think she's mostly late afternoon she
kind of comes and goes she's the late
afternoon late afternoon uh
worker there she works there oh okay
she's the bard she's like a bar back or
a bartender oh i didn't know that i
thought she was just like oh okay i see
she works here
uh bridgette says jenny i love it every
time you wear that necklace it's my
favorite yeah i love this necklace it's
hp lovecraft camp guy asked because i've
had a lot of people because i guess the
tentacles don't clue some people in
because they're like wait who is that
yeah it's hp lovecraft um no my other
girlfriend wants to meet you
i know i need to get down there one of
these days i said you don't like her
because i had cause i am i said yeah
she's got big old boobs she goes oh
goody oh goody
[Laughter]
well they just all those girls that work
there got big boobs just you gotta have
big boobs to work here
it's the lawn it's a biker bar yeah
and you have to be able to shut you and
they show them
because that's where the tips are coming
from they're not strippers no they're
going to give me tips if i go there
what's that no one's going to give me
tips yeah they would there so yeah they
would i don't worry i hope given there's
a bartender you'd make all kinds of
money
you know what a long time ago like when
i was 19 or 20 or something like that i
thought about going to bartending school
yeah i don't need you don't need to go
to school there it's just no i know but
that was one thing that i was thinking
about doing but then i kind of did a
couple of classes and i was like they're
just handing out beer and [ __ ]
pouring [ __ ] shots and stuff
straight shots yeah i can imagine
there's no mixed drinks right you're
gonna mix drink in there i think it
looks crazy
no they might do something like a sonic
are you like i asked for it to give a
sunrise they didn't they didn't have any
orange juice
they don't have that they don't matter
that is a biker bar
wow we don't care about orange juice
you don't have jars just nah
it's on the rocks you know it's okay so
you just gotta drink cuervo gold on the
rocks
they don't play that [ __ ]
yeah you just gotta drink it
straight or see any orange juice get a
sunrise and he's looking to do it no
you have to bring your own
you're gonna go to publix and bring in
some orange juice
sorry honey we ain't got no arms
that shit's fancy you need to go
down the road
that's just too fancy
that's hilarious yeah like they wouldn't
even have that yeah um too bad it's not
gonna be there much longer probably
they're gonna widen that road and it's
when they widen it it'll be right at the
doorstep which will take a part of the
damn
parking lot
and the guy who owns it he
it's been there forever but he had he's
only had it for about 10 years
um but it's always been like that it was
like that when he bought it there's just
like a biker bar you know
and um
he's thinking he's he's old and he's
thinking about checking out he says it's
going to be worth so much as soon as
they widen that road i'm gonna sell this
[ __ ] somebody said i'm gonna sell this
[ __ ] make all kinds of money
although it may not go down that way i
was thinking getting big tom to buy it
yeah well i don't know if he'd want
something way out here but let me run it
for him
[Laughter]
yeah time to run at a biker bar out here
[ __ ] eustis yeah they [ __ ] got
about a million cameras hanging from the
ceilings like walking into a damn
[ __ ] maximum security [ __ ] prison
or a bank you walk well i guess they
need it because you said that that there
was a lot of fights and [ __ ] yeah has
anybody ever been murdered there do you
ah probably
hmm
is anybody like buried out in the park
it's all night time in the weekends
though
that's when the people get murdered yeah
there's flights there every weekend
at night yeah that checks out yeah
yeah like i said i grew up in daytona
yeah then all those [ __ ] biker and
country bars and it's just like pretty
much every weekend you're gonna be a
fight there's gonna be like at least one
fight it was just like [ __ ] it's just
like roadhouse yeah it's like a road
exactly like that i need to get some if
i if i if i can get my hands on a gopro
i'd take some videos in there
yeah yeah i'll put them on the show
then i'll put them on my [ __ ]
motorcycle helmet try to get some candid
shots
because they might not they might not
they might over perform or underperform
if they know they're being filmed see
well yeah it's going to be candid
cameras should be candid yeah
yeah uh elsa says oh my god the last
time i was in a biker bar i was like 10.
my childhood best friend's mom was into
the hell's angels guys
yeah little kids walk in there
that's pretty funny yeah
where's my mommy yeah
mom's gonna walk in with little toddlers
and [ __ ]
and start i couldn't get
hey how you doing you know dad give me a
thud and they start drinking they got
the kid with them
it's just like normal people it's farms
you got some onion rings for little
cletus over here yeah
they have they have burritos
that's random microwave burritos
microwaves
yeah
like we don't got no fryer or nothing no
we just get some we get some microwave
burritos from 7-eleven i had a little
chinese woman walk in i had a little
chinese woman walk in and [ __ ] for
three dollars sell me some egg rolls
really yeah
would she come in with them like a
cigarette girl like back in the old days
like with the tray that's pretty awesome
and they were cold like the egg roll
yeah
chinese egg and she and she was and she
had a drink and she knew everybody in
there and she started settling egg rolls
and then she left
that's pretty awesome i've seen her
twice that's pretty awesome come in
there the egg rolls
see now
yeah i that's like a genius idea
honestly because [ __ ] man if i was like
[ __ ] pretty [ __ ] up in a bar and
somebody walked in with some egg rolls
[ __ ] yeah i'm eating a bunch of egg
rolls yeah it'd be even better if people
came in with a bunch of breakfast
burritos yeah i'd be all over that [ __ ]
well she has she's chinese and she has
the accent and everything so i guess
they expected her to have egg rolls
that's what she had
and she's having drinks [ __ ] talking
to everybody a little bitty thing
probably about 60. yeah he's older walks
in seoul's [ __ ] breed and it was
during the day
sweden at night it was during the day
that's pretty cool yeah so
all these regulars just walk in there
and just start selling [ __ ] to each
other that's pretty funny yeah maybe we
should do that yeah
uh zach says also isn't it weird to
think i'm young enough to be y'all's kid
no it's not weird because we have
friends that of that age too and it's
like every now and then we think of it
and i'm like yeah that is kind of weird
but i don't know we have friends who are
still in their teens
yeah
you know [ __ ] aaliyah and well um
john uh uh what's his name nick nick
yeah nick i think john nick i was
thinking one of the damn [ __ ] strand
durant
[Laughter]
nick is 21 though yeah his girlfriend
was they evidently kind of broke up
they're kind of on the outs i think she
was uh she just turned 18
or 19. i thought she just turned 19. she
turned 19. i can't remember yeah she's
stripping
yeah she's stripping now yeah well you
know that's how they do
and i said what are you [ __ ] hey you
got to make some [ __ ] money
rachel's i said what do you what are you
at rachel's fourth says why don't you
just become a [ __ ] cam girl make make
money for yourself you give them you
know you have to go anywhere you can
just do that from home and you get yeah
and then you're giving rachel's all your
[ __ ] money and then you don't have
all those creepers that rachel's like
trying to like [ __ ] fog up on you and
i realize that she doesn't really have
her own house that's right yeah
mike says tom in the future call your
big titty bar hangers
[Laughter]
low hangers love hello hackers yeah ilsa
says tom should sell peanuts there huh
if i sold anything in there i'd sell
some super [ __ ] redneck like pickled
hard-boiled eggs and mike says i don't
think i would buy peanuts from a dude
wearing a cock-sucking hat yeah
yeah you would
[Laughter]
[Music]
no i'd go in there with pickled eggs
they'd [ __ ] bite they probably sell
boiled peanuts although there's that
shit's everywhere that's yeah i was
gonna say that's that's kind of like
that market is cornered in this area
yeah pickled sausages
yeah you remember those things
[ __ ] ridiculous i think you sell
fried pickles
yeah fried pickles are delicious like
french fries fried dill pickles
so are we um see who's here do a little
roll call well i wanted to do a shout
out i don't think rob is here all right
our friend of the show rob levinson yeah
he saw this
but yeah i'm pretty sure because he sent
me a message earlier today and said oh i
sent you a movie
and i'm excited about this because i
actually i had put this in my
in the patreon poll
to do a movie retrospective on but it
didn't win and i was kind of like bummed
out because i wanted i've been wanted to
do a review on this look it's
identity
i saw this in the theater when it came
out and it's like i really really liked
it and i've seen it a couple times since
then so we'll definitely do a matinee on
this we'll do a matinee on it on sunday
i think cause you've never seen it right
no yeah i've seen it a couple times it's
good we'll check it out um but yeah so
thank you very much rob we're going to
talk about rob said he's here oh okay
there you go there he is there he is
okay you must have just got here then i
didn't see earlier or he didn't comment
earlier i guess maybe that's what it is
but yeah so i'm very excited about that
so i'm going to come here to newfound
from new york [ __ ] i'll take his ass
down to the biker bar he'll be oppo
he'll be appalled but he lives he lives
in new york but he's in the country
anyway so he probably they probably have
that kind of [ __ ] in new york
connor of iceland says i got a name for
the bar dude welcome to the vanilla
gorillas yes
home of honky kong
see i can see it i i can see a whole
like branding
i can do all the branding for that [ __ ]
that would be that would be [ __ ]
hilarious you should totally totally do
that yeah but now florida has a very fun
the florida in the south has a very
special
flavor of [ __ ] biker bar it's it's
its own thing
and there's motorcycles outside and then
there's all the hangers on and all the
old people all the retired people it's
all
it's not just motorcycles it's and
bikers it's
they're just kind of like
the centerpiece motorcycles and boobs
that's what it's about there you go
that's what you should call your bar
motorcycles and boobs yeah and you and i
can't take too much of it yeah i mean
i would i think i would like it yeah i
think i would like it better if they
actually played some decent music in
there but well the thing is is that if
you go down down there during the day
and you have [ __ ] jet x and and uh
people a little bit younger than us than
what they're playing mostly on the
jukebox because the jukebox has
everything it's online it's an online
jukebox you know i mean it's
it's it's computerized and i guess it
[ __ ] brings in things through the web
pretty much it's monetized though
but they'll give you free credits you
know the the the bartenders put free
credits on it a lot
but um
so a lot of the stuff that when the
crowd is a little bit our age or younger
it's 90s stuff
you know what i mean which mean okay
well a lot of it's like new metal or
metal
and um
this is better you know i mean it's
better than leonard skinner oh yeah but
still not did you go in there and i was
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
request [ __ ] you know stuff like
velvet underground or you know [ __ ]
classic [ __ ] you know okay i like that
yeah it's just depends on who's in there
yeah i'm not [ __ ] on this music
because it's old i just i don't like uh
that southern rock i get sick of
southern rock and cats
some of those dudes that's the only kind
of music they know i mean i like a lot
of [ __ ] from the 60s [ __ ] i like a lot
of stuff in the 50s to be honest with
you i like like a lot of rockabilly and
[ __ ] like that um you know so i wouldn't
have a problem with that [ __ ]
want to play garth brooks all the time
yeah
let's just get sick of that [ __ ] it's
leonard skinner
yeah it's like gosh
man i don't know
it's just so ubiquitous it seems like
you can just turn on a radio anytime and
hear that yeah somewhere right now our
radio station is playing sweet home
alabama yeah
and they're not conscious of it
it's totally normalized yeah totally
normalized you start playing something
that's
better then they're like what's what is
that who is that there you know who that
is you know
because they're just
narrow-minded they only know one thing
you know
i only know leonard skynyrd and i know
and i know garth brooks
they'll know all the country stuff
it's southern rock
breaking yeah is that gut is that
garbage
yeah i don't know
um but what another thing is funny
though
is that they'll listen to southern rock
not knowing that say like nazareth is
from [ __ ] wales or scotland or some
[ __ ]
or whatever
all those little [ __ ]
to us those countries are basically
foreigners they're not even states
they're like large counties you know i
think there's some counties in [ __ ]
texas billy ray cyrus yeah that's right
i knew i knew i knew it wasn't garth i
was like wait that's wrong but i
couldn't think of who it was that's
right miley cyrus is dead yeah not
nazarus is from scotland i think
were they
they sound like that it's fake southern
rock it does sound like it does they do
sound southern very much so i don't know
if they're trying to i kind of think
they are
i think they're kind of
pretending to be southern in the same
way
that
rolling stones sometimes tried to try to
sound southern
you know yeah with like wild horses and
stuff i like that song though yeah it's
good that's good i like the rolling
stones yeah they're good
their southern rock was okay but
i liked them just their regular rock a
bit better i thought
you know yeah that's true
it's just the sound that they wanted at
the time dj maniac says see goths know
all the music even if we don't listen to
it that's yeah and in a way i think
that's kind of how because gods are like
really into music like especially like
old school ones like us
um
you kind of
have an appreciation for music even if
you don't like it you even kind of like
know a lot of it remember when i said i
think we told the story before but one
time we were at mannequins
and there were these kind of like basic
[ __ ] karen type chicks like a bunch of
them there yeah and they were requesting
a bunch of songs because there's a bunch
of goths there so i think that they were
trying to i don't know if they were
trying to do this but i think that they
were maybe trying to like oh let's play
something that the gods won't like or
some [ __ ] like that so they were
requesting stuff like bgs and everything
yeah but yeah and i'm like [ __ ] yeah the
bee gees yeah yeah me and tom are out
there dancing we know all the words and
[ __ ] and i think they were kind of like
surprising like what the pgs are awesome
yeah all the gospels knew who the bg's
were and it was uh um disco inferno
wasn't it no it was um or was [ __ ] it
was uh more than a woman more than one
is
yeah
and it didn't have the effect that those
girls had i think those girls thought it
would break up the party yeah see yes
they definitely did come across like
having that sort of i'm like [ __ ] i
used to go to [ __ ] eye bar used to
have uh grits and gravy they used to on
tuesday nights and they moved to
thursday nights and that was all music
from like the 50s to the 70s so you'd
hear like elvis and then you'd hear like
abba or you'd hear the grease soundtrack
and it's like everybody knew all of
those [ __ ] songs yeah
the cheesier the better
yeah during the day you know what i mean
[ __ ] disco got burned out
but good disco was was the [ __ ] it was
yeah dj maniac points out disco inferno
eight by the bee gees oh yeah yeah
uh what was that i thought disco inferno
was earth wind and fire isn't it
earthquake of fire
i was thinking the one that was from
saturday night fever
uh that's um what do you call it um you
should be dancing yeah
oh yeah well they had a bunch of movies
they had a bunch of songs in that is it
you should be dancing
there was one called that or it was just
called dan this [ __ ] now i can't
remember you should be dancing yeah
i think that's just called dancing
dancing yeah isn't it like dancing yeah
i thought
that's what i thought they requested i
thought that might have been called
disco inferno but i think that's earth
winning fire in it
i think it's worth when yeah um
well dinner like bg's had that other
like uh what's the [ __ ]
you can tell by the way i'm with my mom
you can stay alive stand alone stay
alive yeah
i just i just thought of that song the
other day because when we were watching
rollerball and i said oh my god look how
staying alive like all the all the
collars on all the shirts were like it
was cracking me up
um badass domain says do god's like
michael jackson and his music he was
pretty freaky especially no um i'm not a
i wasn't a big fan i did like some of
his kind of poppier singles i like like
his older stuff i like some jackson five
um and i kind of liked i didn't buy the
album like i didn't buy i never bought a
jackson the one no i didn't either but
um
i liked billie jean and i liked like a
lot of his songs he came out like from
thriller and stuff i like those that's
just stuff you heard on the radio but
yeah not enough like i wouldn't turn it
off if it came on like i knew all the
words and stuff but i wouldn't have
bought it yeah that's all it was
um i guess he was a good he was good
though yeah yeah yeah he was good yeah
there's a lot of artists that i liked
when that was on the radio it wasn't
rare it was right it burned out you
weren't that one you wouldn't spend
money on that
yeah you could hear that for free just
turn on the radio and be on there right
um
i i saw that what was that mo walker i
saw the [ __ ] video i rented it from a
video store yeah and it was quite a good
little show i think it was called
moonwalker wouldn't it
was a serious like a little miniature
movie it was a scene yeah [ __ ] uh
music videos yeah
it was weird you know what i mean
because i was like what's he doing
running around these kids i had a
[ __ ] weird feeling about that back
then it was like dude it was very kind
of like i don't know
very mainstream
super super yeah so i think that i mean
particularly in the 80s like goths were
kind of like into more underground
underground stuff so it's like you heard
the michael jackson stuff and like some
of it was good and like i liked some pop
music back then too uh like i liked a
lot of new wave and a lot of stuff that
was on the radio but
you know honestly a lot of that stuff i
like it better now than i did at the
time it aged better like when i like
back then in the 80s like if holland
oates would have come on i'd have been
like oh please but like nowadays i'm
just like oh yeah man eater crank that
[ __ ] up you know what i've been heard in
a long time because i haven't heard it a
long time and i'm like i appreciate it
more now like i mean uh jackson's best
song was smooth criminal and i thought i
liked that song back then and they
didn't over he didn't play that one to
death yeah i think over playing was yeah
she's more than anything else the smooth
criminal was one of his better ones dj
maniac said i'm more of a prince fan oh
definitely yeah he was good yeah prince
is pretty awesome
yeah goths liked him though yeah even
though they didn't necessarily pile his
albums but we understood what he was
doing
yeah and honestly like like i said even
nowadays if you go to eyebar or
barbarellas they're calling it now and
they play prince pretty much everybody
dances that like all the gods and
everybody
um
yeah how about was better than jackson
well yeah uh yeah i don't know if
anybody would argue with you about it
well maybe some people would he wasn't
his poppy but he was better yeah he was
a better artist
uh marissa says how about cher
uh
cher was before our time that was like
something your mom would listen to i
kind of well i used to watch the sunny
and chair show when i was a kid
[Laughter]
i didn't mind it though i didn't mind
some of her stuff
but you know i again it's nothing that i
would have bought and i think i
appreciate it now more than i did back
then back like i said in the 80s like
all the stuff the 70s and 80s all the
stuff is on the radio you just got sick
of it best disco was the bee gees they
were the best i mean the bg's are pretty
[ __ ] awesome yeah i even liked the
bg's back then because my dad had some
other albums um
and i would say kind of like
although i think [ __ ]
my favorite one that was disco i would
say would be blondie and only half of it
was disco they did disco [ __ ] people who
want to admit it well they didn't start
out disgusting
and honestly when they did disco because
they've been playing cbg bees and [ __ ]
glasses disco as [ __ ] yeah when that
came out like all their older fans were
just kind of like [ __ ] this i'm out
they were good
blondie was good they made real good
disco and just good rock you know
good new wave
dermot says cindy lauper was amazing
yeah i agree she had a great voice uh
didn't want to go down that commercial
madonna route
yeah i i actually have a lot of respect
for cindy lauper because she and
honestly she seemed like she's still
going and she i'm pretty sure
um you know she looked good for a long
time too she was like
in her [ __ ] 50s and 60s and she was
still cute as hell so she was another
one cindy lauper was another one who was
very poppy and very popular in the 80s
that i really liked at the time and i
actually did buy some of her stuff yeah
um so
so it wasn't just oh you know i wasn't
trying to be like a hipster or anything
like that like i can only buy stuff
because like i said i like duran duran
and all that so
it's not like i was
deliberately trying to just buy stuff i
liked stuff that was on the radio
uh dj maniac says cindy lauper is still
fine as [ __ ] i thought she was i thought
she still looked really good
uh stop props says was listening to
vienna ultravox oh that's a great yeah
that's great uh best new wave synth pop
yeah ultravox are really really good
um to casey and the sunshine band
thelma houston don't leave me this way
yeah i remember uh that's a good song
actually the combinarts covered that i
had that single
but yeah i had i had a bunch of uh
45 singles and stuff like that i don't
know what happened to them though some
of them are still here but i don't i
don't know what happened to some of them
i think i sold off a bunch
um and then connor watson says i love
annie lennox yeah she is also amazing
she has an amazing voice
so yeah i mean
there was a lot of great [ __ ] back then
there was a heyday it was the heyday of
music really because that was our medium
that was our social medium oh
yeah that's a good way of putting it
yeah and now it's [ __ ] internet stuff
you know and online stuff but back in
those days it was bands
and
through music and clubs that was kind of
like the social media of the day
it's not as that much anymore the money
got sucked out of it
yeah it's like there's still lots of
good bands around obviously but
it's harder to make money there's so
many nowadays because it's so much
easier to put your stuff out
independently
that again it's just kind of like well
it's just like anything like with
authors filmmakers anything like that
it's like there's so much content out
there it's like really hard to kind of
rise to this none of them will ever be
true
rock stars
because there's too many of them and
rock stars were were a manufactured
thing from an industry you have having
to rise to the top and these huge tours
and
big names and radio and that's how you
became a rock star
an mtv back when it showed music videos
but that era is gone that market no
longer exists
so if you look at who's making money on
tours it was the rock stars of old who
are still alive you know [ __ ] yeah
and like their fans are their fans are
older
but they're still spending money and
they and have more money yeah so you
know they're gonna go see them even
though the tickets are a hundred dollars
or whatever yeah i mean [ __ ] and it's
hilarious
as i saw the turbo tour you know back in
the 80s as a [ __ ] jedis priest and to
think that [ __ ] judas priest would
still be touring and that rob halford
still sounded like god i would have
never believed that but that [ __ ] is
still
making a lot of money touring and
he's very grateful to the fans he says
we are only doing this because you guys
we got the best fans you know and
because the people come to see him
and uh
no new artist is really going to top
what's happening with these old guys
you know they can go anywhere at any
time and draw huge crowds some of them
not all of them
like i don't know if metallica got
together they'd probably [ __ ] still
pack a [ __ ]
huge [ __ ] arena
the thing about the older bands too is
that now that we have the internet in a
way they've kind of benefited from that
too because
not all the people that are going to see
them are like old farts um some of them
are like second and third generation
fans
whose parents were into it and they got
into it yeah or they discovered them
online and didn't care that it was like
an older band and they're like oh
they're still around i'm gonna go see
them so it's like
so so they're getting like a lot more
you know stuff from the past like you
know uh you know people that are younger
that weren't even alive when they were
originally around yeah that discovered
them later on
yeah
and it's funny just like the one guys
they're they're
some of them are frozen in time like
iron maiden i love iron maiden but iron
maiden is no longer innovative their
[ __ ] last really good album was maybe
like somewhere in time or something and
they kind of stayed like that and then
the albums just kind of
that same [ __ ] sound
most of it sucked uh one of the newer
ones is called book of souls it sounded
good
but i'm listening to it and i was like
you know what this sounds like 1987 1989
there's no real innovation
just
they haven't gone to full anvil yet
though okay well that's good all right
man just that same base
[Music]
the same [ __ ] bass
line you know
but that's what works that's what their
fans want i guess that's what they mean
yeah that's what i mean it's not like
they're gonna like you know veer off
into like some other new territory and
everybody's like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] we wanna like you know and [ __ ] i i
you know i like bruce dickinson and all
you know i [ __ ] not [ __ ] about it
he had some [ __ ] badass albums you
know peace of mind
but i gotta say the [ __ ]
paul diana on those first two albums i
think we're [ __ ]
that
badass probably the best it was it was
like two different bands i guess you
really couldn't compare them but that
killers album was which is album number
two is [ __ ] badass
paul diana sounds [ __ ] great on that
dj maniac says metallica is still a
thing and they charge a grand a ticket
now oh yeah yeah [ __ ] that noise yeah
no they got people that would pay that
well i know they do but
i don't even have a grand much less a
grand to piss away on that
i'm just saying
um yeah see dave mustaine's [ __ ]
cooked up ass his [ __ ] face is all
[ __ ] swollen like a [ __ ] i
don't know what that dude's been doing
to himself yeah no thanks although i
like [ __ ] mega death and dave mustang
they were they were good
he was he was he was alex jones before
there was alex jones man he was in on
into all that [ __ ] rest in peace album
and stuff i think i think aj listened to
that band
probably probably
zach says uh favorite film score
who favorite film score
zach
suspiria no conan the barbarian
i mean oh that wasn't that was easier
than i thought it would be yeah conan
the barber [ __ ] i have the suspiria
score on i'll i'll listen to that just
like not even with the movie just the
music is that good conan and barbarian
was [ __ ] epic
classical [ __ ]
vagneri i mean there are so many good
ones yeah there are so many good ones
now if i had to [ __ ] just
boil it down to one soundtrack
would be conan
just the first movie
i was thinking i guess because i just
did a review um his name was basil what
basil was the name of the [ __ ] guy
who
basil
oh it's like a greek last name but it
starts with a p but i can't think of it
right now
yeah something he wrote all the music
and everything he's [ __ ] great i
think it was him um i guess because i
was just thinking of because i just did
a review of
ravenous from 1999 and i remember i
don't know if i'd buy that score but i
kind of like that score just because
it's so [ __ ] weird you know what i
mean that movie is like a weird movie
and but weird but awesome
and i love that the score was just kind
of like oh you want even more weird okay
here you go that's like [ __ ] damon l
barn from
blur and uh gorillas that did that and
it was like and another dude too but i
can't remember says yeah man [ __ ]
[ __ ] conan is badass it is you could
just sit back and listen to
look the original soundtrack for conan
is in mono it's not in stereo but one of
those nordic um or maybe like italian uh
symphonies
re-released the entire thing they did it
live that's on youtube in [ __ ] stereo
in in hd [ __ ] high quality sound
that's that's the one to listen to i
think it was it might have been an
italian
or a spanish
[ __ ] orchestra and theirs is even
better than
than the movie album than the movie
soundtrack really good
yeah dermot says uh the exorcist and
hereditary great music soundtracks yep i
agree dj maniac says oh i totally bought
the ravenous score a lot of people did
like in the horror community i feel like
the ravenous score is kind of like
a big thing just because it's so odd
like it's almost kind of like this weird
i don't want to say it's like bluegrass
but it's just like this really weird i
don't know it's very strange but but
like kind of awesome
joe nash's thief which was done by
tangerine dream honestly like any score
that was done by tangerine dream is good
is good i i'm like i like any of that
kind of stuff hey connor i forgot to
tell you i'm mexican now
yeah
again uh louis hernandez let's let's see
the paperwork yeah louis hernandez said
that i'm now an honorary mexican and uh
and i can go to mexico anytime i want
without any papers can i keep it because
this is a mexican in california
declaring this so i can go to mexico at
any time no visa
no passport nothing
nope no
i don't have to go through i don't have
to go through any of the [ __ ] checks
can i can i be an honorary citizen of
another country yeah honorary i i'm not
i'm not i'm a citizen of mexico i'm i'm
an honorary member of the mexican race
oh okay yeah that's that's high that's
that's way up there wow way up there
uh dj maniac also points out yeah all
john carpenter scores yeah obviously
yeah um yeah yeah well i like his stuff
because it's like really simple but it's
really like impactful yeah and as soon
as you hear a score you know that you
know that that's him like he has a
really recognizable
uh score oscar says jenny did you used
to hate oasis and blur back when you
lived in the uk
um
i'm not a big fan of o-waste i don't
hate them
um but i'm not a huge fan but honestly
some of the stuff like blur pulp
um i wouldn't buy it but i'm kind of
into it i like pulp actually quite a lot
like i bought like some of their songs
never i don't think i ever bought a
whole album
but i think i bought a couple blur
singles too
like i think i liked boys and girls and
i liked so i liked some of that stuff
oasis just sounded like kind of like the
beatles to me so i was just kind of like
well if i want to listen to that i'll
just listen to the beatles thanks but
what khan says i'm mexican because i
make my own tortillas
i gotta make chicharrones i think you
said chicharrones
yeah
brian says that his wife is mexican
we're proud to have you
brian is saying that he is proud to have
me as a mexican because his wife is
mexican
so that's something else man
quite a that's that that's that's some
badass authority i like that
my wife's mexican so i can make you
mexican that's pretty cool sure it's
like the transitive property
yeah oh man
[Laughter]
rob points out sorcerer we still need to
do that [ __ ] movie one of these days
um
that is actually on my list it has been
for a very long time badass domain says
pulp is from my hometown of sheffield
i actually really like pulp uh i really
liked common people i really liked uh
actually you know what's funny is that
what's that one song they did i think
it's called what is it called something
disco 2000 or something like that and um
nick cave did a cover of that like a
live cover
and i liked both versions actually
uh oscar says oasis are superior to the
beatles ooh that's some fighting words
right there i don't mind oasis i'm not
i'm not [ __ ] on them i'm just they
it's just i guess like when i heard them
i'm just kind of like ah that's good but
i kind of wish i was listening to the
beatles that's all
um
kanavatsan says jenny can be mexican as
well she needs to make salsa
i'm sure i can figure it out yeah kyle
was he he shared a um a link to
something on my facebook group
called tom shitty movies
um and it's some kind of a movie's
coming out talking about it's kind of
like the great
it's a mexican movie it's about mexican
paranormal stuff tell me again say it
drop it again in the comment section
just to remind me what it was it was
it's a movie coming out
it looked good and it's about all the
[ __ ] horrific [ __ ] that happens in
mexico
it's like a documentary okay it looked
good yeah
kind of like paranormal stuff and i
don't know
probably true crime
sorry i'm just laughing because you
can't see it but pookie is sitting right
there
in a pile of all the toys that auntie
ilsa sent her for halloween yeah she's
in a pile there's a big pile of little
like little orange mousies and like
little stuff and she's just like sitting
over there there in the pile it's just
very funny yeah you got all your toys
bulky oh
okay it's called mexico bamberro which
means barbarian or barbaric mexico
that's how it translates it's a movie
and it looked good okay if somebody
sends it to me we'll review it
well is there is it on like any kind of
streaming thing where we can i think it
was a
no i don't remember i think it was a dvd
or a blu-ray that was coming up or or
something was gonna be released it was
gonna be like a streaming thing maybe
and they're talking about uh tom york
doing the uh
doing the score for the new suspiria
yeah actually i really did quite like
that
um and then no need for me to said the
remake of suspiria i enjoyed i did too
and actually really surprised me
um because i think like back when they
were when it was rumored like a few
years before it came out i was kind of
like man i just don't see how you can
win with that it's like you can't make
it like the old one because dario
argento had such a
particular
visual style that if you try to make it
like that it's just gonna seem like
ripping it off and it'll be pointless
but if you make it completely different
then it won't actually be suspiria
because so much of suspiria is wrapped
up in what it looks like
but
i have to say that they really did kind
of pull it off they did something
completely different with it went like
the opposite way with the tone but it
totally worked it's like a completely
different movie but they still took
enough of the original story so i think
they did a good job with it i don't like
it as much as the original still but i
think it's like a a pretty damn great
movie all on its own
you know okay kyle says it's a movie
it's here on amazon
it's on amazon we're at least here in
mexico it's called mexico barbados
mexico
is probably how they pronounce it
barbaric mexico
and it looked like a kind of like a
um
i don't want a compendium what do you
call it like the greatest hits or
whatever [ __ ] weird cases and [ __ ] it
may have been a series
but he says it's a movie so it must be
one movie they look good man they cover
up it look good that sounds like
something that would be like right up my
head yeah they had [ __ ] dia de los
muertos kind of motif on it look good
some girl the [ __ ] makeup kind of
looked like that mexican goth girl that
dressed up like [ __ ]
santa
muerte
oscar says mexico from 2008 to 2010 was
worse than the middle east in terms of
savagery
yeah i heard that there's all that
narcos narco [ __ ] operations going on
brian also says tom and jenny if you
want to see something really disturbing
watch the netflix series called 1994
about the murder presidential candidate
coliseum on netflix okay well we'll look
that up god says it's an anthology of
eight stories horror stories
oh brian said he said uh yeah it was on
shutter for a while oh i didn't see it
maybe it was in like the other category
because sometimes i forget like to look
in the series or the documentary
category it's still there if somebody
wants to check and see if it's still
there get back with us and drop it on
you on shutter they just put up another
documentary that's called uh what's it
called hail to the deadites and it's all
about evil dead fandom oh yeah and i was
like oh [ __ ] i might need to watch that
i just thought like when i was scrolling
when i was watching house of wax last
night i was just kind of like oh man i'm
gonna have to i'm gonna have to watch
that
there's so much [ __ ] on i've gotten
really behind like on the new [ __ ] they
posted on shutter because i was watching
some other things but mexico city has an
awesome goth scene we need to get down
there and check it out
well yeah like i said i've talked about
buy some clothes i've talked about uh
voltaire yeah uh him going down there
because i think he has a house or an
apartment or his girlfriend does uh in
mexico city even though i think she's
japanese but um but they go down there
every now and then they do like a bunch
of goth [ __ ] down there well terrace
have cuban though go down there
go down there just to buy some [ __ ]
badass [ __ ] handmade clothing
yeah and i'm sure it's like and he said
it's like not and it's not expensive
yeah and he's like and there's tons of
[ __ ] like cool bars and [ __ ] like
that down there too
i mean you know you bro you probably
[ __ ] drive there how long would it
take us to drive to mexico
it's not worth it it's better to just
drive because you could fly you could
probably fly there a round trip for 400
bucks
yeah maybe it's just a lot easier and
you get there and you take cabs you used
to take cabs all over brazil i can make
myself understood in spanish i can fake
spanish
it's fake spanish well after you get
after you drink when you speak
portuguese after you drink you can kind
of slowly make the adjustment the just
the articles are different the the nouns
and the noun
most of the nouns all the verbs and
[ __ ] verb conjugation is the same
it's just you know yeah it's it's it's
fairly similar it's fairly similar i can
understand the thing is
is that i can understand almost
all spanish being spoken they can't
understand me when i'm speaking
portuguese
because portuguese has a much bigger
vocabulary it's got spanish style words
and french style words and italian style
words all in the same language
and spanish just has spanish stuff
well mexican spanish has its own
dialects they have their own slangs
their own accents kind of different
sound and rhythm to how they speak
it takes a while to make that mental
adjustment
you know and then it's good if you've
got it'd be good if you have a friend
who's fluent
because uh you can practice with them
it's a lot more you relax more
especially if you drink it
i learned to speak portuguese drunk as a
teenager
well you had a tutor i had a tutor but i
was afraid to speak
you know tell me about it after about a
year or nine months
i understood what all my friends were
saying
but i couldn't speak to them in
portuguese all right because you're
afraid they would make fun of you it's
just not uncomfortable to speak in a
foreign language okay
and then i would speak they understood
english so i just speak to them in
english
and they'd speak to me in portuguese
because we they were bilingual yeah and
at that point i was but i couldn't speak
portuguese i just understood it
i got rip roaring drunk and [ __ ] i
was [ __ ] trying i told one guy says
look man tell him this and that because
i was trying to talk to a brazilian guy
who didn't speak portuguese and he's
like man [ __ ] you you speak it tell him
you you sp you you understand portuguese
speak you tell them i'm sick of
translating for you
cause i was just drunk i just started
speaking portuguese
i just told you
and then they started laughing they were
rolling he speaks portuguese he now
speaks portuguese because it happened in
a single [ __ ] night
yeah i went from not speaking portuguese
to speak important but you knew how you
were just like afraid to i could yeah
yeah well i just yeah it's it's a
barrier to get across like again
yeah it's a mental barrier i understood
what was being said yeah well that's
that's the first thing that i can get
through the lessons with my tutor
but i wasn't comfortable for with
conversation
yeah
and it was like a mental barrier until i
was just [ __ ] loaded and then
i was mad and drunk and the barrier went
away so i just started yelling and a lot
of it was cussing
[Laughter]
and then once and once he's talking back
and i was like oh okay then it started
rolling and then i spoke portuguese
after that
now oscar says tom attempting portuguese
is probably hilarious no he actually he
can't actually speak yeah he is fluent
in portuguese yeah um i've heard him
talking to
people over uh on the phone and over the
thing uh to in brazil and [ __ ] like that
portuguese
you know it's been a long time since i
speak in it but it comes back quickly
you know
i grew up speaking it
you know my
my first girlfriends were brazilians
yeah you know so yeah well you lived in
brazil i lived in brazil for [ __ ]
years so
just
camp guys said wish i was bilingual i
don't have the self-discipline at my age
i honestly it's like
i don't know like i said i don't have
time anymore i've i've tried like i took
four or five years of french so
i kind of know a little bit of that
um i took a little bit of italian
uh
and i took like a little bit of you know
i learned some welsh like when i was
over there
but brian says that uh mexico barbaria
mexico
is not on shutter anymore but it's on
voodoo for free
okay yeah we'll have to wait i don't
even think when do we have the voodoo
app i don't think we do we have the 2b
app
but it might be on 2b as well because a
lot of times if something's on voodoo
for free then it's usually on 2b for
free as well
dermot says if you can speak one latin
language then it helps understand the
other ones yeah because definitely like
i said i took conjugation yeah i took um
many years of french in school so when i
started
like trying to learn italian i was just
like oh this word must mean that and
this word must because a lot of the
words are like kind of similar and i
just did that you heard me speaking and
that was just cold
i have to be around brazilians
for a few hours before it starts to
[ __ ]
come back because i don't speak it every
day when i
for a long time i used to dream in
portuguese
which that's really cool because
i'm dreaming and brazilian characters in
my dreams are speaking to me and their
[ __ ] is [ __ ] ultra fluid
you know their their portuguese was
better than mine but how the hell did i
tr how the hell did i dream
how did the hell did i dream the
dialogue that's better than my waking
dialogue the the uh the subconscious
mind is extremely [ __ ] powerful it is
the characters in my dreams have [ __ ]
perfect
perfect portuguese like they were born
and raised there
and [ __ ] with vocabularies better
than mine and and i could wake up and
remember exactly what they said
so kanavatsan says it's very rare to see
americans in mexico trying to speak
spanish yeah but how we view it is that
you respect our culture if you tried
it's like that never i kind of feel like
every country has that yeah and it's
just kind of like as long as you're
making an effort
and i get it like because like if i went
to france and tried to speak french
because i do know a little bit of french
but i would be horrified to like try to
speak french to people even though i
kind of know what that what i'm saying
but i'm like oh they're going gonna make
fun of me because i'm gonna sound really
bad i'm gonna [ __ ] it up but i do think
that i mean well it's just like if
somebody came here and was like trying
and couldn't really speak english that
well but they were trying to speak
english at least like you would at least
be like encouraging you would think it's
the same thing when i was living in
egypt and in the sinai peninsula if
[ __ ] if you're hanging out doing
business with any kind of arabs
you want to use as much
arabic
terminology and phrases as you possibly
can
and it's a totally different culture
you want to stay away from phrasing
things in secular terms
everything has to be kind of put in
religious terms
um which you know
modern americans aren't grazed like that
people from the south understand that
but everything is you know god willing
and you know if god smiles upon us on
this day it's just [ __ ] like that
everything is phrased
in religion because that's their
they feel comfortable with that yeah
they feel very comfortable that
everything and it's um
it's getting high like when you say god
damn we said that's almost like a
religious statement but we just say
without thinking or like you know like
or my personal favorite jesus [ __ ]
christ jesus christ yeah yeah
i say that those are all religious terms
religious terms really you know i mean
but the air you know uh islam is a lot
more pervasive throughout their language
or their culture
and for them it's very
it it's comforting and very flowery and
everything is embellished that way
everything is
everything is explained
in in kind of [ __ ] religious terms
and uh they like that and if you do that
then they're
you get a much better response from them
they don't like the cold logic and
i guess you could say greco-roman style
reason and [ __ ] secularism and no no
they don't really like that
it's what we would call magical thinking
they like that yeah which i understand
it i understand the world that they come
from the environment that they're in
they can't trust laws and leadership
everything is spiritual they trust that
because their institutions are
untrustworthy
camp guy says why does jesus's middle
name start with the letter h see i
always kind of wondered about that too
well see i always i always like to come
up with a well like
normally like when i get mad my first
thing is like jesus [ __ ] christ but i
also have used jesus tap dancing christ
uh jesus christ rocket christ i'm just
like you know what i like to think of
something to put like in the middle you
know what i mean but uh yeah i don't i
don't know so i don't usually use
anything with age
uh oscar says you know what else is rare
mexicans in america trying to speak
english they don't want or care to learn
the language anymore i kind of disagree
it depends on where you are that's true
it'll probably depend on where you are
uh here in florida
we we have lots of uh central americans
they're probably not from mexico they're
probably more from like places like
guadalajara and honduras and stuff
matter of fact i did
when i went to to go [ __ ] do all the
housework we did a lot of that it's like
i was back it was like i was in central
america i think they're from honduras
all right the family that runs that
business
and uh it's a mixture of spanish and
english because you know
spanglish that's just the way it is this
is florida used to be part of the
spanish empire i told about the whole
story and the seminoles and everything
even though i gave kind of a shortened
version of the seminole conflict some
people got upset that i was rewriting
history
the way i described the first sim way i
described the deal with the seminoles
rolling
over and being mercenaries for britain
that was only the first seminole war
there were two others and then [ __ ]
king osceola and all that
but i don't want to get into that
okay
the seminoles were badasses they never
surrendered they were patriots
the hardcore crew
the hardcore faction of the seminoles
they had to be deported out of the
united states into indian territory
which was now and would be where
oklahoma was
so they ended up in the united states
eventually anyway
you know but it was a different time
although i don't disagree with him
no man if i my homeland
got bought and then from bought by one
[ __ ] european power and then sold to
the united states under a different name
and then they came in says you guys
aren't in charge because
we bought this land because
because
our shit's stronger than yours i'd be
like no i'm fighting for my country you
know
some of them rolled there because you
know there was a lot of admixture and
people breeding in together not all the
people were full-blooded indians and
it was just it was a lot more
complicated than they'd have you believe
in these
television series
you know well like i said they got to
distill stuff down to like
or a chapter in a book or whatever so i
get it right i mean they don't tell you
that a lot of the [ __ ] seminals were
black
okay they had black seminals that they
had white seminoles too or seminoles
that were
a mixture
you know some of the seminoles were
irish
and well those guys a lot of times says
yeah we'll be in america because they
had a heritage of that but the ones that
were like real hardcore like no man
we're [ __ ] we're not gonna be in the
united america
um anyway i kind of lost what track i
was talking about i've been you know
[Laughter]
yeah somebody says why is uh why is it
jesus h christ and tj madix says the h
is for hitler jesus hitler christ may i
thought it was like for uh humperdinck
jesus humperdinck christ that's a good
one actually sorry i was thinking of
like the engelbert humperdinck uh
bit that eddie azar did
you awake poke yeah she's still over
there sleeping
jesus jesus hippie christ elsa says i
was on an amtrak train from new york
city to south carolina stuck next to an
older lady eating fried chicken and
talking on her phone saying praise the
lord and lord have mercy in every
sentence for hours
yeah yeah i've known some southern
people religious virtue signaling nobody
in my family is like that yeah um
my family were all kind of heathens yeah
but
with maybe a little bit lip service
played paid although i have to say that
when i was growing up
like there was lip service paid to
religion but i was never taken to church
by any of my my aunt and uncle took me
to church one time when i was staying
with my cousins that was the only time i
ever went other than like for funerals
and [ __ ] i never went otherwise
and like i said most of the kids that i
knew that i played with
um
didn't really go either or if they did
they didn't really talk about it it
wasn't really a big thing but i know
that other parts of the south they did
have that but i said mostly that's just
virtue signaling well obviously but i
mean the thing about it is that i think
because i grew up in
maybe in central florida which has a lot
of people because everybody i knew was
from somewhere else
i was one of the very few kids in my
school that was actually from florida
that had actually been born here and my
parents weren't born here i was but my
parents weren't my dad was born in
tennessee and my mom was born in
baltimore maryland
um
you know and they moved down here like
in the 50s or whatever but it's it's
just kind of like
i don't know so so i guess maybe because
it's central florida there was a lot of
you know
people that coming here from other
places
that it wasn't really you know this kind
of backwood like florida cracker type of
type of [ __ ] that you see like in some
kind of smaller towns where they don't
get a lot of
i think you know people like grow and i
don't think that's i mean
that's pretty much gone like nowadays
maybe unless it's like a really really
small place yeah and they would they
would be irrelevant
there wouldn't be enough of them to
matter
whoa is that the other vodka oh that's
the new vodka oh okay why is it real
strong yeah i just thought it would well
i didn't know if it was the i didn't
really stir it it'll probably below okay
oh it's good when it looks whenever you
s whenever you saw
at least in central parts of mississippi
whenever you saw some woman do [ __ ]
virtue signaling the praise of the lord
[ __ ] constantly over and over again
i remember looking i would be kids i was
a kid when i'd see [ __ ] like that i'd
look around and other adults would be
like going oh [ __ ]
you know what i mean yeah i kind of
maybe like country people too yes i mean
that's kind of what i felt like i knew
some people like some people my family
that were like kind of rednecky and
stuff and they were just like
they yeah oh yeah praise the lord yeah
a lot of times a lot of times what the
deal was
is that that was kind of like a what
they call a femme cell which is a
[ __ ] a female in cell a femme cell
or it was quite the opposite that was
like the town hall
and she's [ __ ] trying to [ __ ]
virtue signal how [ __ ] great she is
to try to like
unhealthy yourself
going to church
but she's unknown and she's trying to
unhaulify
but a lot of times she was not only the
hoe she was the one that was fooling
around on her husband with the preacher
well yeah that kind con
well as i've i i
have long uh as i've as i've long
suspected well not even suspected i know
this is true the more you go on and on
about there's a problem somewhere yeah i
mean the more you're going on and on
about i'm crusading against pornography
they've got a [ __ ]
basement full of the [ __ ] okay like
nasty ass [ __ ] because why would they
care otherwise what other people are
doing exactly you know what i mean i
mean it's different if you're
campaigning against something that's
actually like harmful like human
trafficking or something but it's like
if it's something that's not hurting
anybody else
um you know like porn not child porn
obviously but there's a little bit of
overlap that with that too because
sometimes you get like preachers and
[ __ ] like that and they're just like all
about like we have to condemn this that
and the other and that's that always
makes me kind of suspicious yeah i mean
but i even as
as a kid in [ __ ] central mississippi
visiting my dad seeing that [ __ ]
people didn't
people were skeptical
when they saw all that even they were
like uh okay we know what's going on we
know what's going on because they knew
and grew up with the with the people
that were that were like that
and there's a backstory always a
backstory
so
i mean why people disregarded that [ __ ]
yeah in the real [ __ ] south they
disregarded that [ __ ]
most of mississippi and me growing up
it was wild
they were wild they weren't
they weren't [ __ ] t-totaling they
drank
uh they weren't really uptight they were
they were [ __ ] kind of sexually
liberated
it's not
all that religion was a backlash it's
just the surface that's not the way they
really were
no they were wild
mike barrett says ted bundy blamed it
all in pornography yeah yeah that's a
good one ted i know he's dead good uh
elsa says i was reading about the duggar
family oh yeah they're [ __ ] special i
used to spite watch that show
and now the oldest son is convicted of
child porn ah you know what that family
are you know apologies because there's a
lot of them i don't even remember how
many there are but
them are freakazoids and i kind of feel
like i feel bad for however many
children there are because that's got to
be like [ __ ] up growing up in that
environment but i wouldn't be surprised
if like more than one of them comes up
with like some child porn wasn't that
the one with
wasn't he um molesting his sister like
one of them was
i can't even remember now
it was one of those weird like
fundamentalist families were they
quiverful
do you guys know what quiverful is like
they're these like real fundamentalist
christians and they think that you have
to have as many kids as possible so they
have like 19 kids and [ __ ] yeah
they were i don't think they had 19.
that was that other show but
dj mannix is list fun tom ross femme
cell research this week yeah
you didn't know that one that should
exist
what's your female asl
pookie is now
she's got like the
the squishy dracula that elsa said that
has a feather on his butt and she's like
she has a feather in her paw and she's
like licking it
yeah greenspark said yes he was
molesting several of his sisters oh uh
that josh it's josh right josh duggar
yeah
yeah the family with 19 or 20 kids okay
so it was 19 kids i was right about that
i get them confused with
that other weird family that was on
not duck dynasty they're another weird
family but the one that had like all
this [ __ ] children
because i know there was kind of like a
bunch of shows where they're like look
at these weirdos with all these [ __ ]
kids
like it's like the modern day freak show
really i mean you can't really look away
you know
it's like i don't really want it but
it's like it's like here comes honey boo
boo
with like those
big huge fat people
and uh
i don't know something to be said for
that you could take over they say
[ __ ] demographically mormons are good
now mormons what do you call them but
again the amish are going to take over
because they're having a [ __ ] tonight
i'll believe that one night they're
having a [ __ ] ton of kids yeah but the
problem is you can have as many kids as
you want but how many of them are going
to like do what you want probably not
that many they'll just have that monitor
do you like do what your
what your parents want you to do no so
that's not gonna work out
so i kind of feel like any of these
people that are kind of like oh we need
to have like as many children as
possible like quiver full and stuff like
that i'm like yeah but that's not gonna
work out the way you think because at
least a certain percentage of your
children maybe the majority percentage
are gonna rebel against that [ __ ] i
think they [ __ ] that's just the nature
of the beast i think they uh
somebody can check it and drop in the
comments section if i remember correctly
they were saying that at the present
rate as long as it's the democrat that
the birth rate continues along the
steady lines the way it is now the same
[ __ ] growth rate that i think is
within a hundred years mormons are not
more uh [ __ ] the amish would be a
majority
in about a hundred years
well as i said if everything just
clicked along but things don't it
doesn't work
like i said yeah the amish could have
more kids than anybody demographically
but how many of those kids are going to
stay there stay amish
probably not that many
so
yeah hard to say just saying i'm well it
wouldn't be a majority they don't have a
phone not in this day i don't know what
the loss rate is though
i don't either offhand but i'm just
saying that i'm i'm assuming that it's
probably not going to be here's ordeal
they don't have to stay on those things
to call themselves amish
you have a situation where they leave
the amish [ __ ] compounds
or amish land but then still call
themselves amish
there's a lot of that kind of yeah but i
kind of feel like hormones that do the
same thing they're looking really mormon
about them well that's what i mean then
then you're mormon and name only you're
not really a mormon in any like
meaningful sense of the word anymore if
you're just calling yourself that but
you don't do any like mormon [ __ ] well
then that that would that would go
across many of these so-called religious
[ __ ] identities
well honestly
honestly even in the united states um
you know and way more in europe yeah
even people that identify like if you
had if you asked me like oh what
religion oh i'm marginally christian or
whatever do they like identify as that
do they think about it no
yeah um they just truly christian yeah
they just say that if somebody asks them
but they don't like really do anything
about it
but everyone's just kind of like the
thing is though is that even you
who's an atheist
if you take you to the middle east you
would see the differences between you
and a middle eastern person they would
say that you were a cultural christian
they would say that okay well yeah
because things that you do yeah from
that and i'm not denying that yeah
because that's the that's the framework
i grew up in yeah um just because i
don't believe in any of it that doesn't
mean that i didn't grow up with those
you know what i think are mythologies or
those stories it's just
that's what i mean to me it's just like
any kind of cultural thing whatever
whatever country you grow up in it it's
not just religion it's just like you
have a particular set of
you know mores you have a particular set
of cultural you know touchstones and
that's just what we have here and a lot
of them are
judeo-christian-based you know even
though they've become secularized in
this day and age so i'm not gonna like
deny that even though i don't believe
any of those things are true
but i still grew up in that environment
sure
i'm a mythicist
i'm a christian mythicist i know it's
all mythology i don't really care
i just kind of pick and choose as i want
and [ __ ] i like mythology i think i
do as well i think mythology is more
powerful than truth
it can be sure oh yeah because faith
and the power of the mind is [ __ ]
pretty intense there were times where
had i known the truth or believed the
truth i wouldn't have made it
but because i believed in untruths
untruths or lies i actually made it it
helped me get through it
that's military [ __ ] and [ __ ] other
[ __ ] outside of that sometimes believing
in fantasy is [ __ ] great that's
that's exactly what you need
because the because the truth might be
my opposite my tragedy is that i can't
i can't i don't understand the power of
mythology i do but i but i can't
buy into it like i can say to myself
yeah i'm gonna believe this that like
whatever magical thinking kind of thing
but deep down i really don't believe it
so it's like i understand that it's
powerful something it just doesn't work
for me it's a disadvantage uh in some
ways it is yeah but i wouldn't i
wouldn't have it any other way though
but i i admit that it is a disadvantage
in some in some ways but i but i can't
be any different that's just the way i
am
and
i've always been that way like as long
as i can remember so it's just i don't
know it's it's the way my brain works so
i i can't really sometimes i can't
really do anything about it believing in
[ __ ] i guess you could say like a
magical
like believing in a [ __ ] kind of a
magical system can keep you keep your
spirits high you know i know keep you
going well and obviously that's like the
majority of you because that's i mean
throughout human history that's kind of
like what we've had going for and in a
way like i'm not gonna say it makes me
sad that i can't do that it doesn't make
me sad
but i am aware that i can't do that that
i don't have access it just doesn't work
for me it just doesn't no good
survival's good just train well yeah hey
i'm still here it's in here for now
we'll put you under pressure we'll see
what happens we'll take all hope away
nah i'm just [ __ ] ready
how are you gonna do that i don't know
put you in a box for a while
it has to be a transformative spirit
experience kind of like ol honestly i'm
not really that bothered you're [ __ ]
transformative i'm too old to give a
[ __ ] yesterday i think you might be
too old to give a [ __ ] it's something
that has to happen to it i was being
like well uh this is about par for the
course all right well there's a certain
amount of truth in that [ __ ] movie
that we saw what was it uh one about the
[ __ ] dude that had the mask and was
fighting the [ __ ] rebellion what was
uh
uh what they had the government was
bringing like a [ __ ]
was it a plague
and um v for vendetta
oh remember how he captured that girl i
haven't seen that in a long time but
yeah he captured a girl and and he and
made he made her think that she'd been
captured by the secret police yeah yeah
i remember and broke her down and then
and then [ __ ]
let her find these little messages and
in time
he was able to convert her over to
[ __ ] his way of thinking by because
he put her in basically a virtual
reality to see what it was like to to to
uh
to be in the hands of a [ __ ] an enemy
that hates you and is trying to oppress
you you know that it was
like a first person virtual reality
training session but really if you were
to like look at it from legalistic terms
he tortured her yeah he tortured her and
like i said i get that um it is a
different reality
honestly like i said i mean at this
point
i'm just like
i'm too old i don't care about stuff
that much anymore and i'm too stubborn
to give other people the satisfaction of
getting one over on me yeah so
i don't know how well you would just
kill yourself to escape defeat probably
okay all right
that's it probably back to the death i
mean i'll take the [ __ ] with me
i mean i probably would too because i
because i have like you know a lot of
rage issues so probably if somebody's
like pissing me off i would just
probably like try to tear their head off
it's like because i'm like well if they
kill me i don't really care about that
because that you know i've gotten to
that point i'm just i'm old and i don't
care so okay
that's one of the nice things about
getting old you really don't care about
anything anymore
i don't fold anymore i mean i don't feel
i don't really feel old either
but i don't feel old i feel young
i feel young but i know that my time is
near it doesn't matter as much and i say
well 20 30 years is nothing
i at the most i have 30 years left
average i have 20. i know that that
doesn't that doesn't take long 20 goes
by i mean it's still kind of a long time
though yeah tell me when you think about
it look how fast 10 went by well because
sometimes i think about it and i'm like
gosh i could live another 30 years maybe
because how old i'm almost four i'm
almost 50.
and i was like i could live another 30
years maybe another maybe actually maybe
another 40 years because i have
relatives that lived into their 90s yeah
um i'm like god that seems like a
[ __ ] it's possible but then you have
to wonder yourself what would your life
be like then what were your hopefully
the uh the the your physical condition
will [ __ ] be good i'm hoping that
before i get to that point they'll
figure out some kind of technology where
you can pop your brain out and put it in
like a cyborg body because i'm gonna be
first in line for that [ __ ] yeah i'm
gonna be personalized yeah take my take
my consciousness now pop it in like
probably more likely that they somehow
download your content that's cool too
i'm also down with that yeah that that
doesn't alarm me at all i download it
into a cyborg like i said just
right here i'm looking on my internet
yeah
pop it in there that'd be cool that's
what those extra terrestrials are
that's cool yeah actually if i i could
get kidnapped by aliens that'd be cool
too the flying triangles yeah
you got billions of people in that damn
triangle you want to like take me up
there and like we're going to all be
like part of one weird like
collective kind of like internet
consciousness i'm down i don't want to
be with you [ __ ] i'm down i don't want
this collective [ __ ] well if
everyone was cool i don't want to be i
don't i wouldn't want to be collective
with some of the [ __ ] down here
but you know you can have an ability to
wall yourself off i can already i can
already do that because
you're like star trek and like the borg
where everyone is a small part of the
whole
and it's all just a collective
consciousness which that's kind of like
what the internet is but imagine if you
couldn't escape it imagine if everyone
could tell you what what to do in the
internet well they're trying to do that
now it's just that imagine if you could
were physically
tied to the internet
like the borg were from star trek she
never saw star trek yeah i did you
didn't see star trek next generation
yeah i did
you never watch that series with me i
didn't watch it with you i saw it though
i thought you said you need to see it
with the board yeah
i know what that is okay
i i did i had like a i had like a 38
years before i even met you okay so all
kinds of stuff happened i thought you
said you'd never seen star no i saw that
i don't know if i saw the whole series
but i saw like i saw most of it
over the over the years we're the borg
now
and they don't really like it they're
trying to stop that because we're
[ __ ] threatening their power
but everyone is the board
and it's not turning out the way they
thought it would turn out
nothing ever does no pro tip for young
people out there nothing ever nothing
ever turns out the way you think it's
gonna turn out right sometimes that's
good but when the internet makes
everyone the board whoever just relax
just like let it roll whoever is rich
and powerful now will probably not be
rich and powerful in the future and
you're gonna try to stop that boohoo
yeah
my broke ass doesn't care so uh yeah so
they were talking about the duggars
still
so the sun okay so are we talking about
the child molester son well
allegedly the only child molester son
i'd be surprised if there weren't more
than one but um
yeah he has seven kids i feel bad for
them yeah me too
um
badass domains this would you guys do a
show on the crystal skulls oh that'd
actually be a good deal we haven't done
that never done it holy [ __ ] okay i'm
gonna write that down because that's
actually a good idea
um and i don't think we've ever done
that now that i'm thinking about it khan
says tom i got a question if elon musk
chip would make your body live longer
but you still age would you do it uh
yeah i would do it
um because uh you it's your natural
instinct is to cling to as much life as
you possibly can
and if you live longer but your body
continues to age there's a chance where
later if you live long enough you can
either switch bodies to a younger one or
switch into a [ __ ] robotic body that
doesn't age or switch into the internet
where you live forever in the unit not
forever here's the thing
people are going well you'll be immortal
in the internet no you wouldn't
you would live as long as the internet
and the planet earth would live and
eventually the sun goes supernova and
burns everything up
eventually let's say okay we escaped the
earth now we're out in space
it would only be life extension
maybe you would live
a thousand years ten thousand twenty
thousand a million two million
maybe
okay
you cannot live forever
eventually something will destroy you
statistically you can't and honestly
would you want to
uh yeah maybe you would depends on i
mean i guess it would depend i actually
wouldn't mind living forever
um as long as you weren't like in pain
and you could like think of some cool
[ __ ] to do well if you were in this
internet you wouldn't have a physical i
mean i can think of cool [ __ ] to do like
my whole life like i said i'm never
going to live long enough to do all the
cool [ __ ] i want to then you have
religious people what about going to
heaven and this yeah you would
eventually go to heaven because you
could not
have eternal life
forever statistically something would
happen to you star would go supernova
you whatever computer system supporting
you would be destroyed you'd get hit by
something a big old meteor it would just
be life extension it would not be
immortality immortality in the physical
realm
is impossible because eventually the
universe itself starts to break down
as it spreads out it gets cooler more
low energy and you're talking about
something called deep time
where there aren't even any numbers to
express the amount of time that's passed
you know beyond trillions of years you
know beyond trillions of trillions
we have a hard time wrapping our mind
around deep time
because we just not designed to live
that long well we didn't evolve we
didn't evolve our brains didn't evolve
to have to uh to kind of understand that
if i made you biologically immortal
you would still die you would just die
later
something would happen you'd have a
motorcycle accident car wreck you'd die
in a fire eventually you get hit by a
meteor eventually eventually the planet
burns up
yeah
so zack says i love how this is now a
sidetrack show
yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] i mean yeah
go to the restroom it's it's a side
track it's really really hard to like
keep him on topic
i have to say
um you know
uh
yeah elsa says oh i want you guys to
live forever yeah i mean
i i would want to but under certain
conditions you know what i mean because
i wouldn't get bored i don't really
i know some people are like oh everyone
i love would die i'm like yeah but that
happens anyway
um
honestly like i i could live my whole
entire life just i could live forever
just like reading [ __ ]
books that i wanted to read because
there's so many but you know what i mean
uh mike barrett says jenny is full of
rage i am uh i i know you can't see that
but i'm i keep it under wraps like
pretty well
uh so you know
but there's that it'll probably like
bust out at some point
and yeah so what okay so where are we
who wants to live forever yeah like i
said under certain conditions i might
want to but i don't know you
honestly even if you thought you wanted
to like after two 300 years you'd be
like oh my god i'm so [ __ ] bored just
[ __ ] kill me you know what i mean
um yeah andrea smith if everyone was
immortal there would be no need for kids
and we'd be stuck with these [ __ ] faces
forever yeah so you know
i don't i don't know if i'd i'd like
that so much
uh yeah it also says so about that
zodiac killer
i know i can't believe it it's like
[ __ ] an hour and a half i didn't
expect because normally like i said i
don't mind like half an hour 45 minutes
tops of
just you know regular shooting the [ __ ]
while we're getting like
a little bit buzzed we're getting kind
of like
up to speed and everything but holy [ __ ]
like sometimes
sometimes he gets oh that was another
thing i had to mention
the
movie review the movie retrospective
that's going up on friday for it's um
house of wax the 1953 vincent price
movie which is what everybody voted for
for on the patreon poll i had to do that
one again by myself because
uh tom didn't tell me that he had to go
someplace today and we had to record it
so i was like well [ __ ] it i'm just
gonna record it by myself so i did
um but you know you didn't really watch
it anyway i was i i could i had a hard
time keeping [ __ ] like yeah that
didn't keep my attention that's a good
ass movie
it's been some [ __ ] price yeah i wish
i could have watched it in 3d though but
we'll get into that
um i'll get into another thing so so
yeah so the one that's going up on
friday or tomorrow if you're a patron
is just me so hopefully that's not
too disappointing to anybody you know
but at least i stayed on topic ooh
[Music]
that was a burn all right can i talk
about the [ __ ] zodiac good job
it's time to do it time to do the zodiac
yeah you think it's been an hour and a
half you know that right
it's all right
all right
mike says it's like when i was a young
teen i used to treat porn mags like time
once you turn the page it's yesterday's
boobs
well you gotta save the [ __ ] yeah you
don't want to like blow the wad on like
all of the [ __ ] and like it's you know
information overload yeah okay you gotta
like savor it i get that i get that
you know greenspark says jenny never
disappoints oh thank you very much
um
sad says tom did you check the jane the
games i told you about
what the games
play with shows oh oh is assad asking me
that yeah no i haven't checked them yet
dude i've been so busy with this house
[ __ ]
i'll get remind me again remind me again
remind me in about
if you if you remember remind me in
about a month once all this shit's
closed and then i'll go check it out
yeah we're like under a lot of stuff
we're under a lot of [ __ ] stress
because of
the house closing and it's like oh my
god we're not gonna have any money for
like a lot of uncertainty oh my god
it's gonna be all right though i know
but because it's only gonna be a
[ __ ] i'm trying to stay on top
it's really only gonna be a couple
hundred bucks more than would have been
have we been paying rent but at least
we're gonna be getting equity in this
house yeah and then [ __ ] five years
down the road 10 years down the road you
sell it if you wanted to we'll see how
it goes
thing is though i think five and 10
years we'd probably be happy to be here
yeah greenspun said did you buy the
house yeah it's um he went today
yeah um so we're supposed to be closing
on it what mid next month right yeah mid
next month yeah
so yeah all the inspections i got
inspections i had to do had the septic
done yeah the guy came today and did the
septic tank so they had that done ten
dollars came into the game thank you
camp guys
best live podcast ever really appreciate
it appreciate it even though we haven't
even talked about yeah and she's [ __ ]
bitching at me with that i'm just not
staying on top i'm not bitching zach
zach's gay ass gotta jump in and [ __ ]
try to straighten my ass out
zach you need your ass straightened out
you're a crooked ass
zach why did i start the side track show
tom
so you could talk about whatever you
wanted that [ __ ] look man i could say i
didn't get it all right
i love you sex zach says so at what
point does tom get his add diagnosis
maybe that's your problem no that's not
what it it it's not good no i don't
think that's your problem you've got a
lot of problems but that's
probably not one of them i don't know
though you might have add no
no because i can focus real well when i
start getting into a damn trance type of
deal i'll get ready
i can really get into a subject thank
you mike yeah
getting some super chats
all right so you know some [ __ ] about
zodiac killer right well i know the case
well now we're just going to do like a
brief summary because we did a show
about this back in september of 2018.
so i'm just going to do like a brief
summary of the zodiac case and then we
will talk about the stuff that has
occurred
in the last
year and a half let's say because one of
the ciphers got solved spoiler alert um
allegedly and
somebody came out uh and said that they
had figured out who it was uh
we're not really sure how
legit this is but we'll get into it it's
it's a pretty interesting story
so in case you have been living under a
rock or if you're not from the united
states and you're up on our true crime
[ __ ] the zodiac killer
probably maybe not even probably i feel
like he's
kind of the
og
of unsolved
serial killers this is the big fish the
one that got away
and i remember when we were doing the
show about uh that [ __ ] joseph
d'angelo douche like the golden state
killer
um and i was like oh they caught him
like for through dna like for you know
the family
uh you know the dna databases and i was
like i kind of wish they would do the
zodiac killer next
and that
that's not exactly how it ended up i
don't i don't know if like the dude that
they are saying is the zodiac now i
don't know if that's really him they
haven't like confirmed it
um but i don't know we'll see how it
goes because it's not dna i'm going to
say that right now
let me before you get into this
a couple days back we had somebody
saying that well there are serial
killers that
did that were not sexual in nature no
the zodiac as far as i know didn't rape
anybody
but these killings were sexual in nature
you have to understand how psychology
works he focused more on the females
stabbing the females um
uh trying to impress cops with his
prowess
this is a [ __ ] who
has
feelings of inadequacy and who is trying
to overcompensate for the for this
inadequacy by violence
the reason why he didn't rape any of
these women is probably because it might
have been something along the lines of
deangelo
where he was
not well endowed
and was ashamed of it so he didn't want
to rape anybody because that would be
like vulnerability
this is an overcompensation thing
all true serial killers it's sexual in
nature
if you kill more than three this is the
fbi talk and not me you kill more than
three and it is not sexual in nature
you're just a mass murderer
honestly
yeah and when we say sexual we don't
mean that it necessarily has to be that
there has to be rape involved or that
there has to be we're just talking about
there's a sexual motive in the sense
that they somehow feel
some kind of an inadequacy an inadequacy
issue now this is only true i will say
some of them this is only true of male
serial killers not women uh female
serial killers generally not always
generally
uh largely
have a different
uh spin on things female serial killers
in general um are more
practically based yeah or there are more
based around killing
uh you know it's more like a like a
nurse type of thing where it's like i'm
gonna kill old people or babies or
something like that or they're killing
people for profit for practical reasons
and that and and i would say that that's
probably not wouldn't be classified as a
serial killer it's very i don't think i
i don't even know but i've been
classified more as a mass murderer i
can't think of a female serial killer
that had what we would term a sexual
motive in the same way that a male would
i really can't think of one maybe there
is even eileen warnos would not i
wouldn't call her a serial killer mass
murderer
yeah because even her motives not sexual
in nature it was more like a revenge or
a rage
type of issue um i don't really think
she was i don't know
i don't know her i didn't know her but
i don't think she was like getting off
on it in the way that a male serial
killer would like the whole the the
pathology is different a serial killer
is a sexual identity
rosemary west somebody brought up maybe
maybe maybe that might be an exception
but
she was also part of a serial killer
couple yeah which is a different dynamic
and usually when you see that dynamic
it's always a couple
there was a canadian couple that would
do that they would get into yeah that
was a homologa yeah yeah kind of they
would accuse innocent women of stealing
from them and a bdsm murder thing oh
maybe that's a different one that i'm
thinking and she yeah and she's in
prison but going to get out she didn't
get that much time
um
that was that was carla hamocha right i
think i thought her name might have been
carla her her boyfriend did most of it
she did with a knife they carried knives
that might have been i think we did well
we did uh we did a killer couples show
we've done a couple of them because we
usually do them on valentine's day
because we're [ __ ] up like that
but
yeah
usually if you have any kind of woman
that
comes across
as as a serial killer as defined by the
fbi and i believe that their psychology
is correct in the diagnosis
if you find a woman like that there's a
man involved usually almost always isn't
that interesting yeah it's uh it's a
couple
the female is bisexual
there's kind of a
a power bdsm kind of [ __ ]
dynamic to it
where uh the and
surviving victims say that
the female offender tends to be more
vicious than the male offender i think
what ends up happening in those cases um
and somebody brought up uh you know uh
ian brady and myra hindley as well and
this is also true in their situation
whereas where like when a woman who if
to her own devices i kind of feel like
myra hindley as you know monstrous as
she was
you know and maybe rosemary west if they
hadn't hooked up with those dudes they
might not have killed anybody
um
i think what ends up happening is that
they want to impress those dudes yeah so
they have to go overboard yeah i mean
it's like look at the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that i can i'll do worse [ __ ] than you
yeah like to show that i'm worthy of you
so what you have is you have a
a straight male a bisexual female she's
in love with him he's a serial killer
together this synergy builds up and she
ends up kind of being worse than him
yeah but she's trying to impress him
yeah that's why but it's it's it's it
that's it's very rare to find that
particular
combination you know
but uh women if left on their own
devices don't generally do that if they
do become serial killers like i said
it'll manifest itself in different ways
it's usually
um they'll kill people they know like
it'll be munch house and by proxy for
example like they'll they'll smother
their children uh so they'll get
attention
or or they'll kill people per people for
practical reasons like they'll bump off
you know people that live in you know
like somebody like um
you know
like belgonis or somebody like that that
killed people that moved into their just
to get their money you know what i'm
saying women old women that pretending
they're pretending to [ __ ] um be an
adoption agency for single young females
they get the baby the money and they
throw the baby away yeah that yeah that
kind of thing that woman she killed what
hundreds of them
yeah that was the baby in the town yeah
yeah i was gonna i was i actually wanted
to do a show about her one of these yeah
because we haven't i think i put her in
the patreon poll a couple times what was
her name [ __ ] i can't remember it right
now
i can see her face but i can't think of
her name but yeah so
we yeah we were gonna do some [ __ ] like
that where well like i said that's as
[ __ ] up and cold as it sounds that's a
practical reason they were just trying
to get money yeah um females tend to be
poisoners uh they tend to be
angels of mercy quote unquote uh you
know women that work as nurses or nurse
maids or something sick people they kill
sick people or babies start killing
people that weren't gonna die yeah yeah
it's like an addiction
yeah so there's so it's so it's a
completely different dynamic where i
feel like serial killers male serial
killers
um
generally
get some kind of whether it's
you know literal in the sense that they
rape their victims or jerk off on them
like btk did or
they just get off on
the power
over making people suffer
um it's a completely different
uh pathology i've i think like i said
that nothing nothing um you know is
across the board there's always
exceptions
but in general that's kind of how it
shakes out
you don't really see the same motives uh
between this between male and female
serial killers so zodiac even though
you could say i mean he was definitely a
serial killer because he killed at least
five people
um
but
his thing it was almost kind of like
like you said from a distance
so he didn't other than the other than
the lake berryessa attack where he'd
stabbed them but he usually like shot
people just like through their windows
or whatever but i kind of feel like like
you said
even though it doesn't on the surface
seem like a sexual motive
it probably was a sexual motive in the
sense that he probably felt inadequate
in some way that
that made him act out in that sense
you know what i mean yeah so that's
probably that's what you're getting at
right yeah good old micro deangelo
micro deangelo
i love you know what i love
that somebody said that like the one of
the victims was like oh my god he had
like the tiniest dick ever and i'm not
like [ __ ] on people look if you have
a small penis it's like that's not your
fault it's like you were just born that
way and that sucks but it's like i think
it's funny because he's a [ __ ] rapist
and a serial killer i think that's
awesome that somebody said that and told
everybody told the world
for any listeners who are not long-term
listeners years back when we did the
d'angelo case
i called it that that dude was a cop
and it turns out when they caught him he
was a cop
yeah we did a show about the original
night stalker before d'angelo was caught
before he was identified and then we
revisited it like after he was caught to
do what you to do what he did to execute
those missions you had to be very
confident with carrying a gun in public
at night you had to be confident about
the tactical situations outside of house
at night you had to know about police
response this was a [ __ ] that
had good confidence
in
the situation
and i was like he's either a [ __ ]
some kind of a
soldier a commando or a cop
he was a cop i had a feeling he was a
cop
use cop
well i think cop is i mean among serial
killers i think trucker is number one
right yeah truckers up there cops up
there forest rangers up there
as i'm not saying that like you know all
cops are serial killers i'm just saying
that among serial killers who were
employed
they are disproportionately represented
in
i think truck drivers was number one
which makes sense because you can just
drive around and kill people and well no
it's not natural selection if you're a
serial killer and you are a truck driver
you will be you will be around longer
yeah because they're not gonna catch you
there yeah and you're and you're just
like killing people that don't have any
uh any connection to you and if you have
those predilections becoming a [ __ ]
truck driver is in your advantage so
that profession would attract them but
it'd be the same for police too although
yeah i think part of it is that serial
killers want to have power and respect
so they
take towards a profession that's why you
see so many that are cops or military or
cop adjacent yeah uh people that are in
like btk he wasn't a cop he wanted to be
a cop but he was in those kind of like
they they crave power over people
so you see them kind of seeking those
types of those types of professions
oh she woke up finally she was over
there like
yeah they want they want to be like and
btk in particular
um
he just had this real like
just kind of this kind of petty yeah
he's a dick you know your grass is too
long so he wanted to be he was very you
know he he just wanted to like nitpick
about everybody's he wanted to like
[ __ ] rule over everything yeah so i
kind of feel like that's pretty common
in a lot of serial killers mindsets they
want to be in authority over somebody
because they feel like nothing
themselves i guess
so they have to
well they have to make themselves feel
like the [ __ ] man
by
telling people their grass is too long
yeah or their dog pooped on somebody's
lawn or something you know what i mean
if you don't have a lot of power you're
gonna take what little power you can get
and you're gonna like [ __ ] run with
it which he did obviously
so yeah so uh all right so the zodiac um
you know if you don't know obviously
killed at least five people he claimed
as many as 37.
uh this was northern california in 1968
1969
uh and probably became famous uh
largely because
one he was never caught two his [ __ ] was
like super random and three
uh he had a thing where he would taunt
the police with his letters and stuff
and he had all these
codes like he'd send all these codes uh
one of which was only recently
uh figured out so you know some of them
were figured out like pretty immediately
but it took a long time for some of the
others to be figured out now look man
[ __ ]
uh oscar pettis is in there going tom
what you're saying is muddled logic it's
not what i'm saying
it's what the fbi profilers are saying
don't be [ __ ] putting the [ __ ] on me
i end i read the [ __ ] books
written by the best
the dude who [ __ ] made that system
for the profiling of the fbi okay
you got to read the books
it's a sexual motive
whether they have sex with them or not
it has to do with psychology there's a
difference between a sec there's a
difference between
a [ __ ]
serial killer and a mass murderer a
serial killer is just a mat is nothing
more than a serial rapist they just
happen to be killing the victim whether
they have sex with that victim or not
it's a personality type
sorry it's some like well it's a
particular fetish that they yeah right
pretty much and this is
it's like a sexual orientation that they
have
all right and there's a bunch of [ __ ]
things that if you see the interviews
with the captured ones that are alive
they all kind of have that pathological
liar type [ __ ] personality to them
when they're constantly talking and what
comes out of them is
[ __ ] there's nothing to them they're
they're not
they're not very impressive people well
which is probably why they're doing it
yeah which is why they're doing it
because they want to be somebody yeah
but they don't have the means to become
somebody other than right that way right
just because you kill a bunch of people
that doesn't make you a serial killer
nothing no well now there is a thing and
somebody pointed this out in the
comments uh serial killers there there
is the kind of thing where because mass
murderer that's usually somebody that
takes out a whole bunch of people like
in one event whereas serial killers
usually like they kill somebody and then
there's like a rest period yeah where
they kind of like build back up to it
and then do it again yeah so there is
that factor as well
uh so yeah um well it's like a
refractory period though yeah yeah
[ __ ] where you get laid and you gotta
rest before you just screw another chick
like that
okay well yeah that's yes that's the
same thing yeah it's a sight
a [ __ ] serial killer always has this
weird fantasy world that is sexual or
pseudosexual about this like i said uh
sophie sent me that book about btk
and reading that is really instructive
about serial killer psychology
yeah you know in general even though
they're not all like that but
reading that i like that yeah and like
reading that in a way it kind of made me
feel like good because i'm like reading
this going wow this dude is like [ __ ]
what the hell like i don't
like who [ __ ] thinks like this a
serial killer that's you yeah i was like
well i guess i know i'm not a serial
killer because this dude is like [ __ ]
insane right like some of the stuff that
he thinks killing a bunch of people one
after the other if that if that makes
you a serial killer then the punisher
would be a serial killer and that's not
what the punisher was
that's not what a mob [ __ ] hit man
yeah well yeah it's a different intent
yeah the intent the the whole psychology
behind it i kind of feel like when you
talk about serial killers you're talking
about people whose killing is not for
lack of a better word practical right uh
a mob
killer i mean as much as we might not
like it they're bumping off people who
are inconvenient
to them uh it's there's no personal
feelings about it they don't they maybe
don't even know the dude there's like
blood sometimes yeah it's like look
somebody told me like he's gonna talk
and we need to get rid of him so we just
gotta like take care of the problem he's
not enjoying it necessarily or maybe he
is but he's not usually they're not yeah
it's not like it's not the same thing as
like a serial kill it's like relishing
it and then later on we'll have
fantasies about it and they have these
elaborate like uh fantasies constructed
about the scenario about killing these
people no [ __ ] if you go back and you
look at mob killings at least with the
italian mob and any decent mob even the
mexican mob they're trying to silence
somebody
usually or they're trying to stop
somebody from taking business from them
so these are all very practical
things it's just
akin to warfare
but with the italian mob jimmy hoffa
type stuff
your friend is being squeezed by the
authorities if he [ __ ] ends up good
taking a conviction and going or they
end up indicting him and they start
threatening with a bunch of [ __ ] jail
time
he's going to start talking and instead
of him going to jail for [ __ ] 10
years he's going to roll on all of us
and we will all have to go to jail for
10 or 20 30 years and we got mortgages
to pay kids to take care of yeah we
[ __ ] love joey joey's good but
joey's probably gonna roll
we grew up with him um
we're gonna have to [ __ ] get rid of
joey because if [ __ ] joey rolls
then the whole [ __ ] organization is
going to go down
how do we do this
we're going to tell joey's going to be
okay
let's go [ __ ] um
see what joey's doing we're gonna go out
to a [ __ ] restaurant
we're gonna have a good [ __ ] dinner
and we're gonna discuss what we're gonna
do with joey we're gonna say joey you're
gonna have to go back to [ __ ] the old
country and hide out until this [ __ ]
blows over that's what we're going to
tell joey
but in reality what we're going to do is
when joey's after we after the dinner
and [ __ ] everything's all good when
we're taking joey back home you're going
to do what you got to do
and
joey's going to bite it and then we're
gonna put joey in the trunk of a [ __ ]
car that we have we have this old car
and then after and we're gonna put joey
in the trunk of that car we're gonna
drive it down to the [ __ ] scrap yard
and our friend luigi's gonna put the
[ __ ] car into the [ __ ]
crusher we're gonna crush it we're gonna
melt it and it's gonna end up in a big
[ __ ] ingot and we're not gonna know
what happened to joey
that's what
that's that's like i said that's a
practical moment it's just practical
[ __ ] they're not someone's in their way
right someone's going to blab right
so we need to take that risk out most of
the mob hits and the italians the
classic italian scene
most of them were done quietly between
france
well i mean why do you think when i
wrote my faceless villain series i was
just kind of like look i'm
all the murderers that were suspected to
be
mob hits
or
uh you know political assassinations or
something like that i didn't include
those because it's like even if they
never technically caught the person that
did it you know you still know what the
motive was
it wasn't like a weird
serial killer like no motive it wasn't
that type it wasn't mysterious now gangs
went to war in that period they would
attack other gangs and do things in
retribution that was not quite this that
was not quite the same thing
all right they were sending messages
don't [ __ ] with us or hey you wronged us
so we got even but that's still a
practical motive that was still
practical right but a lot of it
half of it at least
was friends killing friends to silence
that dude because he didn't want to go
to jail
and it wasn't really done out of hate
and they usually didn't [ __ ]
torture the guy or anything they were
making he didn't even know it was coming
they just pop
pop well yeah they tried to make it as
painless
as possible yeah and they were like oh
poor joey they didn't enjoy it yeah they
were just doing it because it was a
necessity right right right for them
it's okay yeah joey you're going to do
but yeah hey
we got to do what we got to do
that's that's
that's the rules you know that's
and like i said technically that's not
serial killing because that's just
taking out like a threat like you're
threatening our whole existence it's
been going on for thousands of years
and they didn't make the person suffer
or they didn't yeah no so it's so it's
not really the same thing right zach
says that uh
that one of uh deangelo you did in 2018
was the first episode of yours i found
and this uh so i've been watching you
guys for four years holy crap thank you
seriously we've been doing this four
years we started in 2000 summer of 2016.
been that long so it's been more than
five years we've been doing the show
yeah i can't believe it isn't that
[ __ ] crazy yeah i can't buzz i can't
believe it
when i was looking at i was like wait
what number episode are we on 278.
we've almost done 300 [ __ ] episodes
no wonder i'm running out of ideas for
[ __ ] to do
uh elsa says tom did you read mind
hunters i don't think he did um
i saw like i saw the show but i haven't
i haven't read that either
um yeah and straw dogs 78 says first
original night stalker episode was first
13 o'clock episode i ever listened to
and i'm not even really into serial
killers yeah that was like a really fun
way to do because that was
before the dude had been caught and i
remember like we were really excited
like when he got caught i'm like holy
crap this is like the first [ __ ]
thing like this whole dna like genealogy
thing they finally caught a [ __ ]
and i think i even said at the end when
are they gonna catch the zodiac
and
i'm still not convinced they've caught
the zodiac i gotta say but um you know
in past shots tom has hair
and you're in a different house or rim
yeah that was our old house we had we
moved a couple months ago
so
that was our old house but you know this
is a nice house and he had hair but he
shaved it all off so that happened
sometimes
time moves on time moves on
rebecca says hi folks late for the party
zodiac revisit is going to be
interesting i'll hush and listen because
i'm late honestly you didn't miss
anything because we have been yapping
about
you know how tom does
honestly it's been almost two hours and
he won't even like let me get onto the
zodiac stuff so we barely gotten
up at this point
this might be the longest digression
that we've ever done maybe not i don't
know it's hard to say
danny rolling ghostface says the summer
wind haunting episode was my first
episode of introduction to this channel
um
we should probably do another one like
the guy that
um i know a guy that's done
thank you mike thank you again
um
what's the matter poke she's out there
calling she's not coming she's like no
she's like no i want you guys to come
out here she wants me to go out there
and play
yeah
i wonder if she's gonna start like
running up and down
she woke me up at like three o'clock
this morning i don't know what the [ __ ]
she was doing but i i woke up and i
heard
and then i went out in the hall and she
was like standing there like what i
didn't i didn't do anything rebecca's
just jumping and rebecca you haven't
missed anything we're just starting to
talk about that's what i just told her i
was like dude it's been like almost two
hours and we even barely started on the
zodiac actually okay
so can i yeah go ahead thank you
let's see how long this lasts
all right so
so zodiac now
even though i'm gonna say this is
spoiler alert even though 2021
people came out and i know it was like
big in the media and stuff we know who
the zodiac killer is
that's not confirmed okay
so
let's not get too excited but i'm going
to get into that later on
not confirmed though not no dna no
nothing like that
so zodiac kills at least five people
that they know probably more
uh claim to have killed 37 like in all
the letters and [ __ ] like that like i
said he's probably famous
mostly because the zodiac i mean that's
a pretty rad name you gotta admit
and he kept taunting the police with
these coded [ __ ] letters that
everybody was like trying to figure out
and he kept sending letters until 1974
even though the murders that he's that
are attributed to him stopped in 1969.
he might have done some ones after that
nobody really knows
now uh the five people that had killed
there were four separate attacks
first confirmed incident uh december
20th 1968 17 year old david faraday 16
year old girlfriend betty lou jensen
they were uh near their car on a uh they
kind of like gone parking like like you
did back in the day on lake hermann road
in in vallejo california and they were
both uh shot to death
now uh again no motive so the police
didn't really know what the [ __ ] was
going on it's just somebody that
randomly came up and
shot a young couple like teenage couple
buy their car you know so they didn't
really know what to make of it
july 5th 1969 darlene ferran 22 years
old her boyfriend mike maggio who was 19
sitting in a parked car uh in vallejo a
different location
and they get approached by a dude with a
flashlight comes up to their car and
this uh person
fired multiple shots at them which
killed pharyn and wounded maggio
although he did survive
an hour later
a dude calls the police department the
vallejo police department
and tells them the location of the crime
scene and claimed responsibility for
this particular uh attack and
the 1968 murders of faraday and jan and
jensen
august 1st 1969 the san francisco
examiner newspaper uh san francisco
chronicle and the vallejo times herald
they get a
they all get copies of a handwritten
letter in an envelope which did not have
a return address
uh the letter starts dear editor i am
the killer of the two teenagers last
christmas at lake hermann
and these letters contained details
of these crimes that were not known to
the public so
they took them pretty seriously from the
get-go because they had [ __ ] in there
that the public didn't know
now the person whoever wrote these
letters uh threatened further attacks
said if you don't print these letters on
the front page of your newspapers
i'm gonna do some worse [ __ ]
uh which was dramatized in the excellent
dave adventure movie zodiac have you
seen the david fincher movie zodiac long
time ago
oh we should do a thing on that too
because
man that [ __ ] movie is so good i love
you i remember liking it um i mean it's
based on grace uh you know it's mostly
based on uh grace smith's book well two
he wrote two books about it but it's
mostly based on him
so
um you know so there might be some kind
of like bias or whatever but it's just a
really good
movie i mean it's it's really [ __ ]
good
and we just did a dave adventure movie
we did fight club so we should probably
do zodiac again and i think i brought it
up on there so uh so he sends these
letters he's always like threatening
more [ __ ] print my [ __ ] on the front
page or i'm gonna do xyz
um i kind of feel like some of the
newspapers were like well
we don't really want to put on the front
page because we don't want to encourage
the dude but it's like we still want to
print it so we can like look like we're
doing what he says
so
i think what they i think what they
showed in zodiac was like we'll we'll
put it on like page three or like page
eight or something like that so we're
like technically we're putting in the
paper but we're not putting out the
front page so we're not looking like
we're conceding to like serial killers
demands but you know what i mean so they
do that
now each of the letters that came in had
the very famous uh you know zodiac
symbol which they call it which kind of
looks like crosshairs
so there's that kind of whole thing now
the letters
also had uh one part of a three-part
cipher
and this cipher
uh
which he said
contained his identity
this ended up probably not really being
true but we'll get into that in a little
bit but that was like kind of one of the
things that i think fueled the
uh the public uh intrigue in the case
because it's like oh it's codes
everybody loves that [ __ ]
so another letter comes in
while these other murders still being
investigated
uh this letter comes into the san
francisco examiner it says dear editor
this is the zodiac speaking which i
believe was the first time that he
identified himself as the zodiac
and again he told about the murders
very detailed uh details that only the
police and the killer would know
and started making fun of the cops for
not being able to catch him
now a couple days after that letter
arrived um one of the first this first
cipher was broken this was by a high
school teacher named donald harden and
his wife betty they figured out the
cipher the cipher said i like killing
people because it is so much fun
it is more fun than killing wild game in
the forest because man is the most
dangerous animal of all what a [ __ ]
edge lord yeah but you know that that's
what the first cipher said and they were
able to figure it out like just in a
couple of days so obviously it wasn't
that uh difficult
sorry i was laughing at camp guy while
jethro is ciphering ellie mae and granny
are going to be smoking some crawdads
out of this
the cement pond i have to say it like
that yes camp guy saying i heard tom
shaved his head where the [ __ ] you bad
you shaved your head a long time a long
time ago are you always wearing a hat on
this i guess so yeah
no no i said [ __ ] that [ __ ]
as soon as i started getting big i just
shaved my head i'm [ __ ] with that i
went [ __ ]
oh what's this he wants to be like the
rock
the rock is [ __ ] huge compared to me
if anything i'd be more like that dude
from [ __ ] um
oh [ __ ] what was that dude's name
i don't know who you're talking about
dude from [ __ ] riddick
okay vin diesel vin diesel
he's physically bigger than me but
proportions are similar right now
similar
although i haven't met either one of
them but honestly dwayne johnson seems
like a delightful person oh [ __ ]
johnson's black adam is coming out have
you seen the trailer no is it good
yeah okay we're going to see that i'll
have to send it to you
i was going to shazam i was going to
send the black adam trailer to you but i
thought you'd already seen it i haven't
seen it
vin diesel is a dick okay [ __ ]
everybody that's what i appreciate he's
real close to [ __ ] seagal all right
uh why do you want to be that way why
can't you why can't you be like dwayne
johnson
who is beloved by everyone in the world
i mean he seems like just a lovely
person i follow this the rock on [ __ ]
instagram he lives in the hollywood area
and he pulls up on the [ __ ] like uh
stars tour buses where there's people
like doing through the hollywood tours
and he [ __ ] pulls up he goes hey how
are you guys doing and they start
freaking out he starts talking to the
people in the tour bus
he goes and he goes
seriously
and he tapes it on his [ __ ] phone
does it on his phone i say tape it like
a boomer like a [ __ ] he records
it on his phone and [ __ ] posted on
instagram of him talking to the people
in the hollywood tour bus he's adorable
yeah from his [ __ ] [ __ ] title or
whatever sports car he's in and they're
going it's the rock he goes yeah it's
the rock how you guys doing you like
hollywood you know that kind of said
he's a good dude he's a good dude more
people should be like the rock yeah
don't be a dick be like the rock he just
well he just seems like a nice man he
just seems like a genuinely cool
everybody that i know everybody that
i've i have never heard anybody say a
bad thing about him he's good i mean
maybe somebody has but i've never heard
it
everybody says he's just a lovely human
being he's kind of like
the arnold schwarzenegger of this era
but
he's not as aloof as arnold was
he's like a [ __ ] real nice guy yeah
was very friendly arnold was a [ __ ]
prankster okay
and it was which i don't love that
it was a different time there was no
social media back then if there was
social media in the time of arnold when
he was [ __ ] at his zenith
and he was really at his zenith when he
was 40
with predator one he would have been
playing it up then too
he would have turned out very
differently in those days stars had to
be kind of a loot aloof
from the people
that's where they're powerful you had to
be above the hoi polloi right yeah to a
certain extent that's what
it was a different time i guess
but no the rock is the [ __ ] but we're
talking about physiques
no [ __ ] um i'm kind of like a vin a
mini vin diesel diesel was kind of
[ __ ] um
yeah he was
his frame is bigger than mine but
i look at pictures of him and i go yeah
that's that's almost where i'm at now
rebecca says when i lived in florida i
wished i could shave my head in the heat
yeah i know that feeling well that's why
i kind of like i haven't shaved it in a
while because i'm lazy so it's kind of
like growing out but honestly all this
underneath is all shaved
yeah i do that every summer now diesel's
the diesel's looking like [ __ ] though
now i've seen pictures of him recently
he looks like [ __ ] he's fat now
nice that's what happens when you stop
taking steroids and stuff well i don't
think that's what it was
it was just
he's just not i don't think he's [ __ ]
in on it he didn't care anymore
you can come off you can come off all
that stuff and if you know what to take
and he's got the money he does know he
knows
it's just um he doesn't care
he doesn't care plus he's got a bigger
frame so it's it's harder to deal with
such a bigger frame to keep that
together
and he's the same age as me i think
maybe he's a little bit older
i'm 52. i think he's a couple years
older than me i'm not sure
i don't know like every time like i said
every time i come across somebody like
the rock that's a celebrity but that
everybody like seems to be like
universally loved yeah um i don't
understand like why can't everybody be
like that like why do you have to be
like yes you have money yes you're
beautiful yes you're famous you don't
have to like deal with the [ __ ] that the
rest of us like losers have to deal with
okay fine but it's like that doesn't
mean that you have to like go like spend
your entire short existence on earth
being a [ __ ] douchebag to everybody
else why you got to be like that why
can't you just like be like the rock be
like a nice cool person that like
many years from now when you die
everyone will be sad
i don't want to be the kind of person i
don't want to be the kind of person that
when i die and it's like yeah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] i'm gonna tell you what let me
tell you what and i can think of a lot
of people that when they die i'd be like
good i'm gonna tell you why don't be
that kind of person the rock was a
winner from day one
he was a winner from an early age he won
he was winning all the way into
um you know his [ __ ] wrestling career
and then his acting career
so he never started off as like a beta
he didn't have that hatred in him
you know i'm talking about he wasn't
getting revenge on people
it's not it's it's a very different
mentality
the rock grew up as a big powerful
good-looking guy and a good actor so i
guess he didn't like get [ __ ] on by life
so maybe that's why that's part of it so
in a way like he didn't so he had a lot
of privileges that a lot of people don't
have i don't think it's a privilege well
it is because a lot of people don't grow
up like that if you don't grow up good
looking or you don't grow up like um you
know socially adequate or whatever
you're gonna get [ __ ] on and a certain
type of person is going to
take that and like you know privilege a
privilege infers that it was given to
him i don't think it was given no i
don't mean it like that i just mean that
certain people like if you're i mean
you're not disputing the fact that
people that are good-looking get treated
better
generally because they do yeah oh yeah
um i can tell it in my life i mean well
no that's what i'm saying so so people
that are you know not blessed with like
good genetics or are not blessed with
being oh no that's not genetics in those
dudes
no i'm just saying as a kid i'm talking
about because i'm talking mostly about
like childhood right so if you're like
growing up you know and grew up as as
acceptable
right no i mean if you if you grow up
poor or kind of ugly or kind of like
funny-looking or kind of
um you know socially awkward or
something like that yeah you're going to
have a lot of [ __ ] that's going to you
know and you're going to tend towards
you and a certain types of people well
not necessarily yeah i mean it depends
on the personality yeah if you have a
certain type of mentality that
you know uh cast things outward cast
blame outward because some people do
um then yeah you're gonna have a lot of
resentment about that because you've
been treated shitty your whole life
right so i don't you know um you know so
so not everybody has the privilege of
like just being good looking or at least
just like um you know average average
[ __ ]
that's luck
privilege in in
uh never mind
sounds like that it's something that was
given to them by someone else it isn't
it's just no that's not what i mean by
okay it's just i mean privilege that's
just a generic term yeah um it's a
politically loaded term right now yeah
but i mean
you have privileges because of
what you look like or because of uh how
much money your family has or something
like that it's not
i don't see it as like a term like that
that's just it's just something that
happens to you it's not something that
somebody gives to you or something like
that it doesn't mean that
okay you know what i'm saying i guess
yeah it doesn't
the rock was always a cool dude
yeah he was always kind of an alpha
you know
alphas are tend to be very secure around
other people which means that they're
generous
you know well they don't have to be
dicks because they're not compensating
for anything that and they're not under
attack because they're too strong to
attack
you don't you understand what i'm
talking about
that's what i mean so they don't have
people like [ __ ] on them constantly
right
right so they don't really feel the need
to like lash out right so i'm not saying
that it's like oh with like his fault
that he's like no no and i'm not saying
that either i'm just saying that people
are privileged they're lucky like that
yeah uh not everyone has those
privileges or not everyone has that kind
of luck
um
yeah and i'm not saying that that
excuses bad behavior later on because it
does not because a lot of people grew up
ugly or grew up poor or whatever and
didn't turn out like that most people
don't matter of fact the rockwood has so
far from what i've been seeing and what
i've been hearing is nice to everybody
yeah that's what i'm saying and that's
kind of rare right if you right and if
if you
uh that that's the kind of guy i am you
sh
i show you respect you show me respect
i'm nice to you you're nice to me
which is
the essence of simeon behavior all
primates are like that
most animals are like that
you're nice to you you're nice to me i'm
nice to you
it's it's you know what i mean it's it's
it it's a two-way street
i don't care what you look like if
you're nice to me i'm nice to you
you know but some people aren't like
that
well i mean that's what i noticed look
since [ __ ]
i kind of [ __ ] got what the [ __ ] what
you doing pokey what's your matter with
your pokey oh she's playing with her
her little channel
your little treat toys this goes back to
what i said years ago man before i
started working out and doing stuff you
know i was always physically fit
uh there's times where i get a little
[ __ ] chubby i have to lose weight uh
but back in the military and everything
was always had decent fitness
uh i was always also very um
i understood that you could judge a
person by how they looked
uh there is something to that you can't
be stupid
if a person looks like a bum and they
have a [ __ ] bunch of dried up piss
going down their leg of their pants you
know this [ __ ] is crazy okay
i mean that's they are how that's an
extreme example but the people are kind
of how they look you know what i mean if
a person doesn't isn't in good condition
it's because they're not taking care of
themselves
um
yeah i i've noticed that the way people
treat me now is very different than the
way they treated me five years ago real
different
hell yeah
why people are [ __ ] superficial
but there's something to that it's just
the way humans are it's the way animals
are
can i get back to what i was talking
about go ahead okay danny says the
privilege of this gary guy even being
named a suspect is whack without any
proof i kind of agree with you on that
um i'm not saying the dude is
i mean he's dead now but um he's not a
good dude because he did some other bad
[ __ ]
but
i'm not willing to go out there and say
he's the zodiac but we'll get into that
a little bit
all right so let me get back to the [ __ ]
okay so where was i all right so uh so
the first cipher got cracked right
man is most dangerous and while blah
blah blah like i said very angel
now uh evening of september 27th 1969 a
day before my birthday but three days
before i was born
uh he strikes again he approaches
another and this murder was always one
that freaked me out the most i guess
because
prior to this and i'm not saying this
isn't like upsetting because it still is
but like walking up to people in a car
and just like shooting them and [ __ ]
that's like [ __ ] up but this one this
couple was just like laying out on a
beach right and this dude just like
comes up and just start stabbing them
so
i don't know like every time like when i
saw that in the dave adventure movie it
like that really stuck with me that
[ __ ] scene it's just horrifying
so this was cecilia shepard and brian uh
hartnell
so they were on lake berryessa i believe
they had skipped school that day it was
senior skip day or whatever and they
were just like hanging out like on the
lake they're just laying there there's
not a lot of other people around this
dude walks up to them in a [ __ ] hood
and the shirt with the uh you know the
symbol on it like with the that looks
like the crosshairs he walks up to them
ties him up and i think he said he
wasn't gonna hurt him but then he starts
like stabbing them right and then he uh
puts the message on their car door
and takes off and then he calls napa
police department and says that he did
it
and so the cops go out there now um
cecilia shepard actually ended up dying
a couple days later from her injuries
but uh brian hartnell actually did
survive thankfully
now two weeks after that october 11th
1969 zodiac uh took another life 29 year
old taxi driver paul stein this was in
presidio heights in san francisco
and this uh murder was actually not
attributed to the zodiac immediately
because it wasn't his usual ammo it just
seemed like
even though no money was taken um it
seemed like a robbery like somebody that
was just in a cab and they you know shot
the cab driver or whatever
but three days after uh this murder took
place
uh the san francisco chronicle got a
letter
and it was purportedly from the zodiac
and he said that he had done it
uh because it was the same handwriting
and all that kind of [ __ ] now he said
that he like he gave the details of the
murder
and in
the package with the letter was a little
bit of stein's shirt that had blood on
it you know so the same so obviously it
was like the same person that had been
there
now uh at this point the killer says
he kind of like teases
his next murder uh he's gonna shoot out
the tires of a school bus and he's gonna
quote unquote pick off the kitties as
they come bouncing out
so those are kind of like the canonical
zodiac murders which i feel like most
people like know about at this point so
those are the ones that that you know
are definitely attributed to him
now there have been a bunch of other
ones that have been attributed but it
hadn't really been uh you know proven
one way or the other
uh one of these was the 1963 shooting of
robert dominguez and linda edwards this
was in santa barbara i actually wrote
about that case in one of my books
which did very much seem like a zodiac
style uh killing but they haven't been
able to like link it to him one way or
the other but it did seem like very much
his mo
another murder that's brought up a lot
in relation to the zodiac although
they're not sure if he actually did it
or not was the 1966 stabbing death of
sherry joe bates that was in riverside
california in 1966.
now
so the zodiac keeps on writing all these
letters as i said even though he was
only officially credited with five
murders
he claimed in his letters to committed
as many as 37 and he kept saying things
like oh i know i've done all these other
murders that you guys don't know about
and blah blah so there over the years
they've been like a lot of other murders
that have been attributed to him but
they don't really know if he actually
did any of them or not
um and he actually did send like some
more ciphers
and
again like kept like making fun of the
cops for not being able to catch him so
he started
i mean honestly he kept sending letters
until
1974. like the letters stopped in 1974
even the last murderer that was actually
attributed to him was 1969 so for five
years following that he kept
sending [ __ ] letters
so obviously over the years uh because
he wasn't caught and nobody really knew
what the [ __ ] was going on with that
like several of cyphers hadn't been
solved
um a lot of [ __ ] theories man there
have been so many [ __ ]
um
suspects on this
we even talked about because i remember
like a couple weeks ago when i talked
about that brian de palma movie um the
black dahlia
and i don't remember if i brought it up
on that but i'm pretty sure we brought
it up on our first zodiac show that
george hodel the guy that who said oh my
dad killed the black dahlia
and was maybe also like a serial killer
and was also the zodiac like he didn't
he write like another book later where
he said his dad was a zodiac um
i'm not buying that that was like a
totally different mo
but it just goes to show how
i mean the branding opportunity that you
have the zodiac killer it's like the
most famous
uncaught serial killer probably in
american history right so you know if
they're going to try to link every
unsolved crime to this [ __ ] mike
burt jumps in goes what the [ __ ] is this
this is a talk show bird
sit the [ __ ] back and enjoy this [ __ ]
it's a talk show
i need another drink you want to know
okay yeah
daniel bauer says it was arthur lee
allen honestly i'm kind of leaning
toward that um
sure why not i mean how much of it is
left a little bit i mean use it up yeah
we can throw the bottle out
um like ever clear
i know but just don't put so much of it
in there
yeah just put less in there it's very
strong it's 100 proof instead of 80
proof
um
yeah i mean i don't know i wasn't there
but i ca and until they have dna arthur
lee allen died in 1992
but
to be honest most of the circumstantial
evidence pointed toward him so
and he was the only suspect that was
actually like as far as i know like
officially named
so i kind of feel like probably it was
him might not have been but
honestly like some of the crazy [ __ ]
they've come up with over the years i
don't really know like the whole george
the whole george hodel thing like oh my
dad
killed the black dahlia which
i read some of that [ __ ] and i'm like
you know what maybe
you know maybe he did that one
um
but then to go on and write another book
where you're like oh and also he was the
zodiac like he was trying to like tie
him in with every unsolved serial killer
case now you're going a little bit far
that's a completely different
modus operandi not saying it's
impossible i'm just saying it's very
very unlikely
so i'm not even like given that the time
of day
um so
some people have said too that they
think maybe
uh old unibomber ted kaczynski
uh that maybe before he started the
whole
living out in a cabin building bombs
situation
that maybe he was the zodiac
i don't really know like what the
what the evidence is for that
uh it doesn't sound all that plausible
not impossible but doesn't sound all
that plausible some people have said too
like maybe it's charles manson maybe it
was
some dude that like moved to scotland
and then like he did that and then he
moved to scotland did some [ __ ] over
there so i i don't know it it's just
kind of like he's kind of got to a point
the zodiac has kind of got to a point
almost whereas jack the ripper is
where
every single unsolved murder that
happened while jack the ripper was
plausibly still alive they're gonna like
try and tie it to that one person
whoever he was so i kind of feel like
that's
kind of happening with the zodiac at
this point
so they're trying to like tile this [ __ ]
together
now i even talked about remember we did
a show a while back about the monster of
lawrence that dude that who did who did
some zodiac type [ __ ] i mean he went
around like killing couples and cars and
[ __ ] like that
so there was a theory going around i
don't know how plausible it is but there
was a theory going around that maybe
uh the dude that was the zodiac
then moved to italy
and became the monster of lawrence
so there's kind of a thing going on it's
not as crazy as it sounds
um
we'll talk about okay i'm going to talk
about this right now
so this kind of came about in i think
2018 so maybe it came about like after
because i can't remember if we talked
about this on our original zodiac show
maybe we did but i don't i don't
remember talking about it
i might have talked about on the monster
florence show because i think that was
later
but there was a theory that came out in
2018 uh that was talking about a
connection between the zodiac and the
monster of lawrence case and this kind
of came from an italian magazine called
tempe
and that was kind of the first place and
then it was published in a bunch of
other newspapers now they do have a
suspect right now the suspect is a dude
named joseph bevalaqua
and i kind of feel like that name is
familiar so i probably like i think i
talked about him on the monster of
lawrence show
now he actually he was an american but
he moved to italy
uh later on like in 1974
which
zodiac people are like quick to point
out that's when the letters stopped
coming to law enforcement in the united
states
um you know after the zodiac killing
stopped in like 1969 if they did stop in
1969
so uh so the whole thing about that is
that
uh so joe bevalaqua who was the suspect
for this born in 1935 in new jersey and
he was in the army
and he lived uh you know in the united
states until 1974 and then he moved to
florence italy
now
apparently
the first thing that kind of brought him
to the attention of zodiac researchers i
guess
was that apparently he confessed maybe
to this dude like an author named
francesco amakoni
and he said
that he was the zodiac like an un
unrecorded conversation back in 2017.
now after this came out in the press
uh joe bevalaqua comes forward and says
no i didn't say that or that's not true
or whatever
and
but
but then like the guy that said that
like doubled down on it
and said you know joe bevalaqua
he was in the army he would have been an
undercover cid agent
and yeah and he would have been
um
[Music]
that
his paperwork he says says that he was
working on some like undercover [ __ ]
like investigation in san francisco
at the time that the zodiac was killing
people
and that when he moved to florence
in 1974
he would have had access to case files
of like a double murder that had
happened in 1968 there
and he knew where the um
like the bullets like the shell casings
from that murder would have been stored
and they are
saying allegedly
that he switched out like some of the um
like some of the evidence from that case
into some of the other case so he could
so he could do the monster florence
cases and like it would
go back to like some other like [ __ ]
that wasn't involved with him you know
what i'm saying so he would have had
access to
evidence in some cases that he could use
you know what i'm talking about yeah
that yeah
uh so
apparently um
the italian authorities were interested
enough in this not so much in the zodiac
thing but more in the monster of
lawrence thing
so they did actually apparently as far
as i could tell
they got his dna
in late 2020
but i haven't heard anything since then
so i don't know if they've linked him
with anything
um
i don't know i've seen some sites saying
it's like oh it's a possibility maybe he
did some [ __ ] um i don't know
if they're looking at him as maybe he
was the zodiac or maybe he was a suspect
in the monster of florence case
um which we did a show about a while
back but
you know could have been maybe he did
some [ __ ] i don't really know but we'll
we'll figure that out like i said they
did take his dna so they were interested
enough to do that so we'll see how that
uh comes out
so as i mentioned earlier
uh the dude were talking about the uh
you know the dave adventure movie zodiac
which was based on robert gray smith's
books
uh zodiac which came out in 1986
zodiac unmask which came out in 2002
and those two books he was a journalist
that was working on the case like during
the time that they were going on
and uh you know the movie zodiac is kind
of mostly from his point of view because
it's based on his books
and
they're kind of coming down on the side
of we're pretty sure even though they
couldn't prove it that the zodiac was
probably the student named arthur lee
allen like i said he died in 1992 they
couldn't ever conclusively link him to
any of the murders but there was a [ __ ]
ton of circumstantial evidence which
tied him to a lot of the things so most
people
you know you can't prove it but
most people think that probably he was
like the most likely suspect
and as i said i believe he was the only
suspect that was identified by name
by actual authorities and not just like
people that were theorizing on the
internet or whatever
now interestingly 2014 here's some [ __ ]
that's happened
more recently like in the past few years
2014
uh this book comes out called the most
dangerous animal of all i might have
talked about this on the original zodiac
show
harpercollins published it this book was
published by gary stewart
and
much in the vein of uh
of george hodel or steve hodell
he's like uh what what's kind of a thing
where it's like everybody's writing a
book it's like oh my dad is this ex
famous serial killer is that was like
the way to make money
i don't know
for a certain time period because i feel
like after that happened like the black
dahlia avenger yeah it's like
2010 around that time yeah something
like that well um
hodel's book might have been wow i kind
of feel like that was 2008 but maybe it
was earlier than that where he said well
i mean at first
the first book that hodel wrote where he
said oh i found i was going through my
dad's stuff oh thank you mike
he's a little hyped thank you that's
funny
um
he basic his whole thing how he got
started on that which we talked about in
the black dahlia show that we did
his whole thing started when he was go
like his dad died and then he was going
through his dad's stuff or so he said
and he's like oh i found all these
pictures in my dad's stuff and one of
them looked like the black dahlia even
though i saw the picture he was talking
about and it didn't really look like her
that much to me or you couldn't really
tell who it was but whatever that's kind
of what started him on this whole thing
and so he wrote this whole book
basically claiming oh my dad killed the
black dahlia now i'm not saying that he
didn't i'm you know some of the [ __ ]
that he came up with like you know the
the picture uh
that just really didn't say that much to
me handwriting analysis is largely
[ __ ] so i'm not going to give that
any credence but some of the other stuff
that he said maybe oh my god
thank you so much miguel
i appreciate what you do what is that a
gift from my cat menino to baby cookie
you recently moved to skyrim to come
okay thank you very much oh what is that
mexican peso mexican 500 peso mexican
500 mx i know it's not much that's okay
i don't i don't even know how much that
is
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know
that's exciting we like to get anything
i don't really i don't really care how
much it is
you just give me a dollar i can like
[ __ ] i could buy some [ __ ] with that
that's fine
it all adds up
uh but yeah so
i was willing to give the dude the
benefit of the doubt i think i said this
on the black dollar show i was willing
to give the dude the benefit i don't
know if his dad killed the black guy i
don't know somebody did obviously
but
then the fact that he went on to say oh
by the way
my dad is also
you know the zodiac and did didn't he
say he also did the [ __ ] cleveland
torso murders or am i tripping because i
kind of feel like some people said that
the black dolly and the cleveland torso
murders might have been done by the same
person which to me seems more likely
because at least the mo is similar but
zodiac and
black dahlia
those are two completely different
that's two completely different things
sorry that's like two completely
different mo's not impossible but very
unlikely so yeah so uh i so i don't know
what that's about i'm not even gonna
like give that thing
but 2014 what's i said all that to say
that i guess
him doing that accusing his dead dad
thank you victor he gave me a dollar
yeah
see i can buy like a whole candy bar
with that yeah
and i'll get a lot of enjoyment out of
it so you know
um what khan says has 25 dollars that's
very
buenos
air yeah thank you very much like i said
that's a lot of money buy yourself an
arizona tea yeah
honestly yeah we go to like they're good
the circle k at the corner yeah yeah
they have those like big like tall
arizona green tea i love those they're
99 cents well they have a couple they
got the [ __ ] arizona [ __ ] sweet
tea yeah oh and those are good too those
are good but we buy those if we're going
like on a long drive it's like a dollar
yeah it's like that big and then they
have somewhere like
a half inch half which is half tea
yeah that's the arnold palmer yeah it's
all palmer it's half tea and half
lemonade
since i was a kid arizona
would give you your money's worth
they've never been more than a dollar
yeah they're always like that's 99 cents
it's printed on the cash it's right
there this big ass [ __ ]
it's a big talking and they're decent
the green tea is like decent yeah and
like you said the arnold palmer is good
too yeah and it's just like we were
[ __ ] the fruit punch is okay too we
we were happy back in the [ __ ] 80s
going to 7-eleven and getting a [ __ ]
arizona
for a mere dollar when you're a [ __ ]
broke teenager that's like oh i
amanda marie serenity says love arizona
green tea jenny it's heaven i know i
used to buy that [ __ ] by the [ __ ]
gallon seriously yeah i used to drink
that all the time it was between that
and water
yeah i really like their green tea it's
good
zach says at the gas station i work at
we sell arizona green tea candy oh is it
good i've had other i haven't had the
arizona one but i've had green tea candy
that's actually real i like
green tea candy i like coffee candy i
like all that kind of stuff so nom for
nick i don't know how to [ __ ]
pronounce that but he uh nominec he said
that the [ __ ] green tea diet kind of
sucks well diet everything diet
everything
it always tastes like weird it leaves
like a weird aftertaste as far as
arizona tea goes the the southern sweet
tea that's the one i like the most sweet
tea
dj maniac says yeah 99 cents you can
save the money for the insulin you'll
need eventually when you get type 857
diabetes
[Laughter]
i think the green tea doesn't have too
much sugar in it yeah that arizona
[ __ ] green tea the yeah [ __ ] i
like the green tea more the sweet tea is
okay too
but i can't drink a whole bottle of it
the sweet tea tastes more authentic
because you get like it's a buck or
honestly the circle k i think they're
two for a dollar or
no they're no no no okay look in the
circle k the very large it's big the
[ __ ] big ones you can get two for
three dollars yeah it's two for three
dollars they're [ __ ] huge yeah
they're a giant they're not i can't
drink i can't drink a whole one of those
yeah
and it's too much yeah it's two for
three dollars and they're [ __ ] sweet
tea
yeah and they got some [ __ ] they look
southern as [ __ ] and you drink it and
you go yeah that's sweet tea it is yeah
but i can't drink a whole bottle of it
right
so
you know so it's good but it's kind of a
waste because i can't drink at all and
if y'all yeah i don't know
in the south we drink something called
sweet tea it's [ __ ] it's just lipped
in tea
with about 40 bajillion gallons of sugar
and sweet it's like it's almost like
syrup it's that much there's that much
sugar in it there's no lemon in it or
anything it's just sweet tea
and we like it
it's kind of like it's kind of like
dripping drinking maple syrup
in a way it's [ __ ] strong it's not
quite that bad oh got another soup but
it's getting there super chat's just
hitting us all of a sudden thank you
people hurry
victor says buy yourself a week's worth
it gave us six dollars
yeah oh my god yeah right
yeah when we go by the circle okay well
i mean if we're going a long road trip
like if we're driving somewhere far away
we stop at the circle k and we'll get
like well they're two for you know
they're two for three dollars what's so
funny is that we got a circle k on one
side of the [ __ ] intersection and a
circle k on the other side it's just
like manhattan with the starbucks like
right across
except it's circle case and it's not
manhattan in the south it's all circle k
it is circle k and 7-eleven that's it
and
and they're both good
you can actually get good food at
7-eleven now which i would never would
have imagined that as a kid
but no you see what a time to be alive
you can get good food and [ __ ] i told
you i used to and circle k isn't good
isn't bad either they had good i used to
work
at a print shop that was right next to a
7-eleven yeah so that was kind of like
there i mean there wasn't any place
around there to eat other than 7-eleven
there was like a subway and i'm not a
big fan of subway so i mean you could go
to 7-eleven you man you get salads you
get decent sandwiches in there you could
get hard-boiled eggs you can get like
little vegetable plates most circles
little cheese and nuts kind of
most combos those circle caves in the
south either have a subway in it or a
hardy's
yeah hardee's can be
an acquired taste it depends on what
you're talking about it's okay if you're
broke and you just want some
food that's edible the
the the ground beef patties you could
tell that soy
the beet patty's not as good as
mcdonald's
but they try you know
and no they're not cheap they're about
the same price as mcdonald's it's
ridiculous
wait i thought they were a little bit
cheaper but not that much
not that much not that much cheaper not
to justify that [ __ ] beef patty and i
mean honestly like hearties sometimes
has those like deals where they have
like that cheap box yeah lunch yeah but
they don't give you much in there
parties have decent french fries yeah
they're french fries yeah they're okay
it's hard to mess up french fries to be
well no you can mess up french fries
i'll still eat them though should be
fair with them i mean yeah french fries
are good i don't care how soggy they are
i would put i would but i would put
hearties at the bottom
yeah i'm not putting it at the bottom
it's not bad but it's not as good it'll
do in a pinch like if you're really
really hungry and there's nothing else
around like we've
we've eaten there a couple times when
we're on a hurried we're in a hurry and
it's just on the way where we're going
it's like okay well that'll do right you
know what i mean and her and hardy's
when the 80s was good
it was better
thank you victor thank you very much bro
buy yourself a week's worth of tea and
some fritos okay yeah you can have the
fritos i don't like fritos hardy's
parties in the 80s was almost kind of
like it reminded me of carl's jr from
california yeah see we didn't have
carl's jr here so yeah yeah it used to
be like carl's jr but it's not anymore
let me get a drink
yeah i mean i don't know like i said
i'll eat there if i have like i'm not
picky like i said i grew up in a [ __ ]
trailer park i'm not gonna get [ __ ]
picky on the [ __ ] but
um
even fast food if i'm gonna if i had to
pick like a fast food place like a
drive-through
hardee's is not gonna be my first pick
to be honest probably wendy's would be
my first pick
but
hardee's is going to be toward the
bottom of the list got to say
also got to say taco bell is probably
going to be toward the bottom of the
list as well not a big problem
oh now see del taco yeah that's another
story
we got two del tacos um they're kind of
far from here though one of them is by
ucf which is over where i used to live
in winter park which is kind of far from
here
and the other one where's the other one
i kind of feel like the other one is
more toward disney area isn't it
we only have two i only know that one
there's only two in the orlando area
but del taco is cool because they have
tacos and [ __ ] but then they have french
fries which i think is awesome so you
get like tacos and a side of french
fries
which doesn't which doesn't make any
sense but i'm i'm down with it
del taco is not mexican it's it's
amazing no
that's all right that's a lot better but
it's good yeah it's open all night
better than taco bell a lot better me
and my friend when i used to live in
winter park and me and my like before i
met him
so me and my friend um who also kind of
lived over she lived in oviedo actually
so we used to go out clubbing and we
used to go out on the town
and we almost always went to del taco
because they were open all night
and man they had like they had really
good chicken tacos they got fish tacos
and they had french fries i love that
you could get
a chicken taco or two chicken tacos at a
side of french fries i'm like oh my god
this place this is my spirit animal i'm
like i'm like into it so you know when
you're drunk that's like really really
cool and i'm not like i love tacos but
i don't know i'm not really one of those
taco bell type of people i'll eat there
if i had to but i'd rather have
something else to be honest when i'm
drunk i always want like kind of
breakfasty food
which is why i used to like when
mcdonald's was open all night and when
mcdonald's would do
all night breakfast like i was really
excited when they started doing that
because
i'm like man
because when i'm drunk it's three
o'clock in the morning it's like man i
want a [ __ ] egg mcmuffin or sausage
egg mcmuffin so when they stopped doing
that during the pandemic that was like
really sad but you know del taco is like
that we have two of them in orlando but
they're too far
to go to
um you know
they're not on the way from anywhere
that we're going so sadly
all right so
where was i
okay
all right so 2014 this other dude
because i got off on this whole
hotel thing
because i kind of feel like there was a
mini
was there like a
kind of a mini boom and
people writing books oh my my dad is
this my dead dad is this ex-serial
killer
i kind of feel like there was a mini
boob in that so this might have been uh
a little bit of that
so this book comes out in 2014 called
the most dangerous animal of all and
this was written by gary stewart
and this guy said that his dad earl van
bess jr
uh was the zodiac because like i said i
kind of feel like that was in the
zeitgeist at the time
um
not really a huge amount of evidence to
support that
um
his dad was like really into ciphers and
codes and stuff which okay
uh also really was into the mikado that
opera which
you know okay the zodiac quoted that uh
once in his letters
and uh so
this book the whole premise of it
was that
um
was that this dude named louis myers
had
confessed to being the killer before he
died in 2002.
so this guy
allegedly
um said yeah i'm the zodiac killer and
then he died into this but don't go to
the cops till after i'm dead
conveniently and then he died
so then later they go to the cops now
this dude
louis myers
i don't know how how accurate this is
but i'm just saying
now louis myers supposedly lived near
san francisco from 1975 1971 uh like
said zodiac murders 1968 1969.
um
they think that he was probably 17 years
old when the first murder occurred which
okay that's young but that's not
crazy
um serial killers tend toward well i
don't know serial killers tend toward
well they start when they're younger
they do some of them start around
puberty
um
and they tend to stop if they stop they
tend to stop in their 30s or 40s
you know um
a lot of times serial killers they don't
get caught obviously until they're older
but a lot of times they've done [ __ ]
up [ __ ] in their very early 2014 killing
animals or maybe killing people that
they didn't you know that they didn't
really like get
caught for uh that happens a lot too
so if this person is the zodiac he was
17 when he started now uh this guy
attended two high schools in the bay
area of vallejo and hogan now
interestingly the first two zodiac
victims
uh who were a teenage couple
one of them went to vallejo high school
and the other one went to hogan high
school so again that's a little strange
could be a coincidence
just saying
uh also this guy supposedly worked with
another one of the victims
uh he was a bus boy and she was a
waitress at the same restaurant so again
a little weird i think i talked about
this on the zodiac show but i'm kind of
like reiterating it now he also worked
at a military surplus store
and his dad worked in a naval shipyard
so
it might have been because if you guys
remember like the stuff about the zodiac
like they think that um because the shoe
prints that they found and stuff like
that looked like a military style boot
like the prince that they found
um so
they're like so this guy could have had
access to the same type of uh military
boots that have been left at some of the
scenes
uh this guy was also in the army
stationed in germany from 1971 in 1973
uh during which time the zodiac killer
did not send any letters
which they thought was interesting
and um so apparently this dude had told
this friend that he uh allegedly
confessed to
he's like oh i didn't know the cab
driver who was paul stein that he shot
i was just trying to rob him for drug
money
i don't know see i don't know if i buy
that though
that that seems a little out of it but
okay
now a lot of the stuff did line up but
again they didn't really have any
concrete evidence so i don't think this
dude was ever like brought in
now interestingly
now we're getting like some recent [ __ ]
so 2020
uh amateur code breakers
figured out
the zodiac killers cipher z340
which is the one that was sent to the
san francisco chronicle in november
early november of 1969
which is the one that because two of
them were decoded
this one was the one that had kind of
like frustrated people for a really long
time for like 50 years right
um it hasn't been solved
uh somebody says they've finally solved
it
this is what it supposedly says
i hope you were having lots of fun in
trying to catch me
that wasn't me on the tv show which
brings up a point about me i am not
afraid of the gas chamber because it
will send me to paradise spelled wrong
all the sooner because i now have enough
slaves to work for me where everyone
else has nothing when they reach
paradise again spelled wrong so they are
afraid of death i am not afraid because
i know that my new life is life will be
an easy one in paradise against spelled
wrong death
that sounds like him yeah that sounds
like him uh that's apparently what the
cipher z340 says and it was not solved
until 20 [ __ ] 20. i believe it and
honestly
yeah because i kind of feel like he
sends the ciphers and he's like oh well
you better figure him out because it
says what my identity is
but it doesn't
and i kind of feel like he didn't intend
them to
that sounds like him yeah that actually
does what's funny is that and paradise
is spelled wrong with a c instead of an
s which is something that he did in the
other uh ciphers as well i wonder if he
did that on purpose to throw him off
or he was just a dummy or a dummy but
he's that dumb then how is he coming up
with a [ __ ] good cipher
system
he's not that dumb
well
intelligence takes a lot of different
forms yeah
um you would think you would a
[ __ ] would have checked this
spelling
you would think
and his grammar yeah the grammar in
these are atrocious just saying i'm
saying that is my in my grammar
nominations he had a system to my
grammar nazi self he had a system to
encode something in a [ __ ]
complicated way but he didn't even check
his spelling well the thing about it
though is that making a cipher that no
one can figure out
i don't be that bad i don't think that
takes as much intelligence as you think
because
if you just come up with a code
that only means something to you yeah
um or you're linking it to some
random ass
book for example or something like that
that no one's going to have any
association to then obviously no one's
going to figure that out um it's
definitely him that's the same gesture
that sounds like him yeah it's the same
gestalt it's the same
personality that's him
yeah and the legend he was amazed that
they couldn't crack that he he felt like
oh they'll never well they cracked the
other two i mean the first one they
cracked like what in a week or two yeah
like that teacher cracked it so he must
have went well they never cracked that
one so i know they'll never catch me i'm
so smart yeah i'm too smart for them
they'll never catch me because they
couldn't crack that just like encouraged
him yeah probably right
he was i feel like he was one of those
type of dudes that was like thought he
was way smarter than he actually was
you know what i'm saying
like i said all that stuff about oh man
the most dangerous animal blah blah blah
like i said he comes across nowadays
that's some edge lord [ __ ] yeah and and
and yeah we read that story in like
tonight yeah i think it was eighth grade
or ninth grade yeah we read that story
then so okay good job um that's when
you're not as smart as you think you are
but okay and like that definitely seems
like that what does that mean we read in
10th grade
i can't remember i kind of feel like we
were in junior high when we read that i
think everybody it's a short story it's
not a novel
but
hmm i took it literature
i feel i feel like it was junior high
american literature so that was all like
john dunn and girl and poe that was all
that good or uh you know
scarlet letter
poetry like emily dickinson right right
so i kind of feel like
um
i kind of feel like we read that in
junior high i read that in junior high
yeah and i remember so that was eighth
reading the most dangerous game yeah it
was in our book yeah it's in the
textbook yeah i remember it being in the
textbook so it's not like this guy
was privileged in terms of [ __ ]
education or special he just latched on
to the [ __ ] nearest thing to what he
wanted yeah i mean he saw that and he's
like oh yeah yeah if you're not from the
us i mean the most dangerous game is a
very common yeah i mean at least when we
were growing up required reading yeah it
was in the textbook that was a short
story that pretty much it was just kind
of like it was kind of like one of those
stories like the lady and the tiger that
everybody [ __ ] read yeah or the
lottery by shirley jackson everybody
read that the logan's run tv series had
a [ __ ] take off on most dangerous
games yeah it's very common yeah and
like i said there was a movie they did a
movie on mystery science theater yeah
what the [ __ ] was it called bloodlust
with an exclamation point uh the dad
from the brady bunch before he was on
the brady bunch was in that um and it
was essentially the same story although
i don't think they credited it which was
a little lame
but it was pretty much the same story it
was like the a bunch of teenagers and
they
ended up on this island and this dude
ended up hunting them it was it was
pretty much the same thing
but it's a very very common story so
like i said it's not it's not like this
dude was like super smart or anything
like that uh pretty much everybody at
least in our generation and maybe a few
generations after ours
read this in school
it was in the textbook
in junior higher high school i'm pretty
sure i read it in junior high i think it
was junior high
because like i said high school i'm
pretty sure
i don't remember reading in high school
i think i read it much earlier
but uh but yeah so
i don't know what the i don't know what
the 60s were like i don't know what the
dude i don't know what the school was
like when this dude was growing up
but
no
by the time the 70s rolled around it
smells of underachiever to me which is
uh typical for a uh
cereal killer
a underachiever that is imagining
himself as being more special than he
really is yeah that's definitely the
vibe i'm getting off the [ __ ] that he's
uh writing definitely
that's what i mean when i say like edge
lord he was like
yeah he's very much
camp guy says this guy they're talking
about now sounds intriguing he's
supposedly called the zodiac okay uh
quoted the mikado yeah new for me would
suggest a world war ii or korean war vet
was exposed to asian theater and women
not necessarily because the mikado was
um
you know that was an opera that was
that's fairly well known i mean that's
gilbert and sullivan uh so
we learned about it in high school
i don't know
you know i was in chorus though so i
don't i don't know how widespread that
is but
we watched it when i was in high school
like on tv like we watched a
you know a staging of it
but
so i don't know i it might have been
more widespread back then
i don't know when this dude went to high
school
i'm i can only speak of my high school
experience which was in the 80s
um
you know
i knew of the mikado i was in chorus
and i knew people that were in band and
[ __ ] like that and we wat we didn't do
any songs from that but
we were aware of it like we watched it
and in chorus the a tv staging of it so
there you go i don't really know
so i kind of feel like
definitely this is a dude that wanted to
come across as more intelligent than he
was but he clearly wasn't that
intelligent because his grammar is
atrocious yeah so that's the thing
his grammar spelling is atrocious
which
you know impress people honestly can't
spell paradise and like i said if you're
i don't mean be a snob okay but it's
just kind of like if you're trying to
come across as intelligent
um i don't care how much you know
if you can't write impr if english is
your native language and you can't spell
or write in proper english you're [ __ ]
i'm going to [ __ ] judge you yeah
sorry and take that from jenny you do
not you do not come as a trailer park
you don't come across as smart to me
because
if you were smart
you would have figured that [ __ ] out
yeah you would have had enough reading
experience because honestly i didn't
learn grammar and spelling from school i
learned it from reading books yeah uh if
you had read books
you would know
how grammar and spelling schools aren't
all they're cracked up to be anyway i
mean they are i enjoy each other they
get you started right a lot of it is
[ __ ] but i already knew a lot of that
stuff that's what that look the power of
the internet
had i had internet connection when i was
[ __ ] 10
i'd have been [ __ ] three times
smarter than i am now i would have
[ __ ] loved it i'd have been all over
that [ __ ] i would have soaked it up
yeah you know i'm just saying you just
teach yourself you don't really need i
mean i'm i'll give people benefit of the
doubt if it's online because everybody's
just like typing with their fat thumbs i
get that it's just like you know you're
gonna like do whatever i'm not gonna
judge you but with that but if you
publish a book for example like if you
self-publish a book or
an essay or some big long thing
and it's riddled with typos and
grammatical errors
then i'm just going to think you're a
dummy yeah sorry and i'm not i'm look
[Laughter]
look people i don't wanna i don't
necessarily mean to [ __ ] say that
people don't need schools
no well they do some people do yeah
uh let me clarify just because i didn't
but that was because i just really like
learning for the sake of there is
genetic intelligence there are some
people that are just [ __ ] jenny's one
of them she's born she has a [ __ ]
very high intelligence it's genetic in
her you give her the right source
material she'll dig through it well and
i love that she'll figure right she'll
figure it out i'm a nerd
i love that [ __ ] granthurst he doesn't
seem to be in here tonight we went to
[ __ ] high school he was here earlier
he was here earlier we went to high
school with the dude my best friend
[ __ ] steve rouse that [ __ ]
was a genetic scientist he was on the
human genome project went to ufm and
everything and we were talking about it
earlier
we talked about it about a year ago
we're like man
had we had internet connection
and in today's internet
when we were [ __ ] 17
we would have been [ __ ] unstoppable
we would have done all kinds of [ __ ]
and it's
some people are especially when you're
young when you're young and you have the
right [ __ ]
makeup the right i don't know your
parents are intelligent you're in the
right environment
um you're around the right kind of peers
the synergy
it drives you
to create things and to [ __ ] think of
things
and come up with [ __ ] that [ __ ] money
can't buy we were doing all kinds of
[ __ ] with the old technology and
information we had back then that was
cool
it just makes you [ __ ] think about
wait you know [ __ ] how how it would
have been if we'd have had access to
today's internet
it would have been very different
maybe but very different in a way i'm
kind of glad i didn't because i kind of
like
i mean i like that we have that now but
i like that i grew up with like the old
school in a certain way we were forced
to do things that [ __ ] i mean it
didn't feel like being forced because
you just we didn't know right but we
didn't know any better i didn't know any
better
yeah
so it seems like there's so many young
people today that are brilliant but they
take all this [ __ ] for granted they
don't they're not doing anything
with the technology that's out there no
a lot of people are a lot of people
aren't sure okay
i guess i'm just talking about the
people that we know the young people
that we know today
they're not real aggressive with what's
out there
well like you said because in a lot of
ways it's just part of the part
of what they grew up in yeah yeah so
it's like they're not so there's only
going to be like a small percentage of
people that are going to like take right
you know whatever the technology of the
time isn't like you know do something
different with it for you old [ __ ] who
know what i'm talking about if you would
have moved this technology back to our
time we were like oh [ __ ] this is skynet
we would take we would have taken that
[ __ ] [ __ ] serious as [ __ ]
we would have done all kinds of [ __ ]
with it
but it's just the way things turned out
you know
i'm happy though i'm happy i got i
[ __ ] i got this big ass house in
escrow this [ __ ] is almost a half a
million dollars [ __ ] you know
and i know we can pay for it so
i mean i hope we can pay for it yeah now
we can pay for it we can pay for it
because otherwise i'll just been here
being like give me some more ramen
noodles yeah are we out of ramen worst
case scenario we'll get some of our
friends to move it with us we'll get
some you know that's true we do have
room it's like
if [ __ ] goes down yeah we can at least
get real we got so many [ __ ] help
because this house is big enough to like
have people maybe and our friends are
cool this [ __ ] would be a 24 7 [ __ ]
bdsm sex campaign going on with those
perverted [ __ ] that we'd bring
up in here
[ __ ] we got to keep them out we're
trying to keep them out we're not trying
to bring them in we're trying to keep
them out
them sexy [ __ ] we need to go
back to the club actually well i know
well we haven't been because like i said
we're [ __ ] we're freaking broke we're
[ __ ] broke and i was like dude i can
only afford like booze for home i know
i can't afford like a hundred dollar tab
well it's [ __ ] in the gas i know and
it's a bummer and
december happened thank you victor
picture sent us five dollars and said
get yourself some ramen noodles yeah
right yeah i know i love ramen noodles i
know they don't have much nutritional
value but they are they are delicious
yeah it's the [ __ ] that you add to it
that has all the nutrition
to the restroom
go ahead and finish this go ahead and
[ __ ] keep on working away well thank
you that's that's just kind of what i do
but uh yeah and honestly like even
nowadays i like having the option
of you know i have kindle unlimited um
you know i have a kindle unlimited
subscription so i like the option of
like having
ebooks uh that i can read whatever i'm
actually reading men women and chainsaws
at the moment uh you know so there's
that and there's a lot of books that i
can get for free but
to be honest with you i'm pretty old
school still
i like having an old like print book
i know that's weird i don't mind like
reading stuff online
i will read stuff online all day long
but
there's something kind of cozy about
having the actual book
i'm gonna get a cup of coffee i'm gonna
like sit my chair i'm gonna like read
the [ __ ] i don't know i like that but
you know but i can have it either way
it's fine
yeah so
paradise with the c
it's making me so angry i'm just
he laughs at me but like i'm i'm
seriously
going back to my old school days
all my english teachers [ __ ] loved me
i'm like a [ __ ]
i'm a [ __ ] stickler when it comes to
grammar when it comes to spelling
everything like that because i was a
reader from very young age i learned to
read when i was two
and
you know i started reading ghost stories
and like not too long after that i was
just kind of like oh edgar allan poe i
was all into that kind of [ __ ]
and i read so much as a child that by
the time i started school
um all the vocabulary they were doing
all the grammar they were doing was
second nature to me because i already
seen it like in practice
so uh so people do it nowadays it's
really really jarring it's really
jarring to me like people do like run on
sentences like i read i'll put it up in
a little while
but i did and i'm not saying what the
name is and i'm not saying what it is
because i don't want to like [ __ ] on
independent authors i don't like to do
that because i did like the story but
i did a novella like a christmas novella
and i did a review of it and i read it
and it was really good and it was really
entertaining but the grammar in it
whoo
man
run on sentences
uh commas when there should have been
semicolons
oh my god
it's just oh my god it is really like
[ __ ]
it just made me go like that it's just i
don't know i have a thing about bad
grammar so you know and bad spelling it
just it really irritates me i'm like
this is your native language get with
the program
i get it if it's like not your native
language i'm not going to [ __ ] on you
about that but if it's your native
language you can't even like get that
together holy crap what else are you not
getting jeffrey hart says that the
[ __ ] dukes of hazard made him gay
well victor said that the internet made
him gay
[Laughter]
honestly i kind of had like i had a
thing like for when i was really little
i had a thing about uh because my dad
really liked the dukes of hazzard and i
was just kind of like oh okay that's
cool and like what what were their names
like but like luke and bo or what were
their names
yeah yeah luke right yeah
i can't remember the actors names tom
woppat tom wopat and
jeffrey who is the blonde jeffrey yard
said the incredible hulk did an episode
based on the most endangerous game i
gotta get it oh they probably oh yeah
it'd be an incredible hulk
so like i said that story is just like
it's very ingrained in american culture
a lot of like shows and [ __ ]
particularly back then
did something based on it i grew up
watching bill bixby in the [ __ ]
incredible hulk i need to get that [ __ ]
on [ __ ] blu-ray that's series
or dvd see what that we i haven't
watched in forever it's probably really
good
i don't know
i remember it being good as a kid
incredible hulk yeah i loved that [ __ ]
i loved that show
we should watch it kanavatsalan yeah i
know kind of austin was posting up john
schneider thank you that was it
what is it supergirl power book power
girl what's it [ __ ]
con what was that you posted the other
day i [ __ ] looked at that [ __ ] and i
was going like i remember that [ __ ]
it was two female superheroes back in
the 70s sid marty croft
um
wonder girl super super woman and power
girl something like that
do you remember that one
sort of sid marty croft yeah i think it
was sid marty crawford i remember
sitting marty croft is like [ __ ]
puffing stuff
yeah i think it was sid and marty croft
and i was all that [ __ ] trippy
on [ __ ] facebook i'm [ __ ] i see my
facebook on youtube and i was like i
remember that one
i i [ __ ] saw part of the [ __ ] seat
of one episode i watched [ __ ] uh the
intro and i was like man i remember this
[ __ ] but i can't remember what it was
called now
would it help if you were like um
on acid
no because i would have must have been
about like six or seven when that was no
i'm saying nowadays no i was like six or
seven it's funny how much [ __ ] we
watched when we were kids back then that
the adults that were on it were probably
like really tripping he's saying electro
woman and power girl no i don't think it
was electro woman and power girl
i think i don't know that sounds kind of
familiar i don't think it was that one
[ __ ] con i know you're still on here
[ __ ] what was that [ __ ] you just
[ __ ] posted a couple days ago on
youtube it was something or other and
and power girl something like
maybe it was electro woman yeah yeah
yeah electro woman and power girl i told
you exactly what it was
yes see because i remember elektra
electro had sex with her dad
why is there a [ __ ]
why is there a [ __ ] wait what
in in greek mythology electro had sex
with her dad well i know that but it's
just why is there a superhero
named after elektra
you know incest is best it was in sas
[ __ ] yeah yeah
i don't mean that literally youtube it's
just that and [ __ ] and they were both
cute these are like 70s cuties and [ __ ]
and power girls supposed to be
pretending
uh i don't know but they didn't show us
and power girls just like she's 12. but
i [ __ ] i [ __ ]
i googled it real quick to see how old
these people were at the time she's like
30 and she's playing like a 12 year old
that checks out i was like wait a minute
what
you know well it's just kind of like
back in the 50s when all these moves
like teenagers from outer space and
they're all like [ __ ] 40. they're all
in their 30s and 40s jesus christ yeah
they all had like [ __ ] that's a woman
of power lions china girl
oh yeah yeah
that's right
that's right yeah okay cece khan
khan's down in [ __ ] tijuana mexico
but he understands north american
culture quite a bit
we're we're the same age he and i
[ __ ] you know we're friends we talk
off off show a lot
[ __ ] got two sons that look
like they belong in hollywood like old
hollywood
we're talking about tom cruise those are
some handsome [ __ ] his sons are
[ __ ] there
he's on he's got a youtube channel but
what he does is he uploads old forgotten
series
and one of them is a british series what
was it called space queens is a british
series
he was uploading that one and they
didn't take it down as far as i know
and it's it was a british series kind of
like doctor who but it was like an
all-fema from the 70s all-female
heroes
in space space queens or space he'll
remember what it is he would love it i
saw that [ __ ] go up and i was like wow
what is this i've never seen it before
and uh just kind of went through it real
quick and i was like man i gotta go back
and watch some of this [ __ ] but there's
so much product out there now you can't
keep up with all this [ __ ]
well that's what i'm saying that's the
problem if you lived forever yeah you
would not
get i mean my movie list and book
reading list is so long that i will
never live long enough he just replied
it's called star maidens
and star maidens looked really [ __ ]
cool it had a very high budget it's
british it's british bbc oh i love
british star maidens
yeah it's kind of like space 1999 okay
but it was like nothing but [ __ ]
british hotties in space
uh
british high school
british in space being alpha
they were like being alpha at the time
they were like no we run this [ __ ] here
all right yeah yeah yeah it was cool it
looked like it was like 1975 76 right
chicks kicking off space
british chicks kicking ass
throwing our boobies about victor said
he never got a doctor who was boring you
didn't get the right doctor who you got
to start off with [ __ ]
well there have been a lot of different
doctor who's yeah for me doctor who is
always tom baker
tom baker i mean he's like the nipples
ultra yeah
and you had to start with the tom baker
and how he i like christopher eccleston
also yeah um i like a lot of the later
ones too but
my cousin got me into that [ __ ] back in
the old days
back in the 70s or 80s when the only way
we could get doctor who was on pbs
um my cousin who was two years older
got me into it yeah they're asking who
is behind me that's mirror spock that's
spock from the mirror universe sophie
sent me that for my birthday last year
right and if you don't know if you don't
know the original series of star trek
that was the spock from the mirror
universe i wouldn't say they were the
evil spock they were the third world
spock
yeah it was
uh they were still kind of medieval in a
certain way they were [ __ ]
kind of the
they weren't evil they were just
more uh
more
what's good they were more human that's
a good way to put it i don't know if
that's a good way no they were very
human they were just not
elevated in a certain way they were
fighting against they were
they were kind of medieval in a certain
way yeah they were kind of medieval sure
and that was the whole episode that was
the whole reason for the mirror universe
is to show you that
that version
of humanity is a reality because a lot
of the world is like that and it and
they were not bad even though bad things
happened
their problems were very different they
their problems could not be solved by
reason and logic a lot of times their
problems had to be solved by force
and terror
which is that's the way a lot of the
world is
and that was what the part of the genius
of star trek is to [ __ ]
to recognize that
idealism always doesn't work
it's situational
i think that sophie sent me that
because
spock is like my
ideal man in a lot of ways yeah she's
spock actually she's the female spock
which is funny because my ex-husband
used to call me that yeah she's the
female spock so yeah tell me that but uh
i took it as a compliment he he meant it
as an insult but i took it as a
compliment so yeah take that as you
understand it i understand but um
honestly like from the original like i
love the original star treks here i'm
not like a trek i don't wouldn't call
myself a trekkie
but i love the original series
and spock is like my spirit animal
every time like we watched the original
series we watched it like three or four
times at this point
every time like spock does some [ __ ] i'm
just kind of like he's right why don't
you like [ __ ] just listen
just listen
so
i love spock but the mirror universe
spock
oh that's so cool he did some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] but yeah with the beard yeah
i'm i like it i like it it was it was
foxy
mirror universe although he's foxy
without the beard but you know mirror
universe spock is still spock that spock
is the situation is different
the situation and the culture is
different
which that is [ __ ] beautiful
um the writers of the original series
understood
god damn i love star trek they
understood the reality of the world
growing up in south america i will tell
you that the mirror universe is a
reality the star trek mirror universe is
the reality
for most of the world especially back in
those days
that's the way it really was they
weren't bad people the situation was
different
yeah that was the difference
it's the situation
certain you know
the federation's way wouldn't work
in their world not for everybody not in
their world not for everybody not in
their world yeah
uh thornton's and says i have kindle but
i love print books yeah i'm the same
it's like i like having the option
of
because there's a lot of books that are
available on kindle unlimited that i
wouldn't necessarily buy
but i would still like to read them so i
like that they're still available like
for me to read for free
um so that's cool but
honestly if
if it's a book i really want to read i'm
just going to buy the print version
because i would really prefer to
reading the pro version victor says i
keep forgetting to bring house of leaves
with me to my part-time job a lot of
downtime here
honestly house of leaves
i know it's too late
i wish
that i could have written something as
culturally impactful
as house of leaves because house of
leaves
um that's kind of like all the [ __ ] i
like
it's like it was a story that was like
creepy and it was also kind of like meta
and it was like graphically designed to
reflect the content
and i
love that
i love that and i wish i had thought of
it
um
prior to mark danielski thinking of it
but i did not
um
[Music]
so every time i read that every time i
pull that book out of my shelves because
i do have the print version obviously
uh every time i pull that book out
it's kind of like
with the reverence that some people like
bring out the like the bible or whatever
because it's just kind of like
this is like the
distillation
of
story meeting
uh
medium and i'm really really into that
so i love that somebody did that it took
him 10 years to do it i get that
uh and i respect that
and
i just wish i'd thought of it
honestly it just kind of makes me mad in
the comments section they're fighting
they're saying that [ __ ] star trek
was like a [ __ ] utopian fantasy
other people are saying that the mirror
universe was kind of like backwards no
what the deal was
is that star trek
was
northern
northern american progressive idealism
that that's what
we were hoping for
and in that series
the mirror universe
was kind of like the developing world's
a reality
so you had
idealism and reality that's
and we have to come to terms with that
in america
because reality [ __ ] dictates what
reality is not ideology well honestly
and like i said i you know uh
all right so let's kind of get into this
because somebody said
um
you know it's like the liberals wet
dream like look um i don't know if you
guys know
i'm a liberal so i don't know if you
guys are like [ __ ] [ __ ] on me or
whatever better they're not um but it's
the thing about it though is i kind of
feel like people have a weird uh concept
of liberals i don't really know if
y'all know what a liberal really is i
kind of feel like it's become like a
i i don't know if it's some kind of like
term that people use to like uh cast
dispersions on people at this point
true liberalism is almost like me
in some ways which is nothing i think so
do what you want
and well i don't know sort of like in
some ways but honestly um
but i will own that term because i feel
like i don't like
that it's become
a term of um you know it's kind of like
become an insult
and so i'm just kind of like gonna take
it back because
you know uh i'm gonna do that but
i kind of feel like liberals we know
uh what human nature is like
we know what human nature is like
um so it's not like we're
being idealistic just for the sake of
being we think that we can rise above
people's base or instincts we're not
saying that
it's just that we have to like mitigate
people's baser instincts you don't want
like a whole
[ __ ] society based on that because
that would obviously suck for everyone
um we're trying to get to a point where
most people are living
you know at least as good as can be
expected
uh without too much hardship
um you know and that's all that really
anybody can ask for
uh i don't really know if i don't know i
i kind of feel like people have like
weird
i don't know i kind of feel like people
have like weird
oh there's all this kind of like weird
uh political kind of [ __ ] about like
terms nowadays
and i'm not really sure
how to approach that i don't really like
to get into political [ __ ] on the show
because
we don't agree on [ __ ] me and him
so
i don't know
but
we've gotten a long way away from the
zodiac killer which i was trying to get
back to i don't really see things in
terms of politics
people like to cast things in terms of
they like to cast things in
in political terms i don't see things in
politics because
i'm far too primitive for politics okay
there is only reality in fantasy
that's how i see things
i kind of like to
focus more on reality
the way things really are
right but
i don't know i i kind of feel like uh
terms have been
redefined to a point where they don't
really mean anything anymore
or they mean different things to
different sides so i'm not really sure
how productive that is to like talk
about things in terms of
a particular word because that doesn't
mean the same thing
to
whatever your belief system is
you know what i mean yeah
miguel says so the zodiac killer
a democrat or a republican nowadays
probably a republican i'm sure um
gun nut
uh people
shooting people at random i don't know
that's theirs i don't think so either
either way or another no neither
pervert more than anything else
i don't know i i don't even know if i'd
so much call him a pervert he was just
like someone who was
power hungry
power mad uh someone who was uh
obviously inadequate in some way we
don't really know sexually or that dude
or in an adjacent way and was taking it
out yeah in a way
well i don't
the fact that he was targeting couples
is
instructive if you look at if you look
at serial killers from the past they
don't have political affiliations they
don't even have
a concept of political ideas they're not
thinking like that because politics have
to do with [ __ ] large amounts of
people multitudes and masses and
societies
serial killers don't think like that
they're the ultimate individualists they
don't care about your politics or even
their politics well they don't care
about anything they don't care about any
of that the only thing they care about
is that is the nut that they're getting
whether or not they're coming
that's it
if they come or if they [ __ ]
uh are powerful that's the only thing
they're worried about they don't care
about any politics this is something
that
normal people care about they don't give
a [ __ ] about that
yeah i kind of feel like serial killers
to a large extent
they're so totally about themselves yeah
politics is about society they don't
know anything about that
yeah that's a good way of putting it
politics uh assumes right that you
actually like care about or at least
give lip service to caring about yeah
society aren't yeah these dudes are
nothing um and serial killers not so
much uh that's more like a narcissistic
yeah i only care about my own right
meeting my own needs right that's my own
thing yeah right
so yeah
so by that token i don't think they meet
any standards of like political party
right now somebody like [ __ ] btk
[ __ ] raider raider would probably
register as a republican
but that's because he would want to be
seen as a as an upstanding person who
cares about [ __ ] law and order
and [ __ ] uh
uh [ __ ] like that
so but the thing is is that it's not
that they actually believe that
they know you see them as right
that's all it is that's what i mean
it's all uh style over subsidies right
right uh no they don't actually care
about that no they just want everyone to
think that they care about it right
exactly it's all
right
right
so yeah and that's what i was that's
going back to what i was saying earlier
um there were a couple of politicians
i'm not naming them by name there were a
couple of polishes particularly in
florida
back in the 80s
that were very very concerned suddenly
about satanic panic they were very
concerned about pornography child porn
stuff like that then it came out later
on that surprise
they were super super into
porn or child porn
of their own you know what i mean
uh which
no one was shocked
uh because they made such a big [ __ ]
show about it
uh you know
where were the party most of them not
gonna say what it was but most of y'all
can probably guess
um
i'll need another drink in a second i'll
make you want to come back uh yeah btk
would lean republican yeah i kind of
feel like that was kind of the thing
um
i don't know man it's just kind of like
yeah thornton says that yeah narcissist
only allegiance to self i kind of yeah i
kind of feel like they've
kind of taken themselves out of
the realm of
human
whatever like you know the spectrum
all right so let me get it like while
he's not here to distract me
let me talk about some new [ __ ] that
came out about the zodiac because
you know we have have we been talking
about xanax maybe like 10 of the [ __ ]
everybody knows about the zodiac [ __ ]
but
uh we talked about
somebody figuring out one of the zodiac
ciphers which was kind of a big deal
they figured it out people are kind of
like oh i don't know but it does kind of
sound like his [ __ ] and he had this all
the same misspellings that was where we
got sidetracked
so here's the big thing and this is why
everybody was asking us to
do a zodiac revisited october of 2021
only a couple months ago
there was a team
of law enforcement investigators called
the case breakers this is 40
ish
uh people
they're all kind of like
uh
this was started back in 2011 and i
guess it was kind of like a two like a
married couple that were documentary
filmmakers thomas and donna colbert
and they started this whole like cold
case
independent kind of thing so they were
trying to like get people into
you know looking into cold cases so they
brought in like 40ish
people that were retired
law enforcement uh forensic scientists
fbi dudes that were retired legal people
military intelligence
journalists all those kind of people so
they want to like bring all these people
on so they kind of started this
unofficial whatever
uh you know
thing called the case breakers and these
were people that were volunteering they
didn't get paid as far as i know
uh they volunteered their time to look
into like cold cases and one of the
things they looked into
was the zodiac case
so october 21 2021
uh the case breakers
come forward and they say look
we think we know
who the zodiac killer was
thank you
they claimed the now when they first
came to the media with this
they said we went to
uh a bunch of officials who were working
it's mainly like the fbi and like you
know the
law enforcement in the cities where the
murders took place
they're like we approached them and
allegedly i don't know if this is true
this is what they said
allegedly uh they said they don't want
to cooperate
with the investigation
uh even though according to the fbi and
everything like the case is still open
so you know
take of that we will
so
this cold case team
uh led by thomas colbert who's you know
him and his wife are kind of like
running the whole
case breakers thing
they apparently got a tip
from one of their longtime sources that
they had figured out
that the dude that was the zodiac was
apparently allegedly
supposedly
this dude named gary francis
post
let's see how sure we are
that this is who this really is
uh apparently according to this cold
case uh
group
they said oh we have all of this
evidence you guys so much evidence
so let's see
now uh so they say prior to his death he
died in 2018 just saying that uh right
now so he's dead he can't defend himself
not saying he's a good dude because he
was arrested for some other [ __ ] so
but you know i'm just saying i'm not
saying he's a zodiac i don't know
he died in 2018
prior to his death
allegedly this dude
had given away a whole bunch of weapons
and a whole bunch of
bullets ammo [ __ ] like that
that maybe allegedly could have provided
some uh evidence in the case
little weird maybe
uh this is a quote
from
the
uh
press release that the case breakers
released
old associates of the house painter he
was a house painter that was his job
house painter alleged serial killer at
least they said that
claimed that a few years prior to post's
2018 death at 80
he had quietly given away his weapons
pistol parts gun powder bullets and
shell casings more than a thousand
involving 25 different uh
calibers
to his favorite locals
and most of these particular gifts
have remained in basements and closets
untouched
ever since
so they think this is a little
suspicious
that
when the dude knew he was maybe gonna
die or knew he was going to
because what i'll get into this in in a
bit but because he got arrested a couple
years before that but he uh he was old
so he was going to
a home essentially
so he's kind of like hey i have all this
ammo and i have this
you know all these guns and stuff so
here you have that you have that you
have that so that seems a little fishy
but it's not that's not
that doesn't mean anything just saying
so
they thought that was suspicious
they also think
that uh this dude was the guy that was
responsible which i brought up earlier
for killing oh there's pokey i got pokey
up on the lap oh what you doing look at
her little things look at that baby look
at that baby yeah
she's all chill yeah
she's like okay
she loves daddy did you tell them about
what happened what
when you tried to take her outside to
check the mail with her oh no yeah i
took her out to the mailbox with me i
had her up on my shoulder
walking out she was on his shoulder
and he was like oh i gotta go check the
mail you want to come with me check the
mail she's like okay whatever i'm just
like sitting on your shoulder i walk
around to the front to the mailbox we
have like a really long like driveway
she's sitting up on my shoulder and i
got her and i opened the mailbox and me
opened the mailbox scared the [ __ ] out
of her she went ah and she jumped up she
tore me [ __ ] up yeah he's got cuts
all over his life first just open in the
mailbox she's like
because you know cats are psycho she's a
little jealous and she runs sideways
along the road and goes to the [ __ ]
about
20 30 feet you go
to my side and stops just goes bam
daddy like it's the end of the world and
i'm like what are you talking about
we're out here in front of the house
well the outside is not the outside of
the house that she's using yeah she's
not used to that outside it's a
different outside she hasn't been
outside since we moved to the front door
and she's just frozen wow
and walk to the front door and then
i felt way worse for her than i did for
you with your cut up on you yeah and
then she just jumps into the house and
[ __ ] goes [ __ ] back in the house
i'm back in the house
she doesn't like to go outside you don't
want to go outside pokey where'd you go
that's fine though she can stay in here
with mama i didn't really like her going
outside at the old house either yeah so
the house pookie i'm not really a fan of
her going outside here especially
because
the house that we have now it's just
like there's no
there's nothing for her to hide in yeah
um you know there's no like cool little
corners or nothing it's all like open
yeah come here and there's everybody and
there's bears glasses over here wow yeah
we're in the woods pokey yeah yeah you
stay in here with mama yeah
she's like okay
that's okay she doesn't mind
i just thought it was weird that you
were too seriously though if you had
taken her outside of the mailbox and she
got hit by a car i would have never
forgotten there's no cars out there i
would never
there's no car
well every now and then there's cars
they wouldn't
they would just slow down
holy crap yeah
i mean seriously you have fun pookie
yeah she's like what i'm thinking about
it she's sick go back to the story jenny
thank you go back today
look at her she's so distracting
yeah so one of the things that clued
them in was that this dude
had given away
allegedly a [ __ ] ton of his guns and
ammo
before he died okay
weird but not
that doesn't mean anything
um
they also think now this is kind of
interesting
so they also think
that this dude uh for sure
was behind the murder of sherry joe
bates in 1966 on halloween 1966 which is
in riverside
now interestingly
uh authorities like the fbi the cops
that are kind of like on the zodiac case
they don't necessarily
think that the zodiac was responsible
for her murder she's kind of one of
those murders that is like
maybe that was him but maybe not because
the mo was a little bit different so
even if
this dude
allegedly
had done the sherry joe bates murder
that doesn't necessarily think you know
lead to he was the zodiac because
they're not sure
that those were the same killer
but the thing about it though uh so
sherry joe bates she was 18 years old
and she got found like we talked about
on the zodiac show i think where she was
uh you know she drove to the library in
her uh you know vw or whatever and then
she got murdered in an alley and they
found her uh you know in the alley by
the campus or by the library
and so
basically the cops were like we don't
think the same person
did those two so
we're not entirely sure like how much we
want to like be into this
theory
but
uh a bunch of coincidences
do connect uh the sherry j sherry joe
bates murder
and
gary post
the person who is
allegedly
the zodiac killer this is the big story
that came out
in late 2021
uh gary post was in the air force he was
a veteran in the air force
uh he got a medical checkup for a gun
incident at a hospital that was located
15 minutes away from
where the bates murder scene was at
about the same time
as that murder occurred
uh now at the murder site of the sheri
jovate's uh crime as i believe we talked
about on the zodiac uh
show
they found a wristwatch with paint
splatter on it and they found that
and
it is uh perhaps
interesting to note that post was a
house painter
by trade
he had painted houses for more than 40
years
and they also found at the site a heel
print from a military-style boot
the
size and style of which
matched one
that were
uh the same as some of the ones from the
other zodiac crime scenes and
was apparently the same size
as gary post-war
and as i mentioned earlier
he
was in the military so it would have not
been crazy to think that he had some
boots that were kind of like that
now this is interesting and i don't
think i brought this up on the earlier
uh
show
because this was a crime that i wasn't
actually aware of
so there was actually a murderer that
took place in 1962
and this is very
zodiac-esque
in this
in the same
line as the paul stein murder
but it doesn't get brought up a lot uh
in a lot of zodiac stuff
so this is a guy that was named ray
davis he was a cab driver this is 1962.
and what happened with this this dude
got murdered now before he got murdered
um the police allegedly received a phone
call
where
a a person told them
to expect a
quote-unquote baffling crime
uh and then a little bit later this
happened
so ray davis
uh he was estranged from his wife he
lived with his brother
uh in oceanside california now he was a
cab driver so a little past 11 p.m
uh he worked for checker cab he works up
he picks up a fair
uh at a downtown cab stand on mission
avenue pro probably
and he says yeah i'm picking up a dude
i'm driving them to oceanside
and after this dispatch he was never
heard from again
early the next morning they found his
body
uh in the upscale neighborhood of south
saint malo in oceanside
this was a fun fact their first gated
community
uh he had been shot twice from the back
seat of the cab
one shot to the back
uh and the other to his head
so somebody in the back seat is
obviously shot
and as i said this was
before
uh the
canonical zodiac murders but very
similar to the paul stein murder gotta
say
cab driver
and uh somebody that warned the cops
that he was gonna do it ahead of time
so a little weird
so uh so the guy gets shot and he gets
dumped
in an alley behind pacific street
now the cab driver was not robbed
so
again what was the motive
you know if somebody shoots a cap like
i'm not saying this is good but if
somebody shoots a cab driver and then
takes all their money
no one's gonna question why they shot
the cab driver
this one though he didn't take the money
he shot the cab driver and dumped him in
an alley and just didn't take any money
so
again a little strange
uh so
some people have pointed out this is
very similar to
the paul stein murder which
while not initially attributed to the
zodiac even though zodiac like zodiac
took credit for it three days later so
then everybody kind of like you know
he's one of the canonical ones now but
this is like very similar
uh it's also a cab driver shot to death
in a wealthy area of the city
uh
this is another one where he calls
the cops and takes credit for the murder
before it happens and after it happens
uh
openly stating that he's uh going to
baffle the police that was his intention
um he also when he called said that his
next crime was oh i'm gonna shoot a
random bus driver which that was another
zodiac thing that he did uh he
you know i'm gonna stop a bus and i'm
going to like shoot the kids while they
come bouncing out that was another thing
that you said so he uh targeted bus
drivers or buses in general
um no obvious motive and the same uh
caliber weapon disease 22 weapon and a
long rifle uh in the same killing so i
must say that the [ __ ] whole thing
about attacking buses i think was
fantasy he never did sure but um yeah
but he didn't do it in this case either
but this is still a cab driver
that and then he
said to the police
hey i killed this cab driver but i i'm
gonna do this and that was like some
other [ __ ] that the zodiac did right
so and this was earlier
than the uh canonical zodiac murders
okay so i'm surprised that this one is
not brought up more
uh because this is one i hadn't actually
heard of this one but i like um
when i looked into it i'm like yeah this
one's like very very similar
it might not be related i don't know
but um when i was looking into
the gary post stuff
this was uh another murder that came up
that hasn't been solved as far as i know
and
it's very similar to not zodiacs cannot
like you know
better known murders but at least like
the paul steinberg like the the cab
driver or whatever
so
i don't know this seems like kind of
similar no motive
similar kind of like threats it's that
kind of [ __ ]
so
gary post let's talk about him a little
bit
so this dude
um he was actually i guess was clued
into the code breaker or the case
breakers
group
by an anonymous tip
now
the thing about the case breakers is
like they came out with it and
they
you know sent out a press release
and a lot of the evidence that they said
that they had
was kind of like well
we have xyz evidence but
one of our members has a book coming out
or we can't let so i kind of feel like
they were
leaving a lot of [ __ ]
out like as a tease it was kind of like
a tease
so i don't know how seriously to take
these allegations is all i'm saying
um but one thing i will note that gary
post the guy that they're accusing of
being this he's dead so like i said i
don't he died in 2018. so i'm not saying
he was a zodiac i'm just saying
um but one thing he did do
february 2016 they did arrest him
uh
on felony domestic violence he had
actually
um allegedly he had been abusing his
wife of many years for a long time
and they arrested him on this particular
uh day
for pushing his
70 odd-year-old wife down the stairs
which you know nice
uh so he had done that and i guess she
either got sick of it or somebody else
was there and she was then they were
just kind of like they were sick of it
so the cops came they arrested him uh
you know i think she lived but
she was kind of all [ __ ] up that he'd
like push her down the stairs but
allegedly he'd been abusing her for many
years at this uh stage
now when they arrested him in 2016 he
was 78
years old
what they did they took him into custody
and apparently
they when they assessed him
uh
he's kind of like a little saddled with
dementia let's say that
so they ended up putting him
um and when he came up to like stand
trial they were like yeah he's not um
competent to stand trial because of
dementia so they ended up putting him in
essentially an old folks home or a
psychiatric home
and he ended up dying a couple years
after he was arrested
um so they didn't think that he was like
mentally all there enough
not excusing pushing his [ __ ] wife
down the stairs because
according to several other witnesses who
were there it's like yeah that was kind
of like a common thing for him he was
kind of a spousal abuser
which you know
not good i'm not saying that means he
was a zodiac but you know that means
he's probably not a real good person
now what ended up happening was that
because he got arrested in early 2016
in early 2017
uh when his case was going through the
court
thing like when they were trying to
figure out what to do with the dude
because he was old
uh the newspaper gets contacted by a
news anchor named dale julin
and he said
well you know i've heard there's like
some rumors going around that this dude
is actually the zodiac
so what they ended up doing was they
started going back and they got like all
these [ __ ] affidavits from all these
supposed witnesses who
i don't know like knew of some very [ __ ]
that was going on
now the affidavits that uh were filed in
court
there were a couple from there was a
dude that had lived in groveland and he
said
um that gary post
had told him
that he was the zodiac killer
and he said if you tell anybody i'm
going to kill you
uh so that was like one of the
affidavits that was filed like i'm the
zodiac don't tell anybody
um also there were a couple of
affidavits from former cell mates of his
because i guess he'd been a prison
before
um and they said
yeah he also told us that he was a
zodiac and said not to tell anybody but
we're telling you and you know that's
that whole thing so they had affidavits
from those people also
so
they got a lot of those affidavits the
newspaper
i think they ran them but they're like
look it's like we can't confirm these
it's like we don't have any outside
verification so we're just like telling
you that right now
now uh gary post gets placed in a
nursing home
uh called golden living
i love that i love the names they come
up with for these [ __ ]
nursing homes
golden living that was the place they
put him in this they put him uh there in
2017. now they had to put him in a
conservatorship because he apparently
wasn't all there enough to have a [ __ ]
together enough to you know do his own
[ __ ]
uh so we had to have somebody like a
public guardian that like appointed that
would like look over his ship
so they did that
uh so he ended up dying in august of
2018. so
at that point they officially dismissed
the
domestic violence case that was still
pending against him
because
he's dead now so there's nothing they
can do about it
now at this point they're kind of like
well
it's like look
he's an old dude he was like super frail
he didn't really seem to know what was
going on at the time all this was going
on
but the case breakers these cold case
investigators that
uh seem to believe that this is the
zodiac killer
some of the things okay so one of the
things why they think this is the zodiac
killer
one of the first things you remember
that very very famous
uh you know kind of like uh police
sketch of the zodiac of like some of the
earlier uh people that had seen him
and so it was like this you know this
dude and he's like has the kind of
glasses and he has like the [ __ ]
forehead and whatever now he has like a
couple lines on the forehead right now
um
okay any normal person would just think
that was kind of like wrinkles on the
forehead
that's what i thought
but
one thing that was like really big deal
in
this uh case
was that
gary post had been in a car accident
when he was younger
and he had a big scar
on his forehead
that kind of looked like
the one that was in the original zodiac
sketches
like i said you remember the zodiac
sketches it had like the kind of [ __ ]
yeah the line and the line so he had if
you see photos you can look online and
like just put in gary france's post with
an e at the end
and
they'll show you like the original
sketch and the
like i get it okay but
i don't know i never felt like when i
looked at the zodiac sketches i never
thought that was a
scar i always thought it was like
wrinkles like forehead wrinkles
yeah i thought it was a scar though
um well that's what they're saying
they're saying well gary post had a
really prominent
scar on his forehead
that he obtained allegedly from a car
accident
and so maybe that's what people were
describing but the thing about it was
that i kind of feel like the original
sketches
i don't know
i mean i'm going back and i'm trying to
remember i don't think that like the
people that actually saw the dude
without the mask on
i don't think any of them specifically
said he had a big scar on his forehead i
kind of feel like maybe the
maybe the artist just drew that on there
just because they assumed it would be
there or like they just thought
everybody like that age would have
lines on their forehead i'm not really
sure i don't really know if anybody
described there being scars in their
forehead i'm just saying but that's one
of the one of the things that they're
kind of like uh running with
that this dude had a big scar on his
forehead and like i said if you if you
google
his name you'll see the you know you'll
see he does have like a big scar on his
forehead which
i don't know but i don't know if anybody
like described that though
so there was that
now
uh i'm not really sure like okay there
were a couple other things too
in the sense that
yes he was allegedly a domestic abuser
like some people
that came forward
uh
for example like his neighbor
said oh now that i'm i was a teenager
when i grew up next to him at the time
but i was like kind of thinking oh maybe
now that i'm thinking about it in
retrospect
yeah maybe he was a zodiac yeah he was
like terrible to his wife and he used to
beat her up all the time like i said he
got arrested for like pushing others
pushing her down the stairs
but
i don't know like a lot of this is kind
of like witness i'm not saying that he
wasn't the zodiac i'm just saying i'm
not sure how
airtight this case is they don't have
any dna or anything like that
um
so because honestly the case breakers
come forward and they're like uh we
think we've solved it
we have all this like x y and z and we
like this dude was in the area and they
have like a lot of circumstantial
evidence i'm not saying that but a lot
of their evidence is
witness stuff a lot of is like people
that
and there's also kind of like
there's kind of like a crazy offshoot
where
okay so this is like some [ __ ] that was
reported by some maybe not as credible
sources like the daily mail and stuff
where it was kind of like well that's
like the british right-wing paper and
it's like nobody believes that anything
that they print so it's kind of like
they kind of said oh well
it's not only that not only was this
dude the zodiac but he also had
a whole like bunch of people that he was
grooming
to be like his murder posse
because they can't just have one serial
killer they have to like
make like a big whole thing about it
like make a conspiracy about it so it
was that whole whole thing so some
witnesses that came forward said oh my
god like this dude he groomed me into
being a killer for him and instead of
i'm not saying that's impossible i'm
just saying that's probably that's very
unlikely so i don't know so i don't know
how much
the thing about it though is that when
the code breakers or the case breakers
came forward
um some of the [ __ ] that they said
they don't have one they don't have any
dna it which is a big thing
uh two all they have is a press release
and some of the stuff that they said
like um
one woman that is on the case breakers
team alleged and allegedly
she's kind of like a code breaker
like secret service whatever
um you know from the military she's like
oh we have all this other evidence but
we can't say it because you know one of
our members is like publishing a book
about it
um
one of her claims
is that
one of the ciphers that they haven't
figured out yet
you can only figure out
if you already know
what gary post's name is
but
she won't elaborate
onto how that actually
maps out you know what i'm saying she's
like well i'm not gonna say anything
about that until the book comes out
because one of our members is publishing
a book about that and
um
you know but you have to know the dude's
actual name which is gary francis post
before a lot of the ciphers will make
sense because his name
is the key for figuring stuff out that's
pretty much all she will say but she
won't
elaborate because it's
some stuff that's going to be published
later so like i said there
i kind of feel like
you know i don't like to [ __ ] on anybody
but it really does kind of feel like
they're just trying to get publicity and
honestly
gonna say
uh tom voigt the guy that runs zodiac
killer i think it's a zodiac killer.com
and he's been
compiling all the evidence about the
zodiac murders for the past shipment 25
years he's had a website
and he's it's a massive
massive website it's like a huge
database he's super into it and he's
been doing it for 20 odd years
um
when this
information came out uh about the case
breakers and they said that they'd
figured out who it was because of the
forehead scar and because of some other
information that they won't disclose
because yadda yadda we're gonna like
publish the [ __ ] later on
uh he was not
having it
he's basically
uh he says and the fbi wasn't having it
either like when the announcement was
made like i said it wasn't
it wasn't anything that was like you
know when d'angelo got caught and
they're like look it's kind of like we
have the dna it's all this the zodiac
thing it was just
i mean i remember hearing about it and i
was like they caught the zodiac but it
wasn't it was a press release
from an independent group
that was not affiliated with the fbi or
with anybody that was working on the
case
fbi came forward very shortly after and
said look this case is still open uh
this is not
you know we don't know this might be
true we don't know we haven't
investigated it so don't get excited
basically that's what they said
uh so don't we it's still open uh we
don't we don't know anything about this
so that's what they said
tom voight who is the guy that has uh
run zodiackiller.com for 25 years
uh he did an interview with rolling
stone
and he basically said when the
claims about that uh
you know that the zodiac killer been
found he called them quote unquote
hot garbage
uh or quote unquote completely bogus
he said why did this get coverage uh
there's no dna there's no backing
evidence all you have is like the
forehead scar and some other
supposed evidence that you're not
telling us because somebody's publishing
a book about it later
his quote was i love this
his quote
he says
just a tip
if you want to get on fox news or tmz
just pick a popular cold case declare
with certainty that you have solved it
put out an overly complicated press
release and wait
that was his quote and honestly i'm not
gonna argue with that
uh because it seemed to work in this
situation
uh according to the fbi
this is
uh
this is a dude that was not on their
radar previously at least not as far as
they're willing to admit
they don't have any dna evidence uh
backing this up
could this dude be the zodiac sure
um
but the fbi is not giving anything up
about it so i don't know this is an
independent group that came up with this
[ __ ]
uh they just did a press release
um
and a lot of media picked up on it
so had they solved it i don't know the
dude's dead
so i'm not really sure if they're ever
gonna figure it out
but
i don't know like some of the people on
the team
and i'm not disparaging everybody that's
on the team there's 40 [ __ ] people on
the case breakers team
some of them used to be in the fbi some
of like military intelligence some of
them used to be cops [ __ ] like that
they're doing [ __ ] you know it's
freelance uh you know for free or
volunteering kind of [ __ ]
um
and some of them are convinced that this
is the dude
but
i don't know i i don't know
i don't know if they've caught him or
not honestly to be honest
when we did the show on
the zodiac back in 2018
i don't know i don't know if you showed
me anything other than
that [ __ ] dude that they thought that
it was
did he do all of them i don't know but
i kind of i i wish that they would
figure out who it is but through dna i
want to be certain
i want to be certain that that's who it
is i don't just want to be like oh
somebody has like a weird scar on their
forehead
that's lame yeah oh and i have more
evidence but i can't show it to you now
because
we're going to like publish some books
later and we don't want everybody
knowing all the information
so i'm kind of feeling like this might
be
allegedly
this might be another hodel situation
where
my dad is dead so i'm going to link him
to every unsolved
serial killer case in the world because
i just want to like make some [ __ ]
money look i get that everybody needs
money i'm not disparaging that okay
you want to disparage your dead debt
maybe your dad dad was an [ __ ] i
don't know and maybe he was like yeah he
did all the [ __ ]
and you want to like write a book about
it if you can sell that [ __ ] okay more
power to you
but
i don't know how much credence
we want to give to an end and i'm not
disparaging again
the uh you know career accomplishments
of all the people that are on this team
but
accusing somebody of something and
proving it are two completely different
things yeah now i am willing to give you
that the person that figured out the
the uh the cipher
you probably nailed that that sounds
like the zodiac that's him um yeah that
sounds like some [ __ ] that he would yeah
and that
again that sounds like some [ __ ] that he
would have said in his [ __ ] yeah
figure out these ciphers and i'll tell
you my identity he's not gonna do that
no it's just like some [ __ ] about
how he likes to kill people blah blah
blah like it says like some education no
the cipher that's that's that oh yeah
i'm not disputing that at all that
sounds absolutely started to [ __ ]
dictate that [ __ ] to me i was like yeah
that's that same [ __ ] it's the
same douchey [ __ ] yeah that's
just so douchey yeah do she love her
khan is [ __ ] he's asking me about
like
to worms and tequila and i said [ __ ]
there are no worms at tequila because
yeah i'm testing your mexican knowledge
oh yeah yeah no the worms were from
mezcal
all right they're not in tequila that's
a [ __ ] gringo [ __ ] concept
from back in the 70s up from california
all right
now you can go to tijuana and go to the
damn
tourist traps and find
some [ __ ] [ __ ] tequila with it
with a worm in it there's their
mexicans are taking the piss out of you
man
no
no [ __ ] tequila never has a worm in
it that's mescal
tequila is the [ __ ]
mexican version of [ __ ] single malt
scotch whiskey it's [ __ ] classy
there's only [ __ ] three different
types of [ __ ] tequila
silver
that's
like their version of
vodka you mix that all right then
there's reposado which is kind of like
a slightly yellow
you can mix it but you're not really
supposed to i mix it it'd be like
jornitos reposado that's good
and then there's gold
which they call that [ __ ] um well we
call it gold the mexicans call it uh
khan help me out but but that's their
version of a [ __ ] it's a flavored
tequila
it it doesn't have to be aged
that's that's a strong point of tequila
but that's their version of whiskey they
drink that on the rocks
um
ancho i think that's what it's called
gold we call it gold they call it anjo
which is angel
angel and uh that's just on the rocks
like corvo gold
we mix it here
but mexicans are kind of like cuervo
gold no that's not really that's not
really the query
that just reminds me like the queer
steely dance [ __ ]
kind of like the [ __ ] uh uh cuervo
gold is kind of like uh the equivalent
of [ __ ] jack daniels
of american whiskey where i don't know i
like jack daniels and i don't like
tequila jack daniel's not that great
it's not but not that great for american
whiskies no 57 would be a good one well
yeah top 57 i don't know did they make
that anymore that's canadian that's
canadian
yeah yeah i used to work for the company
that distributed it it's canadian i said
is it canadian it's canadian it's
canadian i used to work for the company
that distributed it in america but that
company went out of business as far as i
know so i don't know if they still and
they had maple versions which were
really good i'm trying to think of an
american whiskey you mixed it with
orange juice and then you put a slice of
bacon
on the side like a lime a good american
whiskey would be maker's mark they're
pretty good
um they have a bunch of different
flavors
but
you know american whiskey's come and go
most of the real
famous american whiskey names are
corporate owned
and they're kind of like coca-cola where
they're not craft you know i mean
honestly nowadays if you're really into
beer or if you're really into liquor
yeah um wherever you live you can
probably find some better shape well
then you're right yeah i mean to be
honest with you when i was in saint
augustine in june on vacation
they have a distillery there yeah they
make
uh
gin
they make
i don't think they make vodka but they
make like several other
liquors
and you can buy them from their stores
so and they make them there
and most cities do have
that kind of [ __ ] nowadays yeah so you
can buy like some good [ __ ]
wherever you are you don't really have
to like buy
the corporate [ __ ] yeah there's a
lot of good [ __ ] uh i like that tap 57
that she brought
yeah i brought some home
because i used to work for the company
that distributed that's why you could
probably take a good american
malt whiskey
or even a corn sour mashed whiskey and
mix it with [ __ ]
maple syrup and it'd be [ __ ] great
you know it's a great sweetener but
that's kind of the american slash
canadian flavors
kind of [ __ ] maple
you know
um but it's all just depends on what
region you're in you know
there's a lot of goods i mean as i said
now local local yeah nowadays
um
there's so much
i mean so many people are like foodies
and so many people are into craft beers
and [ __ ] like that wherever you live
unless you live like in the ass end of
nowhere you can probably find somebody
locally that's making something decent
you just got outside oh i started a
[ __ ] firestorm in there people ask me
if i've had mezcal no i've never had
mexico
if someone wants to send me miss kyle
send me something
thorn cezanne says gas station lollipops
put the worm in there somebody sent me
my friend nicole many years ago
sent me some of those lollipops with the
with the worms in them
i didn't eat them though yeah i stuck in
my fridge it's like yeah i might eat
those one time when i'm super drunk but
i never did khan's talking about 1800
yeah 1800 we've had we have it here
before it's good yeah yeah you can get
that here yeah
so let me talk about this since we're
like talking about
crazy conspiracy theories okay
so
this is another thing that makes me
think not
disparaging the case breakers
uh all right
but
you guys think you found the zodiac okay
fine i'm willing to listen to the [ __ ]
but
when you come up with some [ __ ] like
this
making me not
making me less uh likely to listen to
your
line of whatever
so they're also like okay well we have
some like witnesses
uh five or six witnesses that say this
that and the other
a couple of the witnesses this is one
this is a dude named will with one l
he says
uh this isn't the press release
uh he's described as outlaw turned
zodiac whistleblower
zodiac whistle which immediately is
getting my little yeah
kind of flying yeah
uh escaped from post-zodiac criminal
posse
again
zodiac has a posse yeah
there's a zodiac posse a gang of zodiac
this okay this is
do you remember the [ __ ] about like son
of sam yeah and how he had and i'm not
yeah he's saying that like
yeah yeah and i'm not saying that maybe
he didn't have like one other dude that
was worried like that's not crazy
but
these whole kind of theories about oh
this one serial killer and they have
this whole like cult of people
that's okay that's that's a little bit
beyond the pale
you're gonna have to like give me a lot
more [ __ ] to like convince me of that
you know what i'm saying yeah the larger
your conspiracy is
the less likely it is so you have to
give me more
evidence
so yeah
allah turned
zodiac whistleblower
says
that he escaped from post's zodiac
criminal posse
which roamed for decades
in high sierra
uh now in his 50s and hiding in the
northwest will says he's angry and
ashamed
claiming the psychopath groomed me into
a killing machine
this is someone all right
all right i'm not disparaging anybody so
like look
the weirdest [ __ ] has happened to
somebody i'm not saying it didn't happen
to you i'm just saying it's unlikely
so
every time like some big serial killer
comes up and everybody's like yeah that
dude like groomed me and it's like that
you're gonna have to like go way farther
than that like convince me that that's
what happened
because
the zodiac for all intents and purposes
it just seemed like he was going around
shooting people at random and didn't
really give a [ __ ] about
a cult or
grooming people into whatever it just
really didn't seem like a thing it was
just going around in his little [ __ ]
outfit
killing people at random that was kind
of his
his deal that was what gave him a
hard-on
yes yeah
i don't really know if
i don't know
this is a whole thing where people are
like
retroactively claiming that they're like
[ __ ] we're groomed into this [ __ ] i
don't know i don't really know
so yeah he says you groomed into a
killing machine
so he tells the case breakers this is a
quote
he had a great side oh i'm sure
that's me
he just didn't have a conscience
he didn't have a conscience but also he
had a great side great side okay
whatever
he could kill indiscriminately good for
him and i mean you know
he's pretty much proven that over the
years he couldn't even stop after he
moved up here
he just
uh he still had to continue to kill
even if it was small animals just to
make himself feel better well good for
him
uh i've seen him kill bears deer otter
um
ferrets marmots
just anything that lived
he liked to shoot them
watch them fall down he liked to mess
with the carcasses when he was done
he just got bloody that was the quote so
you just shoot a ferret because you see
a ferret i've never seen a ferret not a
not a wild ferret in the united states i
have seen a ferret only only domestic
ferrets
you know it's weird one time when i
lived at my grandma's house yeah
we had a kitty and she lived on the
porch yeah her name was oreo
and
one time oreo was like yelling so we
went on the porch
and she was fighting
with a ferret
and it was obviously somebody's ferret
that had like escaped yeah and the
ferret got into
our
you know room where the [ __ ] laundry
[ __ ] was
um so you know there was that so that
was like a weird situation but yeah that
was the only time i've ever seen a
ferret and that was somebody's pet yeah
escaped
let me tell you something people i've
owned ferrets ferrets are [ __ ] clowns
they're clowns and they're sweet as hell
uh
people used to
[ __ ] tell me that things like
weasels and minks were these vicious
[ __ ] things absolutely no they're all
like ferrets they're [ __ ] clouds
and i'm glad that there is a that there
is an internet and a youtube
to t to show us the characters of these
animals
a lot of the animals that i grew up
thinking that they were vicious they're
not vicious at all they're friendly
little [ __ ] things inclu including
weasels and ferrets
and minx they're
they're clowns
yeah of course they kill other little
things but they kill mice and rats and
well they gotta eat they eat you know
just like cats right but they're not
aggressive towards humans or any other
animals kill mice and bugs and [ __ ] like
that they gotta eat too and ferrets and
cats and dogs all get along there's a
pecking order
so it's not like we thought it was back
in the 70s and 80s i don't honestly
see ferrets any different than cats
they're very similar and honestly i had
a friend where i used to work and he had
a couple of ferrets yeah and he said
those ferrets are honestly just like
[ __ ] human children yeah they're very
[ __ ] friendly
they're friendly and they're they like
to [ __ ]
communicate and play and
well just like pookie is like a human
child yeah in a lot of ways yes
the thing is though is that a ferret
doesn't live as long as a cat a cat
lives a lot longer ferrets and irma and
they don't they don't live very long and
that's something people that own these
things have to come to terms with that
because you have these wonderful pets
that uh well it's like having a kid that
dies when they're like 12.
five
five which is hard i think i think a
ferret lives to be about five or six man
that's even worse they don't live very
long
they are cute though and they're very
friendly and they like people and they
like all of all kinds of other animals
they like cats they like dogs they're
playing they're like play machines play
machines that's what they are elsa said
yeah i had two ferrets yeah they're so
fun they're [ __ ] they're super
flexible and and good cuddlers yeah
they're clown clown clowns
uh yeah and you all the [ __ ] yeah my my
friend that used to work with me he had
two or three ferrets yeah him and his
girlfriend and it's like the stories
they told like the videos they showed me
oh my god you can get a pharah to act up
and they they [ __ ] they deliver
they're like do it they're like yeah
they just well they're just like little
fuzzy people yeah they're they clown
their asses off they don't live long but
they have a good time
[Laughter]
they're cramming a lot of fun
yeah it's all condensed down into a very
small well like i said that's why
i mean you know that's why i kind of
feel the way i feel about pookie because
um
she to me she's like a tiny little
person so i treat her like a tiny little
person well cats are long-lived compared
to [ __ ] uh well yeah they can live
like 15 20 years which is a long time a
long time yeah
um you know not long enough in my
estimation we all live a certain amount
of time sure and it's just our in and
cats live a long time for what they are
and i mean she to me she behaves like
uh
a human child would behave yeah she
can't talk but she kind of talks and i
kind of know like what she's saying
what's going on right like she goes
and like i'm like okay so you want that
all right
like you can figure it out yeah she has
body language she has like little so you
know it's it's kind of like having a
tiny little fuzzy person it's kind of
like that but
you know everybody i've known that had a
ferret
they said kind of the same thing
uh that they're kind of like little
bitty people
they act like little khan's asking what
a ferret is a fear is like a weasel oh
he doesn't know what a fair it is
it's like a weasel it's a north american
creek yeah it's like a weasel yeah they
come from here they're like a weasel or
a mink they're bigger than both
uh
they came from the uh
north american prairies they ate prairie
dogs for centuries
but the prairie dogs are all gone the
cattle industry of these 1800s wiped
them out
and the uh the ferret kind of became a
domesticated animal they are domestic
they were used as a as a hunting animal
to uh
what they call ferret out
rabbits
they'll chase a rabbit out of a burrow
you shoot the rabbit
and then you share some of the meat with
the ferret
they're like a they're
they're like a very large weasel
uh and they have a good personality very
good personality yeah
a lot of people in the us keep them as
pets yeah
uh they do they stink yeah um but
a lot of people keep those pets because
they have like really good personalities
yeah so a lot of people keep those pets
so that's why also the oscars because
they're smelly little things with sharp
teeth they are very smelly yeah but
they're friendly they're very friendly
and they're [ __ ] clowns
they [ __ ]
entertain you like crazy
they jump and flip and
put on shows and they're they're nice
creatures they're they're cute
con says hasn't seen poopster in a while
you were just holding her up yeah yeah
yeah she's around where'd she go her
little like tree toy is like right there
yeah
i bought her a new thing you know we
have that little thing you know you have
those little like things where
what is that is it a little like cat or
a little bite like my neighbor totoro or
whatever that is and you put treats in
it and she like bumped into it and like
treats come out the butt yeah
i said look pookie had poop streets and
she's like what
i don't get it so she has that but i
bought her a new one for christmas but i
haven't showed her it showed it to her
yet it's a snowman
and it does the same thing you put
treats in it and like treats come out
its butt
so
hopefully she'll be into that i don't
know
but i got her that i got her like a new
um
one of those things that has
i don't know like all the little [ __ ]
tracks in it like little balls
because man she loves that she loves
little balls and little crunchy balls
and [ __ ] like that so i'm kind of like
trying to give her some [ __ ] to
entertain her
she doesn't like to go outside anymore
which is good i'm into that i don't
really want her to go outside
but because i don't really like her to
go outside at the old place but
you know i i kind of got pressured into
it
but
she's been outside here a couple times
she's like yeah i don't like it she like
runs back in and i'm just like that's
fine you stay with mama
but
so i'm trying to like entertain her in
other ways
so i'm trying to like buy her new toys
and stuff so i got her like a new stuff
that she
like has some balls but she likes all
the like halloween toys she likes the
crunchy balls
you know like elsa sent us that big uh
box of like all the halloween toys she
loves like this little scrunchie
i know they're like they're so cheap but
she loves those like
she loves little balls that like make
that just
she like
i leave him on the floor like around
here for her to play with and she like
runs across them and like
kicks some of their back feet
and then she kicks them up under her
like front feet and then she like rolls
over and back and she's like
and she like [ __ ] throws them
she'll [ __ ] throw them and chase them
and [ __ ] like that she throws her own
[ __ ] and chases it it's like hilarious
but yeah she does that kind of [ __ ] but
i don't know man
ferrets that's like [ __ ] funny that
you go to
i used to work with a dude back in the
old days
and back in the
late 90s early 2000s he was a cop
actually
part-time
and he worked as a graphic designer
where i worked
and him and his girlfriend had i think
they had two ferrets
and they were they loved those [ __ ]
parrots
and
um
i mean this ferrets the way they talked
about them this was before i had cats
i mean i had cats when i was a kid but
not to the same extent as nowadays
but they had two ferrets and just like
the way that they're talking about them
were like oh my god they sound like like
tiny little fuzzy people and that was
like awesome
because the [ __ ] that they were doing
was like amazing
but now that we have pookie
it's not as weird to me nowadays because
pookie does like a lot of the same [ __ ]
that
you know he was talking about the
ferrets doing but back then you know
what i mean so
yeah
what's that talking about okay
i just walked in
no i'm talking myself mostly i'm not
talking to you larry says [ __ ] mezcal
might as well drink gasoline i've never
had
mezcal
i don't think i have either actually
it's fermented it's not like it's not
distilled from what i remember
miguel says we have a snowman treat
pooper
yeah i just bought one it's like a whole
i got it from chewy i think or something
it's like a bag of treats and it has
like a little
we already have like a little treat
pooper thing but it just looks like like
i said it looks like my neighbor totoro
it looks like a little cat
like a little fat cat so we've did we
finish um well i'm still working on it
okay once you do that first then we'll
talk about this other side okay
uh
so yeah so we're talking about this
whole we're getting into this whole
remember when we talked about
son of sam yeah and how we there was
that documentary about oh maybe there
was more people and maybe there was like
this whole cult i kind of feel like
is that human nature
to
just think oh well we can't just have
this one serial killer that does this
[ __ ] up [ __ ] we have to have this
whole
interlinked
society of people it's this is like the
basis behind the whole satanic panic of
the 80s
it can't just be like one weirdo that's
doing this [ __ ] we have to this whole
network
i don't know i i kind of feel like maybe
that's a human thing i don't really know
but that's kind of what i'm feeling in
this situation
so this one dude will with 1l
he says yeah zodiac grooming me into
whatever i i don't buy this but whatever
um he's a killing machine okay uh he had
a great side he didn't have a conscience
okay
he would kill indiscriminately
uh you know killing all the animals or
whatever
now casebreaker says
and this is one of the things that came
out in their
uh you know press release
was that
uh he witnessed post burying the murder
weapons
and um
[Music]
says that he gave the team
meaning like the case breakers people
the dig site
although they're not releasing that
information
so
i'm skeptical like i said
maybe we're keeping the ship back
because we want to make money off the
release of it
but come on this is a criminal
investigation don't be that way i'm just
saying
now another witness
that put some [ __ ] forward
uh in relation to this case
is
is this woman named michelle and she is
allegedly
post's
daughter-in-law
now her quote says
uh when she was 10 years old when she
were when her 10-year marriage ended
michelle says
that post ordered two of his criminal
posse
like i said can't just be one dude it
has to be like a whole extended thing
uh to go after her
breaking her windows
then threatening harassing and
assaulting her until she moved out of
state this was in the press release
uh so
this is someone who is allegedly
sort of related to the person that
they're accusing of being zodiac
and she's saying
yeah so his posse
not him
uh caiman did this [ __ ]
not saying i don't believe that i'm just
saying i don't i don't know
so another woman
that they had uh statements from was a
woman named gweny
now she was apparently a kid
and she was babysat by post and his wife
back in the 1970s
now she says
and this is a quote
he taught her the little kid
you know she was a little kid at the
time
how to use guns
sometimes going to the woods five days a
week
in the last year of her child care
she witnessed posts callousness and
violence toward his wife
a wife that only slept on the couch this
was a wife that later
um you know for real he was arrested for
pushing her down the stairs so yeah this
is it's not that crazy
uh recently gwenny caught up with the 75
year old wife now in assisted living and
the phone call standard of one line in
particular i'm sorry that i didn't tell
the cops about his zodiac pass now
this particular girl
who was allegedly a child at the time of
the
slayings i'm guessing
um
she later came forward and allegedly
said that she was felt bad because she's
like oh in retrospect
yeah that dude was probably the zodiac
and i probably should have said
something
but i don't know
like
here's the thing
um shitty dudes
are a dime a dozen
um
so
just accusing every shitty dude that you
know
of being a famous serial killer
i'm not really sure how far this is
going to get you because like i said
shitty dudes
dime a dozen uh dudes that beat up their
wives dime a dozen
uh
back then dudes that molest their
children dime a dozen
um not saying that's good i'm just
saying
that's how it is
so
does that mean that every single one of
them serial killer no
um does that mean every single one of
them is a good person no obviously
they're all shitty people but that
doesn't mean that they're serial killers
uh so i don't know um
and particularly back in this time
period i kind of feel like dudes back
then i mean
man they got away with some [ __ ]
you could beat up on your wife and kids
back then and
well the culture and the enforcement
that's what i'm saying it's like it
wasn't really in the same world it yeah
so
no one re it wasn't like a red flag the
way it would be nowadays nowadays
if you did that [ __ ]
and later on some serial killer [ __ ]
happened somebody said oh we need to
look into this
fella because they knew
you know the pathology
that would not have happened back then
because honestly back then
you smacked your wife around just match
your kids around
no one's really gonna
question it honestly
which is sad but
well you know out in california my dad
when he was in his twenties and [ __ ]
but i remember when i was a kid
would go would
be like kind of like hammond and han
over some of the [ __ ] guys were doing
and this is california
in the 70s
you know i mean like hey you know kind
of hard on his wife
that [ __ ] wasn't cool even back in the
70s you know i mean this is all
yeah i mean people weren't well 70s
people were like yeah you're not rich
just be doing i mean culturally i feel
like people were kind of like yeah
but it's not like you could like call
the cops
uh you kind of could to probably
depending on where it was state you were
but would the cops do anything
though uh in the 70s even now i feel
like they didn't well okay
i'm trying to move myself back to that
time
in the 70s
if a dude were to call the cops
on his buddy who was roughing up his
wife the cops would have showed up in
california at least and and
given him a talking to like why are you
doing this you knocked that off yeah or
like [ __ ] you know it would have been
something like that you have to
understand now women's are different
than men
you feel like you're not supposed to be
doing that you have to understand
now would they have done anything
legally they may have not been able to i
feel like they probably at that time but
the thing is is that
um
because i'm thinking about some dudes i
grew up with and their dad and the mom
and my dad there they were like
neighbors you know what i mean
and no my dad did [ __ ] disagree with
certain [ __ ] that this dude that i'm
thinking i want to name his name
he was just like nah
that [ __ ] ain't right um he didn't call
the cops but
people did kind of talk to the dude
about it it was a different world back
then
there weren't as many people and things
weren't handled the same way back then
well and like i said i mean i didn't
need a system to do it it was like more
like the community you know what i mean
but the thing about it it's like it's
easy for
dudes to say that because you weren't at
the receiving end of it
so
for a woman to
hear that yeah is like really upsetting
because it's like well
our the whole culture was like based
around
well we you can we can just like slap
you around because we don't agree with
you what you say or what you think and
that's fine and like no one's going to
do anything about it
that's very very upset yeah but women
were different back then they're there
i don't really think that's an excuse i
really don't okay whatever
i really saying i'm just saying that the
system wasn't in place well yeah and
people the reason for the system not
being in place was because
uh
people dudes were in charge no i don't
think that's what it was yeah it was i
think i think what it was is that
[ __ ] there was kind of like an
element of innocence back then they
didn't think
that that kind of [ __ ] would happen
but it was you know things like that did
happen
and uh
they were like
it was like a different country back
then
well and honestly like back then in a
different country
back then
uh it kind of feel like
honestly i feel like
from a woman's point of view
it feels like it was only very recently
that dudes that it occurred to them
that women were actually humans
uh that actually had the same feelings
and [ __ ] as they did
um and that was like kind of like a
revelation in some ways maybe um i don't
think that's what was so one-off yeah i
i do kind of feel like that's what was
going on i think what was going on i do
kind of feel like that was not what was
going on okay
um that i don't think that's what it was
i grew up in that time too uh i'm only a
couple years younger than you yeah
and
this is something that i mean you
obviously had a different experience
than me because you were not a girl
um so
i wasn't a girl back then
that's what i'm saying
no that's right well that's what i'm
saying but well you're
you're um
you're so but these people
are dead now no but what i'm saying is
that you're um
no your uh you know uh
look on the world
is different because you didn't see it
the same way as someone like me would
have seen it it was kind of like it was
kind of like in it it was kind of like
another country back then
these dudes were raised to have certain
expectations right and like well
honestly um and me as a woman i was very
aware of that y'all were not aware of it
because it was uh you're saying y'all
like i was involved in i was like no i'm
i'm just saying just in general in
general these are other people that
they're dead now
okay but i'm just saying that it's still
like the um it's almost like another
country and well
the
the
you know the you know it it's kind of
like still
resonates though is what i'm saying it
didn't have anything to do with you
though come here pookie
didn't it
no you were like i grew up in the 70s
yeah but i was still i was still very
very aware of it um you weren't like i
said you weren't a girl back then so i
guess you didn't it was another country
at that time
b so you weren't a girl back then so i
guess you didn't uh you weren't aware of
it
but because i was a girl back then uh i
was aware of it those are dead
i'm not dead no the people that were
doing that were dead
they're gone
but the perception of it is like
well you can remember it but that
doesn't make it real those people are
dead
my perception isn't real you guys no you
remember it but those people were dead
they weren't raised like us
their mentality was very different
they just were okay
those people are long gone
it's like for something from another
country
and that doesn't still resonate to
modern day because it totally does
no it totally does
those dudes those dudes had a different
[ __ ]
picture says nah the boomers are still
around yes they are they weren't boomers
they're still around they weren't
boomers the ones that i remembered
they were a little bit older than that
and they're dead green spark says i
worked at a women's shelter through
college legacy lives on yeah okay um i i
honestly don't understand why dudes feel
the need
to
um
tell people how they experienced their
life but that wasn't you that was there
it was me
okay
so your husband did that to you
my husband did do that there you go
there you go no the culture does that
that was another generation those people
are [ __ ] gone yeah but i was raised
by those people you understand that
right yeah but they're i'm being raised
by they're gone being raised by people
as a dude and being raised by people as
a girl are two different things those
people are gone in the 70s those people
are gone and [ __ ] the people that
were my parents are still alive
you know that right that way
i'm just saying that the culture at
large
reacts differently
um because you didn't experience it that
culture's gone that doesn't mean
that
the uh you know the
the
you know the
[ __ ] what's the word i'm looking for
what's the word i'm looking for
he doesn't know what i'm talking about
that culture he discounts everything i
[ __ ] said no i'm not discounting um
yes you do yes you do you're trying to
revive something that's dead
those people are gone
they're not my parents are still alive
are they doing that
no i'm saying the culture their culture
at large yeah that kind of like
resonates you're a dude you didn't
experience it the same way that i would
have experienced it and i don't
appreciate
you casting your
[ __ ] on me because that's not how i grew
up
i didn't grow up that way either right
so the way that you grew up is not the
same way that i grew up
so i didn't grow up that way though so
you like [ __ ] saying oh i didn't
experience this and that and the other
i don't appreciate that because it's
like my experience is not the same it's
yours no nobody [ __ ] beat you or
[ __ ]
or did anything any of that to you how
do you know
i didn't do it to you you didn't ask you
didn't ask me you never asked me i did
that to you no one asked no no one said
about you
well who did it then
were your
ex-husband he was even from here
he's from [ __ ] [ __ ] scotland
or wales or whatever i don't have
anything to do with that
but those [ __ ] were
is indicative
no one's talking about you okay
people are talking about the culture at
large no one's talking about you
particularly all right i didn't do
anything to anybody
as far as i know
you are very very narrow-minded i don't
care either way yeah i know you don't
i need help i don't see any of that as a
reality
well you don't have to
because none of it is directed at you
that's all gone
it's not okay uh but but good for you
but you're gone
i
nobody is do nobody is like they were
back in the 70s or the [ __ ] 60s
that's just gone no one's saying that
all right
let's talk about privilege you have a
lot of privilege i don't have any
privileges yeah you do no you do
but you don't realize it and that's the
same what privilege do i have
all of it like what because you don't uh
you seem not to realize what it's like
growing up to be someone other than you
okay whatever
and you you laugh at anybody that has a
experience different than that like it's
not
oh it didn't happen or oh it's like it's
not as bad as you think or
that's you really need to like examine
that okay you really should examine that
uh tammy says
yeah uh
my mom is still alive yeah my mom was
still alive too my dad is actually still
alive and my stepdad is so low that's
them actually my grandma's still alive
yeah although she's dying sadly she's in
her 90s
that [ __ ] isn't happening anymore though
it is uh it absolutely is it absolutely
is between them uh
thorns events men still hit women uh
yeah they do uh
let's see tammy got my kids dad who
abused me for 19 years because i had
nowhere to go and nobody helped me yeah
stop feeling that
well look man if it's that bad then stop
[ __ ]
stop [ __ ] with these people just
don't do anything well it's easy for you
to say like i said it's very easy for me
yeah it's really [ __ ] easy because
you don't have to deal with it no
because you don't have to deal with it
you never have to deal with anything
again privilege that's pretty it's not
privileged yes it is
it is
that's privilege
and the fact that you don't realize that
no that's very sad that's very sad that
you don't realize there's no privilege
there is no there is what makes you
privileged over anybody else
holy crap
do i really need to explain all of this
to you can i explain to you after my
birth
yes is it really is that what you think
yeah okay fine
uh you've had a lot of advantages that
you really don't realize
you really don't realize that's just how
things are though
yeah but is that it doesn't have
anything to do with me it's just luck
well no one's saying it has anything to
you yeah yeah but everybody's just
saying that you know people should
recognize it but that's just not the way
that life is
some people yeah people are different
no one's the same
one armchair is uh one archways
velasquez ortiz velasquez says everyone
has different lives and yes domestic
violence still exists yeah big time
you just don't hear about the issues
yeah i kind of feel like
um
i don't know if that's the case because
i do kind of feel like it still happens
probably to the same extent that it's
not like that was
but well back then
it was
acceptable
it was supposed to be part of marriage
yeah like something like your wife said
some [ __ ] that you didn't like you could
smack around nobody was like gonna like
[ __ ] get on your [ __ ] about it
they did though
i mean they did but it wasn't they're
like man you must do that but it wasn't
like nowadays yeah um
you know everyone was kind of like well
you know that [ __ ] happens by the time
chicks speak at a turn no we have to
like smack them around it was that kind
of [ __ ] from what i saw
in my dad's generation by the time the
[ __ ] 70s had come around they knew
what you were supposed to
what you weren't supposed to do you
can't you know i mean it didn't it
they were like no that [ __ ] ain't cool
man
and i remember it
i remember my dad going like
i mean but
the fact that a few dudes were like yeah
that's [ __ ] not cool that doesn't mean
that it wasn't like widespread because
it was i think it was widespread
it was wide i think it was widespread
and honestly she wasn't cool and like
nowadays thornton says more women are
killed by partners than strangers yeah
by a very very very long i know that's
why y'all need to stop [ __ ] 95 well
honestly it might be 98
stop dating
just leave those honestly um like
honestly
i'm a i'm a woman stop dating leave
dudes alone you're worried about
strangers which i would be too i would
not go on like don't go anywhere with a
stranger honestly
but
honestly be worried about your [ __ ]
boyfriend your husband
they're thing being the one that kills
you honestly just go out like live on
your own be it iselle be a femme cell
don't [ __ ] with those dudes they're all
killers no you shouldn't don't [ __ ] with
them
don't play the odds no you'll probably
be honestly i'm speaking to most women
nowadays
you're going to be much happier
by yourself just be living on yourself
living on your own
honestly you can do what you want i see
it all the time you'd have to like worry
about like some what other dudes doing
you don't want to like [ __ ] worry
about some dudes going to kill you
um
it sounds nice yeah to be fair
it sounds nice
i
i can't see anything outside i know i i
don't see a downside leave those dudes
alone
i'm seeing it outside
honestly you want to get off uh get a
vibrator good yeah get your body dildo
that's like that's better
it's it's better
in a lot of ways
so yeah
i i don't i don't really see any reason
i don't see any reason why you need to
do it so just [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying i'm just saying
yeah
uh you know
so yeah
domestic violence still in a [ __ ] oh
yeah big time
um it's kind of like domestic violence
coming to mexico kind of athalan says
yeah
uh we're still in baby steps on those
issues a lot of macho guys still like
beating the wife
yeah and you see it i watch a lot of
movies from the 50s and the 60s
and they're still kind of like this
thing
and it's it's creepy it's still kind of
like played for comedy
um
back in the day 50s and 60s oh my god
these ladies
they're so they're silly ideas we gotta
like slap this
[ __ ] out of them and it's like and it's
not
it's like played for like laughs
in movies from the 50s and the 60s
which is like really really upsetting
from a modern point of view because
you
know but
greenspec says i'm giant no i'm not a
giant baby i'm actually sure i'm short
yeah you are i'm sure yeah
i'm only like five six
what's up she said i'm giant i'm not
giant
yeah you're sure she says the guys are
intimidating guys aren't intimidating
not to me
no guys are intimidating it's got to be
a group of dudes really for me to be
[ __ ]
and and and me my if i get intimidated
my response is [ __ ]
oh well if they come at me [ __ ] crazy
like that i'm gonna fight to the death
but that's just
i don't care anymore i'm more like a
kamikaze now
i've been through some bad ass [ __ ]
military and all kinds of other [ __ ]
that i went through i don't i i don't
even care anymore
i don't care anymore no me either and
honestly like tammy says the thing is
yeah the guys are sweethearts in the
beginning yeah well that's how they get
you
so
i was a sweetheart girl
she was chasing after me in the [ __ ]
beginning girls though yeah okay i'm
just saying like girls that are younger
yeah don't fall for it don't believe it
don't believe anything dude
don't believe anything the dude says
the dude says [ __ ] yeah it doesn't mean
anything does that apply to me
yes that applies really hard to play
that place for all dudes
uh what do you say it doesn't mean
anything okay it doesn't matter watch
their actions
what they say doesn't mean anything okay
um
if they do that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
well yeah but you know
women lie too
well yeah well i mean that applies
across i mean i could [ __ ] show you
[ __ ]
direct examples
don't trust people it's just like i'm
we're gonna go back are you trying to
like like go back to the bible we'll go
back to the bible
oh you're trying to like pull some [ __ ]
off of your own stuff no no we're gonna
go back to the bible oh no we're gonna
like talk about it like i stopped by but
but more people back then like in the
bible which is full of [ __ ] but bye bye
they even break that up then
these are these are like made up these
aren't that full of [ __ ] these are made
up so there's a lot of ancient wisdom in
there they said [ __ ] not really it's
a lot of asian not really it's that you
you judge the tree by the fruit that it
bears
in other words you know what i mean
[ __ ] it's not so much what somebody
says is what actually happens
yeah so that's you know that's the same
thing you said
thank you well thank you for
interrupting me i'm not interrupting you
and you brought up some [ __ ] that was
exactly the same as what i said
i said girls
anything a dude says
don't believe it okay watch what they're
doing
and that's what you have to like [ __ ]
dude i'm old i'm like what time is he it
is
uh
9 45. okay so you can make some food
you can make some food
but yeah i'm saying
you know probably everybody here is like
old and
they've you know they've already figured
the [ __ ] out
but
yeah
girls don't believe anything dude says
watch what he does
don't watch what he says
i'm just saying
you gotta like watch the actions don't
don't watch the
don't listen to anything he says
that's with everything though why should
he do that that's not some dude that's
that's weird so interestingly
well yeah
now intro this is another thing i want
to bring up [ __ ] craziest business
are we in your face are we gaslighting
now i'm not gonna i'm just talking about
craziness are we guessing
all right go ahead
oh my my 50 years of experience
are not valid
[Laughter]
because
because your intentions
we are not we talking about no i didn't
say that
my 50 years of experience or not okay
look look we're going to stop fish
finish the show because tom has decided
that
well his intentions are good
uh so here's another thing that i wanted
to bring up
yeah i'm crazy this [ __ ] crazy
go ahead finish the show it's honestly
honey it's getting late
i'm i'm going on it i know like a long
[ __ ] uh you know do you want some of
this
what
liquor
yeah sure poor next season yes are you
gonna maybe some food now or what i'll
make you something we get done
we just got to [ __ ] split this
man i'm getting like the [ __ ]
i'm getting to the house of wax action
because
house of wax wow house of wax action no
shut up you weren't even here when i did
the movie review i had to do it without
you
i was [ __ ] busy i'm trying to [ __ ]
do paperwork on this [ __ ] [ __ ]
i was [ __ ] signing off 1953
even in 1953
the poor [ __ ] at the center of this
was
constantly
nagged and constantly [ __ ]
uh gaslated
by all the men around her
she's like look
i know that this dude vincent price who
owned this wax works
is using corpses and he's making them
into wax figures
no one believed her none of the men
believed her man but she was right
she was right
so just saying
i'm just saying
so yeah let me get into this okay so i
wanted to mention this because i don't
know if this is related or
not so 2021 december 9th this is very
very recent
december 29th 2021. newsweek comes out
with the [ __ ] about
a bunch of news stations in albany new
york
and they say they've got a bunch of
letters
from somebody
and they're claiming to be the quote
unquote
chinese
zodiac killer
i don't know what
no like a couple days ago a couple days
they haven't killed anybody as far as i
know
but this is like some [ __ ] that's trying
to like [ __ ] ride in the gravy train
i don't know
so they get all these letters
and
so they report to the fbi the fbi like
looks into it
so basically
what happens they cut like okay so the
letters that came from the original
zodiac killer what are you all right
yeah
you sure yeah it's starting to cod and
the kanji is [ __ ] with me she's like
yeah it's in the heat of the tequila
what's your problem
that's because
it's in the heat of the tequila
i'm not drinking tequila you are i am
yeah you got a problem with that
well maybe
[ __ ] i'm falling i'm falling
okay go ahead
goodness gracious
you are you're really having a problem
yeah
aren't you
all right go ahead
[Laughter]
hold on one second
okay bye
all right so uh so okay
so this person as far as we know hasn't
killed anyone however
uh as of december early december 2021
they've been sending a lot of letters
uh claiming i guess
that they've been doing some [ __ ]
to all many times now
people have been like uh upset about
this because
there was um
i don't know if he necessarily
identified himself as the quote-unquote
chinese zodiac killer
but uh there was a letter that arrived
from uh the zodiac back in 1973
and the letter that he sent
uh
he said that he was going to kill a
woman in albany and there was actually a
crime that was
maybe maybe not like related to that
uh he sent the letter this was august of
1973 the letter said
you were wrong i am not dead
in the hospital i'm alive and well
and i'm not and i'm going to start
killing
again
and that was the letter that was sent to
uh you know albany and the thing about
it is that
one of the zodiac murder victims
was elizabeth faron and she
uh had lived in albany at some point
and then a man that was previously
considered a zodiac suspect
uh who was richard golkowski
uh works for a newspaper
in
albany but he didn't work there anymore
and that paper wasn't uh around anymore
so nobody knew if that was like maybe
some kind of thing so i don't really
know so
as of
late 2021 there's some chinese zodiac
killer so nobody's killed anybody
uh but
nobody knows because like i said the
zodiac in 1974
uh he hadn't probably killed anybody
since 69 maybe
but he was like oh i killed all these
people that you guys didn't find out
about like i said he claimed he'd killed
like 37 people even though he's only
credited with five
um
so
it's possible he killed some other
people that he didn't get credited with
did he do this [ __ ] probably not i kind
of feel like the zodiac
he's probably dead by now i mean he's
got to be
how long ago was that
1969
even if you had started killing people
when you were
all right let's assume
i'm tired i'm i'm thinking about doing
math when i'm
drunk if you were
like for the sake of like being easy
let's say you were 20 years old in 1970
how old would you be now
70 80
90. 77
about 70. i mean you'd be old you'd be
70.
would you still be running around
killing people or still
honestly if you still weren't killing
people would you still be worried about
i'm gonna send some like [ __ ] uh
letter to a newspaper like saying hey
i'm the zodiac [ __ ]
i kind of feel like you'd be over that
at that point would you be
too old to be worried about that [ __ ] i
don't know
i don't know i'm not
i'm not a serial killer
i'm not the kind of person that would be
a serial killer i'm not the kind of
person that would be
obsessed with this [ __ ] where you'd
still be like sending [ __ ] letters to
people where you're in this in your 70s
i don't know
maybe you would
maybe that's your whole entire life
goal
i don't know
um
i don't know i'm not buying it
but
okay so like what do you guys think do
you think that
gary francis post
the people that the case breakers this
independent group i'm saying the fbi
are still saying
we're looking into the [ __ ] but we don't
have any proof
so we're saying the case is still open
we're not going anywhere with that
so this is an independent group this
isn't official or nothing
what do you guys think do you think this
dude is the zodiac or
do you think that they were right back
in the old days
that [ __ ]
whatever it's like the [ __ ] dude that
like uh
alan whatever what the [ __ ] was that
dude's name
god damn it i'm so [ __ ] drunk are you
gonna help me
yeah of course you're not
of course you're not
tom's gonna take a dive downstairs
that's what's looking um what does that
mean someone said
i don't know it's dumbo
you're not helping about what yeah
thanks what are you talking about
nothing
um never mind
what do you want me to say about it
well it would help if you're actually
like listening
i can barely [ __ ] make it i can
barely [ __ ] yeah me too but okay i
have to keep [ __ ] together this this
[ __ ]
this show was at the end
it was at the end arthur allen lathe
that's who i was talking about
do you guys think that arthur allen lee
was actually
the zodiac
i'm kind of leaning toward that i don't
know i don't know if anyone's actually
going to prove it why are you laughing
at it i'm just laughing at you are you
laughing at me
we laughing at me
you wanted me to save you in the middle
of the show i don't even know where the
[ __ ] we are at this
arthur allen
lee lee
yeah i don't remember that was it was
arthur allen lee i don't remember him
from any other case
well thank you for that thank you for
backing me up on that yeah anyway
anyway yeah uh now that we're back to
like important [ __ ]
so
do any of you guys
thank you just
so do you guys think that arthur only
was actually the zodiac i don't really
know because like like i said he died in
1992.
um
did they get his dna
maybe
will they ever be able to prove it
maybe
he had the most circumstantial evidence
uh most of the people that worked on the
case kind of thought it was him
i'm leaning toward that but i'm willing
to be convinced otherwise
i'm not sure
if there was enough evidence to convince
me
because i kind of feel like this whole
thing that came out it was this big deal
um
you know that this whole
you know gary frances post dude oh we
found the zodiac blah blah
but
i kind of feel like it was just like a
publicity stunt
in a lot of ways
uh they didn't have any dna
they didn't have a lot of
they had some evidence but it was very
very circumstantial and honestly it
wasn't any better than the
circumstantial evidence they had for
arthur ellen lay which
in my estimation was a lot better
uh then you know because if all you had
was oh well his he had a forehead scarra
that was kind of like that drawing
and the drawing was like well they just
put those lines there because they
thought somebody of that age would have
forehead lines
i don't know that's like not that big a
deal to me so i don't really know that's
very very
sketchy um
so what are we talking about i'll tell
you a word do they think that we've
caught the zodiac no no no no
look you gotta give me more than that
give me more than that give me some dna
[ __ ] give me some [ __ ]
give me some [ __ ] look
here is
the [ __ ] standard thing in criminal
[ __ ] justice
if you don't have an indictment
on a dude
on a suspect
within a couple months
you're not going to get him look people
can say [ __ ] all day long
oh
i thought my neighbor was a zodiac since
i was a kid yeah that doesn't mean
anything
you can say anything this is why i've
kind of been holding back over this
[ __ ] cup
she's [ __ ] with me i [ __ ] know
they don't have the dude no they they
[ __ ] had the dude you'd have had an
indictment by now and the fbi have said
that and honestly like the dude that
runs the zodiac killer site said this is
like not no
he he called it quote unquote hot
garbage yeah he said this is not this is
just somebody that's looking for
publicity to like sell a book right he's
like i don't think this dude i'm not
saying that dude wasn't involved but he
wasn't even on their list
he wasn't on their list they don't have
his dna they're on figure you know
fingerprints they don't have nothing
when you look at statistics
you have the right suspect within 30 to
60 days
of the [ __ ] case you know what i mean
no this has been so long no
you don't have i mean do i think that
they'll catch him at some point i mean
maybe
well they might because they caught
original light soccer yeah but they had
[ __ ] they had true i mean he left all
kinds of a lot of [ __ ] dna in um
and uh i'm gonna say
from what i know from the original case
they didn't collect the evidence they
needed
from from from well they didn't think
about it at the time back in those days
no one was thinking about
we needed to get every single [ __ ]
hair and everything and i got a [ __ ]
real strong suspicion
in tom ross's [ __ ] in internal
instincts
the [ __ ] the original zodiac killer
is dead and he's been dead for a long
time can we talk about maybe
that
uh people don't want
the zodiac to be identified yeah that's
another factor i kind of feel like well
it's the same kind of factor that you
get with like the jack the ripper
um you can make a lot of money
uh selling a book saying you've
definitively identified jack the river
which you haven't uh you know
but
i kind of feel like that's a way to make
money on the true crime circuit circuit
but
have you really done it no
but
that's kind of like do we want that do
we want that uh mystery solved
no
i kind of feel like we don't
yeah
it is long dead jack the ripper
nobody wants to know who that is yeah um
everybody wants to buy a book about who
it might be um and they want to like see
some evidence oh maybe it's that guy
but everybody wants
the mystery to
you know
to keep going that dude's long dead well
obviously and um and he wouldn't buy it
even back in the day
the thing about it
i kind of feel like um
the [ __ ] about the why people like true
crime why people like unsolved mysteries
why people like thrillers stuff like
that you like
and i'm the same i'm not [ __ ] on
people that are like this but it's like
you like
mystery and you don't necessarily
you don't want the mystery solved
um if the mystery is solved
that takes the fun out of it
if you knew
definitively who jack the ripper was if
somebody came out and said i have dna i
have
all the [ __ ] evidence i have
everything
this dude was definitively jack the
ripper or this dude was definitively the
zodiac killer
would you
want to know that
probably not
i mean you kind of would but then you'd
be like nah i don't think that's you'd
find like some way to like think that
maybe that was wasn't him
because
people like mystery they don't really
want it they want to know but they don't
want to know
yeah so i kind of feel like that's why
jack the ripper
that mystery has sustained over the
centuries is because
you want to know but you don't want to
know
you want it to be
a monster you want it to be
um you know a ghost a [ __ ] it's an
old legendary case right it's a legend
you want it to be like a ghost you want
it to be something that's like you know
you want it to be something other than
because if it was solved it would just
be some regular ass
true crime case and that's boring and
that's what it was right
sure
um you know obviously it was just some
[ __ ] crazy dude that cut up
prostitutes for whatever reason that he
did it yeah and you would it was a
person that did it was a person and you
wouldn't have been impressed if you saw
him right it was just some lame ass
person some weird pervert yeah um but
nobody wants to know that everybody
wants to
kind of put and i get it
um you want to
uh you know attribute this kind of like
mythical
you want jack the ripper to be like a
mythical figure you want the zodiac to
be
a mythical figure you don't want it to
be just this yeah um you know in-cell
chubby loser loser yeah that's what it
was which it was probably who it was
um you don't want it to be solved
colin's saying we're going to mannequins
next no we're not going to mannequins
bro it's [ __ ] december
it's december we're broke we're broke we
gotta we're buying this house yeah
i am so [ __ ] broke right now and we
gotta wait so [ __ ] we gotta wait for
this [ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] pack we
just got like a new dishwasher we got
the [ __ ]
holy crap we're like so [ __ ] broke
we're just we're like you we're like
y'all it's it's the [ __ ] this
december
you spent your money on presents for
people you got all kinds of [ __ ] going
on
you you're waiting this month out
so
that's why i'm not pumping i'm not
pumping [ __ ]
super chats everybody's broke
we just got a job yeah
i mean i'm breathing yeah and then we
just gotta wait till we'll see what
[ __ ] january brings
[ __ ] crazy as the world is now we'll
see
but um
no
this dude they don't have him they'll
never have him
old as i said
once the case gets this old yeah and
it's this mythical yeah nobody
i'm gonna argue nobody really wants it
to be psalms yeah because if you do
solve it
um
it's not gonna live up to people's
expectations
of because people that have been
mythicizing this for such a long time
you kind of feel like in a weird way
this is not like a human it's like a
superhuman yeah it's like like i said
jack the ripper it's almost kind of like
a mythical figure well i don't know
they're getting what they want because
yeah that's it was just a person it's a
person but it's just a person they
didn't catch him they got away with it
right yeah
i mean in the end
it's just a person if they don't really
catch you within 90 days the chances of
them catching you [ __ ] start to
diminish with each passing month and
it's been [ __ ] decades this dude's
gone
probably dead
and kind of ozone said well they got
d'angelo and that's why i'm kind of an
outlier
outlier when they caught deangelo yeah
because i didn't think they would catch
the original nightstalker either when we
did the first show about it
um
when they first caught him the first
thing i thought was that now they'll be
able to catch the zodiac that was the
first thing i thought
um will they still be able to do that
maybe
um but quickly though i don't know well
it all has to do with did his
descendants
upload
i mean that's how d'angelo got caught
because his descendants had uploaded
stuff to like genealogical dates so they
were able to like you know i think they
would have caught it [ __ ] back maybe but
i don't know um but the thing about it
is that
i kind of feel like they made a big deal
about you know in 2020
or 2021 rather that they'd oh we caught
the zodiac and it's like blah blah but
it's like they didn't have dna it wasn't
like it wasn't like that it was kind of
like an independent group
i'm not [ __ ] on them because a lot
you know some of them work for the fbi
allegedly some of them were like cops
allegedly
and they were volunteers and they
thought they had figured it out but they
didn't have any dna that have anything
like that it was just basically like a
press release so don't get too excited i
don't really know if that's who it was
or not
i'm just saying
um you know i would like to think that
the zodiac was caught
but
i don't know even though he's
dead he's not gonna get much he's dead i
tend to think well the dude that they're
accusing died a couple years ago yeah um
i mean if they did catch the day he'd
probably be dead or he'd probably be
like so old that
well it you know
just like original nightstalker like
d'angelo he was like an old man
when they caught him
he'd been like not killing people for
that look how long he got along with
that he got away with that [ __ ]
it's amazing i mean
but
that dude's near dead also
good a couple years
we have to look at the big picture five
years is nothing
once you get to a certain age
you know
d'angelo will be dead by the time
here shortly
too bad he didn't suffer more
he got away with it
that's what makes me angry that's what
makes me angry if they can't look at the
[ __ ] that he did yeah look what he did
if they catch you in old age they you
got away with it
yeah because now he's just going to go
to prison and retire
and if they execute him it's more like
euthanasia
yeah
because he's old
i mean they executed what are they
taking from him a couple years yeah a
couple years in prison
so would you argue like should they make
him suffer
um
well in this i don't know maybe the
current system they have now
probably wouldn't work out too well
um
in the medieval system
they would just kind of like
fasten his [ __ ] feet down to the
ground and two dudes with the [ __ ]
wood saw would stand on either side of
him and put that saw in between his legs
and [ __ ] saw him up through the
crotch you know i mean we've seen
woodcut drawings of them doing that
and uh that's what they would do to do
all right do they like need somebody to
volunteer for that because i will
you know or we could do it mexican style
we [ __ ] you know
they wouldn't even
look
taking a dude to the top of the [ __ ]
temple and cutting his heart out wasn't
a punishment it was a religious duty
i'd like to see i'm gonna ask khan to
dig up what a aztec punishment was
it's probably a lot worse
because getting your heart cut out
wasn't a punishment it was a duty
you're paying back the blood debt
but what was the
punishment and then [ __ ] uh you guys
come back with me what a punishment was
i'll remember it if it's good an aztec
punishment because you know i'm not
mexican
i
i have been you're an honorary i have i
have been declared mexican
and i have to know the mexican
punishments
i know what the cartels are doing as
punishment but i'd like to know what the
traditional mexican punishment was
and once that's once i got that [ __ ]
then i'll [ __ ] tell you whether or
not
they should be punishing these dudes
okay
let's see what they're saying
yeah i don't know man it's like
cutting off hands and feets with sharp
rocks i don't think i don't think the
mexicans did that
that's a good idea though yeah
i mean
it would have had something to do with
this with the [ __ ] obsidian blades
saws with the shiny blades and [ __ ]
[Music]
goodness gracious i know [ __ ] getting
sleepy
i know what time did i wake up i don't
know
6 30. yeah it's 12 00 at 10 o'clock now
is it it's 10 o'clock holy crap yeah
you guys i've been up all day
you want you want uh something to eat
yeah so after all that [ __ ] you're
talking to me you want me to cook for
you
you guess someone said something
see she was saying okay
i'll cook
thank you see that's how his [ __ ] are
come on man it can't this is how women
are across the world because even in
mexico and even in the united states hey
this is how they are
we have standards this is how they are
you have to abide by them
or don't
all right i mean if you don't
i'll make my own food i don't give a
[ __ ] no i got food down there i got that
pork left over from the other day
goodness gracious i got pork i got
[ __ ] up i'm fully keeping people it's
made of my own food i got pork and baked
potatoes down there that's right
but like i said you don't want to make
that then that's fine go to bed i'll
make my own food i know you all yeah i
will okay
we're all going to get food there's the
dominance right up the street i don't
need you
dominoes is probably closed
i'll give a [ __ ] i'll find some [ __ ] all
right
i don't need you all right don't get all
excited
i don't understand why you think that
you're like instrumental in my like
instrumental we talked about to my
calorie it takes a calorie for good i
will find food it's the 21st century
it's all that same [ __ ] well you know
dudes think they can just like [ __ ]
skate by on the minimal
and the grease special on minimal effort
grease packs minimalism well grievous
okay
honestly i don't need no man yeah she
don't need no man yeah no i don't okay
but you know okay
you're fun to kind of have around
sometimes all right um but you know
we've been around a long time you guys
k sure knew yeah
how long have i known you about 10 years
holy crap more than that yeah so i've
known you a long time
um you know after a time you're kind of
like
i'm [ __ ] i look i've been drinking
man yeah me too all right i need to
[ __ ] make it something to eat before
i pass up okay
oh my god we got like more than four
more than five hours laughing
you're so cute yeah
where did poogie go
she was even sick of this [ __ ] she was
like i'm out of here tammy goes how the
hell did you eat before you met tom yeah
exactly how did you um
no yeah i did i needed i made it
i don't know how i managed it
i managed to like make food for myself
and i don't know how a [ __ ] ate before
i [ __ ] appeared because
that's why you're that's why you're
laying because you don't understand that
i'm an adult i went down to publix i
went down to publix and i got some
[ __ ]
bakery made
hamburger buns and made a hamburger
before we had this [ __ ] show that
[ __ ] was good but
yeah yeah i hadn't eaten all day
well he was out where were you i had to
go to the [ __ ] yeah you were outside
yeah the escrow [ __ ] yeah he was outside
of that and then i was here dealing with
the
dudes that were pumping the
safety
so that was i dealt with them too um
not gonna i'm not judging yeah
everybody that came to the door
about the septic tank yeah
what was up with all of their teeth oh
yeah yeah nobody had they they deal in
[ __ ] human waste that's how they're
gonna look nobody had a full set of
teeth no
all of their teeth weren't always the
hell yeah i mean i understand that this
is usually they're experts they're
experts in that [ __ ] though they're i'm
not judging i'm not judging
but i every time i open the door there
was another dude there and i'm like
experts in this oh and you also have no
teeth okay awesome
okay
it's the way it is man
yeah it is i mean you know i'm just
saying nobody had any teeth yeah
they had teeth but
not all of them yeah look let's put it
that way i'm not i don't have all of my
teeth theater like my back teeth are
gonna miss the one tooth
i'm missing i'm missing uh the teeth in
the back leg fell out but
yeah one too
i don't have any justice i did this yeah
i don't have any dental insurance i
don't have any insurance i don't even
have dental insurance i bit down on some
[ __ ] and [ __ ] crack my tooth yeah
that's what happened to me too yeah um
so i'm just going to like [ __ ] roll
with it just you know
yeah ready to go
uh i guess so i can't believe it
all right yeah we love you all people
i mean you guys yep we love you guys
we're going to be back on sunday and
probably
honestly
we're going to be talking about this
[ __ ] movie right here
yeah yeah we got to watch that because i
i love this movie i don't think tom's
like ever seen it i've never seen it so
i'm like excited to show it i'll just
check it out
we'll see what is that i saw this from
rob
yeah rob sent us that rob levinson who
was in the comments earlier i don't know
if he's still there he's probably gone
but um yeah so we're gonna talk about
that on sunday when we come back friday
night
we'll be here
on our side track show that's your
baileywick are you talking about every
day is my baileywick
sure
but you can just like talk about
whatever
we talk about whatever how much money
how much percentage yeah we talk about
how much percentage did i talk about the
zodiac killer on this show
do you estimate 50
50
maybe 50
maybe they enjoyed it though
okay
yeah
they're drinking too
okay
all right man this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
tab was [ __ ] what happened it's
[ __ ] with me
oh i'm gonna shut this [ __ ] down
shut this [ __ ] down
okay
all right
all right so we'll be back friday night
talking about whatever the [ __ ] tom what
to talk about what are we talking about
goodness knows whatever that's not me
he's gonna talk about his fortress of
baltitude
go make me some food
seriously all right so
hopefully we talked about the topic
enough to justify the title of this but
you know whatever
uh all right so
thank you everybody for dropping by
thank you for super chats because i know
a lot of people uh drop some in the
comments and i love that
uh we'll be back friday evening at 5 p.m
eastern standard time
uh so thank you for dropping by
thank you very much for
hanging out with us on wednesday night
we will see you on friday
bye